that was of course always part of the
intention Mr Jeffrey Cox I'll suggest
the next office perhaps you could
promote me to uh Mr Speaker I'm more
than conscious that last time I had a
prolonged outing in this house the
verdict did not go
well and um and on this occasion uh I
intend if I may to adopt an approach uh
which I hope will be more uh to The
house's taste I want to listen to The
house's views and I shall be Mr Speaker
as accommodating as possible to the
interventions of members of this house
knowing as I do that many of them have
very strong views upon this subject and
Mr Speaker I have listened with care to
the speeches of members of this house
during the course of last week's
proceedings and I have been struck by
the heartfelt and eloquent expressions
of principled opinion that honorable
members have made and I was particularly
struck though I don't think he's in his
place this morning by the speech late
last night Mr Speaker and I commend you
and those who remained here until after
1: in the morning to complete
yesterday's proceedings by The Honorable
member for gedling who waited I think
until midnight or shortly thereafter to
begin his speech and who made the most
passionate appeal
to members of this house to understand
the value of
compromise
he told the
house that the membership of this place
confers on us not only the great
privilege of participation in the
government but the
responsibilities that go with it and Mr
Speaker in the
past when this country has faced these
kinds of
grave obstacles and impediments to
finding a way forward the members of
this place have found the resource
within
themselves to achieve a compromise and
to subordinate I will in a minute and to
subordinate the ideal
preference solution that they would like
to see
for that which commands a a degree of
consensus and Mr Speaker it is precisely
for that reason that I support the
withdrawal agreement not because I like
every element of it but for wholly
pragmatic reasons it is the necessary
means to secure our orderly
departure and unlock our future
outside the European Union Mr Speaker
since the 23rd of June
2016 we have been on a road that has led
us
ineluctably to this point one after
another this house has taken the steps
Often by overwhelming
majorities necessary to bring us to the
brink of
departure and there are now but two
steps to
take the first is this withdrawal
agreement it is the first of the two
keys that will unlock our future outside
the European Union Mr Speaker it is
sometimes said and I understand in
various circles that if you are moving
from one atmosphere pressurized
atmosphere or environment to another
it is necessary to have an
airlock and this withdrawal agreement is
the first key that will unlock the
airlock and take us into the next stage
where the second key will be the
permanent relationship treaty I give way
to The Honorable uh the attorney general
for giving way and I appreciate the
point that he has made with regards to
the value of compromise and anyone
involved in any significant negotiation
knows that compromise and the timing of
it is absolutely essential is he aware
of the most recent comments by the
retired former Irish ambassador to the
EU and a man who worked on behalf of the
Republic of Ireland on the Belfast
agreement when he said in the Sunday
business post that we the Irish
government were wrong to insist on the
back stop and softening our stance is
the only way to prevent a new no daily
is he pushing for that
outcome well of course I say to The
Honorable gentleman I would have been
infinitely happier if the European Union
had not laid down as one of its Cardinal
negotiating points and principles that
there should be a back stop but they
have done that and on the basis of their
own uh guidance to their own negotiating
principles it would have been a demand
that they always sought and we are faced
with the position as it now
is if we take this step of entering this
withdrawal agreement we will then enter
a stage where we are to negotiate the
second key to unlock our future outside
the European Union and what I commend I
will give away in a moment if honorable
members will permit
me and what I'm commending to the house
is that we take this key
and we unlock the door to that first
chamber that
airlock where we can then settle the
permanent relationship which is set out
in the political
declaration I will give way for the
right on grateful to the attorney
general for giving way and his use of
the airlock analogy is very striking but
does he realize that the reason why many
of us will vote against the deal tonight
is because on the other side of the
second airlock is a complete vacuum
about our future relationship with our
biggest nearest and most important
trading partners I I I intend to address
that very point that the my right the
right honorable gentleman addresses
because it is important I will in a
moment it is important to distinguish
between the withdrawal agreement and the
political declaration and the permanent
treaties in which the that the the
long-term relationship between this
country and the European Union will be
settled the political declaration sets
the boundaries within which those
permanent Arrangements will be
negotiated and the aims just in one
minute the aims of this withdrawal
agreement are to settle the withdrawal
agreement settles attorney general give
in a moment the withdrawal agreement
settles the outstanding issues that our
departure
creates now these are two separate and
importantly
distinguishable
functions the withdrawal agreement
commands I would submit across the house
in with the exception of two of its
areas the back stop and the political
declaration widespread consensus as to
its necessity and its wisdom I give way
to the I'm grateful to the attorney
giving way might I draw his attention to
the amendment n that is in my name that
calls upon him to be a servant of the
house to give his legal judgment whether
undertakings about the back stop and our
ability to limit it are binding in law
and therefore actionable in law
internationally might I draw might he
draw our attention to the letter he
wrote in consequence to probably may be
in consequence to the Prime Minister
saying that we actually had that legal
basis from the council's conclusions on
13th of December read the
letter right honorable gentleman is of
course right to say that I publish that
letter in the spirit of the conversation
I had with him in the spirit of the
desire the government has to make clear
as much information as this house needs
to make its judgments may I I see there
was an intervention Mr Speaker I I think
from this side I want to take I thank
him for giving me on the back stop can
you confirm um in terms of Northern
Ireland fish land in Northern island
with tar free access into the EU and tar
free access back to UK but fish from
Scotland will was subject to Tar get
into the EU and therefore Northern
Ireland is getting treated different
from Scotland in the back stop and the
Scotti secretary talked about
responsibilities the Scottish SEC said
he would resign if Northern iseland was
given different conditions to Scotland
is that not the case the Scot secretary
should consider his
position no I think I think the as I
understand what the honorable member
says I think the honorable member has
misunderstood the back stop the back
stop does not deal with the question of
fish at all it has no policy
Arrangements well I I we we I'm willing
to discuss
it gentlemen later order no just order
orderable gentleman is rather excitable
today the Attorney General yields to
none in his courtesy in the house but it
is not reasonable even to expect of the
attorney with his formidable intellect
the capacity to start to try to respond
to an intervention that he hasn't heard
when he's dealing with one that he
has I will in a if I say so I'm very
happy to discuss the matter with the The
Honorable gentleman afterwards if if you
would wish give away to my
most grateful to my right honorable
friend does he agree with me that the
non- selection of the amendment standing
in my name and the amendment standing in
the name of my honorable friend the
member for westre the chairman of the
Northern Iron select committee makes it
the government's challenge this
afternoon harder to convince those of us
who are still concerned about the
implications of the back stop and what
does he think can replace those two
amendments well I'm grateful to my right
honorable friend I I have to say that
I've never underestimated the challenge
that I face this morning um or or or
that the government faces but what I
would say as I shall come to in due
course is that I have reflected deeply
as he knows upon this question of the
back stop and and I have reached the
conclusion that it is a risk that it is
acceptable to take even having regard to
The Perils that it does involve if it
were to become permanent and the
questions that it unquestionably raises
in connection with the union with
Northern Ireland you give way on that
point I I will give way to my honorable
friend I'm very grateful to the attorney
for giving way will he confirm that
while the political declaration is
aspirational in style it is not legally
binding in international law but the
withdrawal agreement as a draft
International treaty would be F fully
binding in international La will he
further confirm that he's offering the
house an embarrassment of riches after
months of debating the back stop we now
have the a loock as well is the
government so desperate that in the
final analysis they're now offering the
House of Commons a buy one get one
free no my my my honorable friend there
what I mean the the airlock metaphor is
indicated to demonstrate the distin
that exists between the withdrawal
agreement that has been negotiated over
thousands of hours which is as he
rightly says is the legally binding text
and the only legally binding text and it
was only ever empowered under article 50
to deal with historic issues outstanding
matters that otherwise would have
catapulted uh citizens businesses
governments into legal uncertainty
Mr Speaker I do want to make a bit of
progress if I may because it's important
to look at what the withdrawal agreement
does we should not underestimate the
complexity the legal complexity of our
disentanglement from
45 years of legal integration it has
taken two years and thousands of hours
of detailed and arduous negotiation some
of it highly Tech
to produce the
585 pages of the most minute
consideration of the possibilities which
no deal in legal terms would create for
the millions of people who depend upon
the certainty of the legal system and
rules that we have hitherto been subject
to I will in a moment it provides for
the orderly and predictable and legally
certain wind ing down of our obligations
and involvement in the legal systems of
the EU if we do not
legislate for that legal certainty as a
matter of law alone thousands of
contracts thousands of transactions
thousands of administration
administrative proceedings judicial
procceedings in the European Union in
this country will be plunged into legal
uncertainty it would be the height of
irresponsibility for any legislator to
contemplate with
equinity such a
situation if you were a litigant in a
court if you were dependent upon having
concluded a contract on the basis of EU
law and you found yourself suddenly with
the rug pulled from under you not
knowing what your legal obligations
would be you would say to this
house in a moment in a moment I will
take interventions you would say to this
house what are you playing
at what are you doing you are not
children in the playground you are
legislators and it is your
job in a minute I will I promise the
right honorable lady I will give away I
intend to take many interventions in the
course of this speech you we are playing
with people's lives we are here debating
the effects on on legal
continuity 45 years of legal in I will
to the right on
lady
45 years of legal
integration has brought our two legal
systems into a situation where they are
organically
linked and it is the same in medical
terms to appeal to those who have a
medical
background as if we were to separate
from a living
organism with all its arteries and veins
a central part A a living organ from
this body politic and I say to the house
I say to the house we cannot
underestimate the
complexity of what we are embarked upon
doing now these these I can't resist
giving way to the
honor the order
the Attorney General as per usual is
addressing the house with a remarkable
combination of the intellect of Einstein
and the eloquence of demostenes I hope
that he will not caval if I just gently
remind him because we're all enjoying it
enormously that there are oh well I'm
certainly enjoying it there are 71
honorable and right honorable members
who wish to contribute I know he'll
tailor his contribution to take account
of that important fact Mr Chris Bryant
the thing is that the Attorney General
is making a very good point which a lot
of us agree with which is legal
uncertainty is the worst possible
outcome which is why some of us are so
angry that this vote was taken away from
us in December because there isn't a
single chance of the government getting
the necessary legislation through by the
29th of March even if he were to get his
way today can he confirm that if the
vote is not won tonight they will have
to defer leaving the European Union on
the 29th of March well first thing I say
to The Honorable gentleman he knows the
affection I hold for him he it's not my
way what I'm asking the house now to
do understanding the heartfelt
passionate and sincere views held on all
sides and I listened all last night to
the speeches on the other side as well
as on this side that we must come
together now as mature legislators to
ask ourselves what are the fun mental
objections if there are in to this
withdrawal agreement now whether or not
it can be done by March the 29th or
whether it can't doesn't affect the
decision we has to take today which is
do we opt for
order or do we choose
chaos and that is the decision the house
made now I'm going to I shall take I
shall take the SMB if I may don't
remember forgive me mentioned that there
are two problems with the deal and he
admitted there are two problems with the
deal it's a bit like the yachtsman who
when seeing his yacht on the Rock said
that anchor chain was great only two
links were bad and that is what he is
given the house tonight it is a disaster
and well he knows it now the second
point to the member from kilar and Lon
he misunderstood the point in fish it's
not fish being caught it's fish as a
commodity once caught and if it's landed
in Northern Ireland it is at a more
advantaged position for export to Europe
than fish caught and then landed in
Scotland for export Europe and he should
recognize that and be straight with the
members of kar L which I'm sure he was
trying to be but misunderstood the
point I wonder if I might
don't order order order in terms of good
form it's the norm for the minister
occupying the bench of the person making
the speech to offer some response before
taking a further intervention it may be
a perun one but that's the norm Mr
Speaker I had wanted to take them
together I say I say to The Honorable
gentlemen there is if he is referring in
relation to Northern Ireland to the
quota that is to be agreed by The Joint
Committee for
landing well I I I would need to examine
the issue I I'm not certain The
Honorable gentle is right but I again
have offered to discuss it I wonder if I
may take the honorable grateful to the
right honorable and learned gentleman
for giving way he says he's much
exercised about legal certainty so can I
ask him about paragraph two of his
letter yesterday about the exchange of
letters he said that the letters from
the Council would have a legal force in
international law and be relevant and
cognizable in the interpretation of the
agreement albeit they do not alter the
fundamental meaning of the withdrawal
agreements Provisions he as a senior
lawyer like me will know that in a
competition between the letter of
assurance and the withdrawal agreement
the withdrawal agreement as the
international treaty will Triumph that's
the case isn't
it well let me say straight away as my
letter says these these these assurances
in my view make a difference to the
political question that each of us have
to take but they do not as I said in the
letter as the I'm going to ask the
accept take the intervention of the ROM
gentleman they do not affect the legal
equation and I I'm grateful to the
attorney general for giving away and
just on this point about the legal
effect isn't it the case that the Prime
Minister said 5 weeks ago today in fact
about legally binding a insurances that
what he has just said confirms the fact
that legally binding insurances haven't
been achieved and that's the tragedy of
where we find ourselves in now after 5
weeks and in fact from our point of view
the thing that would have been essential
to get this matter through the house
with our support wasn't even asked for
which is the changes that would
eliminate the Trap of the back stop here
here first let me say to the honorable
my honorable friend the legal equation
Remains the Same the assurances are
binding in the sense that in
international law they would be a
legally interpretive binding
interpretive tool what what they do not
do is Alter the fundamental meaning of
the provisions of the withdrawal
agreement in that respect he is right
but and and and I need to come if I may
to the F first the first point that I
want to make to the house is let us
examine the rest of the agreement first
do we do we have I will in a minute do
we have give I will I will in a minute
do we have before us a
sensible the withdrawal agreement a
sensible settling of these critical
historical obligations for continuing
transactions to resolve for millions of
people the legal uncertainty of of
taking ourselves away from the highly
integrated legal system in which we were
organically linked and indeed part of
now the 585 pages I must make some
progress I will take many more but on
the
585 Pages what does it
do first it secures the right
of 1 million British citizens living in
the European Union and 3 million
European Union citizens living in the
United
Kingdom what are we say to say to
them if this house
today does not take the advantage of
resolving and giving them the certainty
of knowing that their position is
enshrined in fundamental law I will I
will in
a it settles the bills it legally allows
for the orderly completion of these
thousands of continuing transactions of
judicial proceedings accounting
procedures that otherwise would be
thrown into a legal void and it provides
for a period of adjustment for people
and for businesses of the next 21 months
extendable up to 2 years to allow our
businesses and our individual citizens
to adjust to the new realities that is
what I mean by
airlock it's quite simple an airlock
enables the human body to adjust to the
new pressure it will face when it exits
the airlock and this period allows the
transition and adjustment of this
country to enter into the bright new
world that we will enter when we leave
the European
Union so so I say I say to the house
with all due difference and
respect these parts of the withdrawal
agreement we all of us would regard
Would we not as
essential in order to create the bridge
for our departure from the European
Union give way to the I'm most grateful
to my right on friend for giving away he
speaks of the legal complexities of the
withdrawal agreement mayor and he also
speaks of a coming together may I refer
him to the advice that he gave to the
Prime Minister on 13th November in his
capacity as attorney general and on page
two paragraph 8 he said and I quote for
regulatory purposes Great Britain is
essentially treated as a third country
by Northern Ireland for goods passing
from Great Britain into Northern Ireland
how can he on the one hand talk about
coming together yet his own advice to
the Prime Minister talks of anything
but but but I I I understand the force
of what uh the The Honorable gentleman
says but precisely the same prevails in
numerous EU countries for the purposes
of uh regulation the Canary Islands are
treated as a third country to Spain it
is it is not for the purposes of
regulations alone single Market
regulations alone there are examples all
around the world where there are
regulatory differences between
individual parts of the jurisdiction of
sovereign states may I take the
honorable ladies
intervention thank you
Mr thank you Mr Speaker
I'm very grateful to the Attorney
General on a previous occasion which I
thought was a magnificent performance in
early December attorney general um you
used a very very striking description of
the back stop you described the back
stop as an instrument of peill an
instrument I did not Mr
Speaker the Attorney General you're
quite right the Attorney General
described the back stop as an instrument
of pin an instrument of pain as much for
the European Union as for the United
Kingdom that is very strong language
indeed attorney general an instrument of
pain for the European Union would the
Attorney General take some time to
explain that in detail I think that' be
very helpful immensely obliged to The
Honorable lady because that that is
precisely what I want to move on to if
we
accept and I urge this house to accept
that effectively 90% of this withdrawal
agreement of its Pages some 450 of the
585 in fact settle these crucial
outstanding matters that no sensible
person could doubt require to be settled
in order to affect our departure that
leaves the two grounds of objection
which have been Advanced and I repeat I
listen with great care to speeches on
the opposition side of the house the two
grounds of obje ction to this agreement
and declaration so may I come to those
two grounds of objection before I do may
I simply say that there are some typical
misconceptions about the withdrawal
agreement it is said for example that
the
cju retains jurisdiction over our courts
once the Tim limited obligations have
wound down that the withdrawal agreement
settles it does
not it does not it does not it does not
how many times do I have to say it to
my does
not the fact of the moment the fact of
the matter is that once once these
obligations have wound down the cju will
have no
jurisdiction over the resolution of
disputes between individuals citizens
businesses in our country this is what
our people voted for and we by adopting
this withdrawal agreement can give it to
them secondly it is said secondly it is
said that we will be permanently Bound
by EU rules but we will not the fact of
the matter is the withdrawal agreements
obligations are time inherently Tim
limited and once they have wound out the
EU rules will no longer have effect in
this country I take I I I I I think I
take the honorable gentleman then I will
take my right honorable friend is making
his case with his usual eloquence but on
that specific point and his point about
airlocks airlocks need exit mechanisms
and in the absence of legal certainty
that we could leave the uh unilaterally
leave the back stop something which my
Amendment F addresses and I will be
pressing what certainty is there that
the EU doesn't drag negotiations on so
that we could still with an extension to
the transition period be discussing
these issues in four or five years
time here in lies the critical question
that we all have to confront in
connection with the back stop but before
I answer it I take the honorable
gentleman thank the uh the attorney for
for giving way and while he pauses for
breath can I too take him to the airlock
in traveling through an airlock it helps
to have a supply of air in this
particular case I would urge
conditionality that we don't agree to
write out a check for £39 billion of
hard earned taxpayers money unless or
until a future relationship agreement is
agreed that is legally binding that
would give us greater leverage in the
negotiation and enable us to deliver
serious value for the British
taxpayer you you you cannot say to
somebody to whom you owe money I'm not
going to pay you my debt unless you give
me something else it is not attractive
it is not consistent with the honor of
this country and it is not consistent
with the rule of law
and the fact of the matter is the
withdrawal agreement settles those
historic obligations now may I come on
to the critical question and the
challenge that was let that was let I I
will do in a moment let me come on
because time is short and I need I need
to move on the back stop there is I
would suggest to the house an
inconsistency between those who say in
this house that the EU will do what is
in its interests and that it will
cynically ENT trp Us in the back
stop they have said and can anybody
doubt that this is true that the only
real thing that is in the best interests
of Any Nation or any organization of
Nations is to have cordial relations of
good willll and cooperation with your
neighbors history has taught that over
the
centuries to ENT trp Us in the back stop
against the overwhelming political will
of this nation would have precisely the
opposite effect of cultivating those
cordial relations of Goodwill between
ourselves and the European Union any
future relationship will depend upon
good faith and Good Will and these are
insurances which I accept do not have
effect upon the legal equation in my
view represents solemn statements of the
president and the council and the
commission which to breach would be
incompatible with the European Union's
continued standing in international
relations and forums but even if even if
I must make some progress even if I'm
wrong about that let us just exam what
the honorable lady asked me to look at
what is the position in the backstop
first the European Union no Belgian
lawyer no Belgian lawyer there's a
there's a Freudian slip Mr Speaker no
Belgian fisherman no French
fisherman no Danish Fisher no Dutch
fisherman will be allowed to point the
prow of their
one meter into British Waters under the
back
stop they will have no access to the
rich hunting grounds that for decades
they have exploited perfectly lawfully
because the back stop provides them with
no legal basis to do so now I asked the
house I asked the house to reflect no
why do you think why does the house
think
that the Rumblings and Hollow
thunderings of concern are emanating
from the cils of the
Kor they have 10,000 Gile on the streets
of Paris and elsewhere but if their
fishermen are told if they no I must
make break this if their fishermen are
told that they cannot catch a single
cordor place in the waters of the United
Kingdom they will place intense pressure
upon the European Union so I say to The
Honorable lady that fact alone affords a
real issue for the member states but on
agriculture we do not pay we do not have
any further participation in the common
agricultural policy under the back stop
and we pay though we we get tariff free
access to the single Market we pay not
one penny for that system now I say to
my honorable friends I must make
progress I say to my I say to my
honorable friend I I will in a minute I
say to my I will for the right on
gentlemen I I I say to my honorable
friends as I say to members of the House
opposite the EU will have to set up
entirely different
systems legal administrative in order to
set up the Customs Union that is
enshrined within the back stop yet
Britain will pay not one penny of
contribution to those complex
administrative and Technical Systems
which the EU will on their side alone
have to
finance how long does the house really
think the European Union would wish to
go on paying for a bespoke arrangement
in which they are paying tens of
millions of Euros to sustain a customs
Union that is simply on their own
admission a temporary Arrangement but
even if that was wrong there were the
regulatory Provisions under the back
stop they are standard non regression
Clauses they exist in free trade
agreements all around the world they
provide us with the ability if we wish
to take it of being flexible about the
means by which we achieve the outcomes
because all they do are require us to
maintain parity of Standards with the
position we had when we left the
European Union therefore it does give us
regulatory flexibility if we we wish to
Avail ourselves of it and the European
Union are faced with not a penny being
paid with tariff free access to the
Customs Union with not having to obey
the regulatory uh uh laws that
theorder order I have been tolerant thus
far and I enjoy enormously the
performances of the right honorable and
L gentlemen but this
perambulation is very uncommon and IR
reg and the right honorable anded
gentleman must face the house we want to
see him and to get directly the benefit
of his mous tones the Attorney General
you you upgrade me entirely justly and I
AP I apologize well my rable yes I will
take the my rable
friends
everything that the Attorney General
says about the back stop may be true but
he knows that many of our honorable
friends are deeply concerned about this
and we want an end date I'm not asking
him for an answer now but I see the
Prime Minister there I see the chief
whip there is an amendment on the order
paper now which has been selected by the
speaker which could unite the party or
most of it it is a compromise if we can
have an end day to the back stop then we
can move forward I do not ask for an
answer now but I beg the government over
the next 6 hours to consider whether
they should not accept these amendments
because they would try and unlock this
process and get it through Parliament
here well can I say to my uh right
honorable friend um the amendment which
he has uh um has put down is one that
would uh in my judgment um not be
compatible with our international law
obligations now he may know that he may
accept that it's certainly my view that
it would not not be and therefore would
be likely not to be seen by the European
Union as ratification and certainly
would raise serious question marks over
it so I say to my uh ronom friend we
need to examine this without the
Indulgence of believing that there is
any other easy solution the fact of the
matter is looked at as a it's sometimes
said that the problem with the back stop
is it will not enable us to walk away
that is true except in this
regard the question is what would be we
been walking away from would the other
side regard it as something they would
not wish to wait walk away from or would
it be an Embrace that they would like to
escape as well and if my honorable and
right honorable friends and if members
of the House on all sides come to the
conclusion both sides come to the
conclusion as I would urge them to do
and as I have reached after many hours
of reflection that it would be as The
Honorable lady said as instrument as
painful to the European Union as it
would be to
us then it is a risk weighed against the
other risks that we should take if the
consequence is something worse now I
want to come on if I may say if I I will
give right to the
H thank you Mr speak could I take the
attor of General backa some time ago
when he was saying that there was a
commitment to give £39 billion an
obligation a legal obligation to give 39
billion to the EU despite the fact that
we've been a net contributor of more
than 210 billion since the EU started
could he explain to me on what legal
advice he gives that because the House
of Lords said there was absolutely no
legal obligation honorable my honorable
friend is is wrong the House of Lords
did not say that the House of Lords
committee said there was none in EU law
the House of Lords said there may well
be public international law obligations
and the argument that there were no
public international law obligations in
my judgment and I've tested my judgments
as I always do on matters of law with
some very distinguished lawyers of
expertise in this field is that the
basis for not having public
international law obligations is flimsy
at best and the House of Lords committee
did not say there were no public
International obligations now I must
move on because the next thing I must
deal with is what are the
Alternatives what I will come to my
right I will come to my rable
friend it's it I will come to my rable
friend um but but I need to make some
progress the orderly exit from the
European Union would always require a
withdrawal agreement along these lines
no alternative option now being canvased
in the house would not require this
withdrawal agreement and now the back
stop so let us be clear whatever
solution may be fashioned if this vote
were if this motion were defeated and
this deal defeated this withdrawal
agreement will have to
return in much the same form with much
the same content and
therefore and therefore there is no
serious or credible objection that has
been Advanced by any party to the
withdrawal agreement now it has been
said last last week by the the right
honorable and learned gentleman for
halin and some pankas that we should
have negotiated a full Customs Union
with aay within the political
declaration and there would have been no
need for a back stop because the
agreement could then have been concluded
within the transition period but he
knows and it is clear that the European
Union are unwilling and regard
themselves as Bound by their own law not
to have entered into detailed
negotiations
on the permanent relationship treaties
there they were never going to do it
their own negotiating guidelines said
that they would not therefore there was
always going to be this withdrawal
agreement a political declaration
setting out a framework and months
thereafter if not years of detailed
negotiation in relation to any final
resting place that any political
declaration might have I will come to
the honorable right honorable gentlemen
if if I meant I I will give way in time
now let us let us just examine the point
let us examine the
point the question then is what is the
basis for the
objection to this withdrawal agreement
because I yes I will I will to the
attorney for giving way Mr Speaker he
and I both members of the criminal bar
though I was certainly ever in the
attorney's League we both understand the
art of negotiation you can't be a
criminal barrist or indeed any lawyer
unless you understand negotiation now he
advances the case for this withdrawal
agreement on the basis that it's reached
some pragmatic consensus but I suggest
to him that a good negotiation is
something that settles things that a
majority can positively support the
problem I suggest with this agreement is
that it doesn't settle anything and it
doesn't satisfy the vast majority in
fact it satisfies no one properly in
this house well I I I I I I say that is
because I would respectfully suggest to
my right honorable friend that the
expectations of the withdrawal agreement
have been far too unrealistic the
withdrawal agreement let us hear it from
this is a serious issue and I asked just
for the Indulgence of the house I know
I've got to give way I think to the to
the right lady I asked for the
Indulgence of the house in making what I
hope is a serious point if the house
doesn't ackn accept it then fine but let
me at least make it because it the
withdrawal agreement and the back stop
are the first and necessary precondition
of any solution now I know that my The
Honorable uh ladies and gentlemen on the
opp on the other side have real concerns
have real concerns about the content of
the political declaration and about the
issue of the safeguarding of Rights
particularly I think I listened to the
honorable lady last night I think it was
The Honorable lady who spoke of who
spoke of this the enshrinement of
environmental rights and environmental
laws and so on but the political
declaration would never have been able
to have secure detailed legally binding
text on those matters and those are
matters that will be discussed and
negotiated in the polit in the next
stage of negotiation it makes no sense
to reject the opportunity of order now
of certainty now because in a future
treaty members of this house are unhappy
that they don't have guarantees about
what will be in it what will be in that
treaty governed by the parameters set
out by the political declaration that I
need to come to in a moment will be
negotiated over the next 21 months and
this government has made this pledge to
this house that on these negotiations it
will take fully the opinion of this
house in all of the departmental areas
over which that negotiation will take
place now I wonder well I hope it is a
point of order rather than a point of
frustration but I await with baited
breath
and and you'll be aware the attorney has
now spoken for 49 minutes um I
understand there are a substantial
number of colleagues who wish to speak
today could you tell us how many
colleagues are waiting to speak and how
what approximate time people are going
to get for card South B as always is
trying to be helpful but in fact it was
really a point of frustration the fact
is as I have previously advised the
house no fewer than 71 honorable and
right honorable members are seeking to
catch my eye so there are notable
constraints to which I don't wish myself
now to to add but of which I feel sure
the attorney will take account set
myself a clear time limit but I am
anxious to take
into you really can't win I I'm trying
to take as many interventions as I can
and I'm going to take the right
honorable gentlemen get the back stop uh
I I'm very grateful to the attorney uh
for giving way he talks about the danger
of setting unrealistic expectations but
it was the Prime Minister sitting next
to him who promised in her Lancaster
house speech that we would have agreed
the future relationship before exit day
and secondly he makes great play of this
implementation period it's of no use in
some respects if you don't know what it
is you are transitioning to he knows we
will have a different European
Parliament a different European Council
a different European president there two
other presidents that will all have
changed by the time the future
relationship is due to be settled well
let me say we we must start from where
we are now it's easy to say we shouldn't
have started from here the political
declaration does set out clear
parameters about the future treaty first
written into the DNA of the political
declaration are two Cardinal principles
it is not a legal document but no
political declaration would ever have
been a legal document by
definition you cannot have under EU law
a finally negotiated text with all the
legal detail now let me come to the two
clear conditions in the political
declaration I am going to complete
within just a few minutes let me come to
the Future declaration first no free
movement you cannot would theable lady I
really can't your own colleagues are
saying I'm taking too long I really must
set round up now the position is the
political declaration has two clear
conditions first
first that there will be no free
movement you cannot belong to the single
Market without participating in the Four
Freedoms therefore we will have a deal
which will admit of a spectrum of of
Landing places where we will not belong
to the single Market secondly no I must
now make progress secondly there will be
an
independent trade policy you cannot have
a customs Union certainly not one that
is not a bespoke one without having
while having an independent trade policy
now the labor front bench say that they
want a customs Union with a
say that would be the first time if it
were ever negotiable the first time that
the European Union had allowed a third
country to have any say over the
commercial policy therefore it is a
fantasy a complete fiction they also say
they want a strong single Market deal
formerly the exact same benefits no with
with no free movement well that is
exactly what the government wants they
want a clear strong deep relationship
with the European Union with no free
movement so I say of The Honorable
ladies and gentlemen on the other side
as well as
the all right
since I thank the right honorable and
learned gentleman for giving way he's
been speaking for almost an hour and for
almost that entire time he has been
addressing the concerns of a wing of his
party rather than the concerns of this
house this week two Amendments have have
been passed neither with the support of
this government to the finance bill and
to the business motion both of those
Amendments have made clear that the view
of this house is to avoid a No Deal
brexit that is the priority of this
house not the issue of the back stop
that he's been addressing for the last
hour so instead of trying to unite his
party as The Honorable gentleman for
gains has urged him to do will he not
try now to unite the country the right
thing by this country and W out leaving
the European Union on the 29th of March
without a
deal I say to the right honorable lady
she can eliminate no deal today all she
has to do is vote for this one and the
reality is and the reality is it is the
height of irr responsibility for the
party opposite claiming to be a party of
government to plunge millions of our
citizens into legal uncertainty of the
type because of a factitious trump top
basis of opposition whereas the real
strategy is to drive this government and
house onto the Rocks create the maximum
chaos and to create the conditions for a
general election we know the game I say
it's as clear as day and so I say I say
to the
house
Zen house must calm itself it's an early
stage of our proceedings the attorney
general and so I say to the house with
the greatest of respect we must seize
this opportunity now this is the key by
which we unlock the first of two our
future outside the European Union I
believe it's an exciting future I
believe the opportunity for this house
to hold the pen on 40% of our laws from
environment through to agriculture and
fishing should excite us as an
opportunity to do good in this
country but if we do not and let us not
forget that there are many outside this
house as well as in who wish to
frustrate the great end to which the
people of this country committed us on
the 23rd of June
17.4 million of them in hundreds of
constituencies regardless of party voted
to part company with a political
structure that no longer commanded their
Ascent we should be deeply grateful
because in other ages and other places
such a moment could only have been
achieved by means that all of us here
would deplore but we should not
underestimate the significance of the
moment because it was expressed
peacefully by the ballot here Mr Speaker
if we approve this agreement we know
that we shall leave the EU on March the
29th in an orderly way and can commence
negotiation of the permanent treaties
this agreement and the accompanying
political declaration are the two keys
that unlock the demand of the electorate
that we should repatriate control over
vast areas of our laws that hitherto
have been in the exclusive legislative
competence of the EU if we do not take
that first step then history will judge
us harshly because we will be plunged
into uncertainty and those who wish to
prevent our departure if this vote fails
today we'll seek to promote the
conclusion that it is all to
difficult and that the government should
ask the electorate to think again that
is why former Prime Ministers and their
Spin Doctors and all their great pandrum
of the past are joining the chorus to
condemn this deal for they know this
deal is the key there is no other
destroy it in some form or other the
only practicable deal and the path to
brexit becomes shroudy in
obscurity and if Mr
Speaker we should be so deceived that we
should permit that and when historians
came to write of this moment future ages
will Marvel that the huge repatriation
of powers that this agreement entailed
of immigration
Fisheries agriculture the supremacy of
our laws and courts was rejected because
somehow it did not seem enough and
because of the Northern Ireland back
stop Nick Thomas
Simmons thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I'm of course happy to open this
debate for the opposition today and
follow the attorney general I'm of
course great ful for his remarks over
the past
hour I was also pleased to see his a
letter to the Prime Minister yesterday
giving advice on the back stop protocol
and the latest exchange of letters and
indeed to receive it without the need
for a contempt motion on this
occasion Mr Speaker I stood at the
dispatch box when the Attorney General
gave his statement on the legal position
on the 3rd of December and he sent the
members of this house and I quote it is
time they grew up and got real and even
said to my right honorable friend and
learned friend the M for camberwell and
pekham there is nothing to see here but
after the government was founding
contempt of Parliament and published his
advice the next day it turned out there
was everything to see here and it was
the government that needed to get real
and let's be clear about first of all
what the Attorney General himself has
advised what did he say on the back stop
protocol despite statements in the
protocol that it is not intended to be
permanent and the clear intention of the
parties that it should be replaced by
alternative permanent Arrangements in
international law the protocol would
endure indefinitely until a superseding
agreement took its place in whole or in
part as set out therein which parts of
the back stop more likely than others to
remain even in the event of a trade deal
being agreed he's never actually told us
he added there are numerous references
in the protocol to its temporary nature
but there is no indication of how long
such temporary Arrangements could last
and on Northern irland incidentally the
attorney general and these are his own
words GB is essentially treated as a
third country by ni for goods passing
from GB into ni his own words the
Attorney General even said the protocol
appears to assume that the negotiations
will result in an agreement Mr Speaker
are we in this house to assume given the
conduct of these negotiations that this
government will be able to negotiate a
full future trade deal in time for the
protocol not to come into
effect Nick mcferson the former
permanent Secretary of the treasur he
disagrees actually with the Secretary of
State for the environment food and Rural
Affairs I know he's not a fan of experts
but perhaps you'll just listen to this
one for a moment who said there is no
way the UK will negotiate a trade deal
with the EU by December 2020 even 2022
is optimistic mid 2020s more likely now
as a matter of law as the shadow law
officer I ask myself is there anything
to prevent the back stop from becoming
permanent as a matter of international
law no there is not it would endure
indefinitely pending a future
Arrangement being arranged not not my
words the words of the Attorney General
in this act now I have to State Mr
speaker clearly for this house that we
as an opposition and the labor party are
committed to the Good Friday agreement
it's the agreement that my predecessor
now Lord Murphy of tvine who sits in the
other place helped to negotiate when he
chaired the peace talks it is one of the
single greatest achievements of any
government since
1945 we on these bench are committed to
the longlasting peace that's been
achieved since 1998 and care deeply
about the livelihoods the communities
those people who live on the Northern
island island border but our position is
that a permanent Customs Union with a
sayian external trade deals a strong
single Market relationship and
guarantees on rights and protections
that have rendered a back stop
unnecessary and let me be clear as to
what this back stop is I'll have name is
single other country which is in a
customs Union with the EU which has a
say over trade yals is this not an
unprecedented legal and political
novelty of the kind which is quite
rightly called a
unicorn well I I Mr Speaker I let me be
clear that I would want our own
arrangers but he's asking me to give him
an example of that particular
theoretical possibility it's not one I
wish to emulate but turkey is actually
one of them if he actually looked had a
look at it and secondly secondly let let
me let me just no no I'll respond to
this let me respond and let me actually
respond to the Secretary of State on
this he will vote this evening for a
back stop that itself contains a bespoke
customs
Arrangement the Union by let me actually
be clear but I'll be clear but it has a
sign and there's the difference you see
is the Secretary of State should admit
now let me be absolutely let me be clear
no I'm not no I'm not wrong and and let
me be clear as well as to why this back
stop in and of itself prepares provides
only a bare bone Customs Union this is
why we on this side of the house can't
support it it has I'm happy to wait
thank I'm very grateful day to The
Honorable gentleman thank you Mr Speaker
may I just take a moment to inform the
honorable gentleman and I'm sure he
already knows that the vast majority of
farmers and businesses and fishermen and
Community leaders in North n strongly
support this deal negotiated by the
government and I heard the warm words
from The Honorable gentleman about the
support for the Good Friday agreement
but I tell you actions speak louder than
words and by voting down the brexit deal
tonight it's a clear signal the lior
party does not care about the
consequences to the Good Friday
AG I do have great respect for The
Honorable lady but I fundamentally
disagree with her final remark uh there
because there is a commitment to the
Good Friday agreement on this side and I
can tell her that we in my constituency
of tor great pride in that agreement
which was the peace talks were shared by
my predecessor throughout that time we
have great respect for it and want to
protect it but let me be clear as to why
this back stop the bespoke back stop
actually the bespoke Customs Union
within the back stop we cannot support
it has no proper governance firms based
in Britain rather than Northern Ireland
would be outside the single Market
facing barriers to trade and the
protections for workers and the
environment are unenforceable non reget
R and Clauses that would see the United
Kingdom fall behind over time in short
it falls well away from what labor has
argued for so what other roots are there
for us to exit the back stop now I ask
the Attorney General about International
treaties where the UK has no unilateral
right to terminate and his response was
to direct me to the Vienna convention on
the law of treaties now even if applied
and incidentally it only applies between
states the Attorney General knows this
is clutching at straws first it is said
we could argue that the EU was not using
best Endeavors to complete our future TR
trade Arrangement and that this
constituted a material breach under
article 60 of the convention now what
has the Attorney General said on the
back stop protocol article 2.1 he said
it's the duty of the parties to
negotiate a superseding agreement that
must be done using best Endeavors
pursuant to article 184 the withdrawal
agreement this is subject also to the
duty of good faith which is both implied
by international law and expressly
created by Article 5 of the withdrawal
agreement but Mr Speaker and I quote the
duty of good faith and to use best
Endeavors is a legally enforceable duty
but there is no doubt it is difficult to
prove again not my words Mr Speaker the
words of the Attorney General he knows
that's the case second apparently we
could try and argue there's been a
fundamental change of circumstances
under article 62 of the Vienna
convention but we could not credibly
argue that entering the back stop with
such a change in circumstan when it is
clearly set out in the withdrawal
agreement and the way it is to say that
a scenario that we are all well aware of
and debating now represents a
fundamental departure does not wash with
anyone as the Attorney General knows
what he is advising on Mr speaker is not
so much an airlock but a padlock and
it's a padlock with two keyh holders of
which we are only one now I ask myself
what changed over Christmas what's been
achieved by the delaying of the
vote uh I mean the Secretary of State
for the Department of the environment
food and Rural Affairs told us as I
recall on the morning of the vote that
quote it was definitely 100% going to
happen and we all know what happened
after that no wonder Mr Speaker it's one
of many incidents in this process that's
led many of us to disbelieve so much
that the government says but the prime
minister in her statement later that day
said I have heard those concerns I will
do everything I possibly can to secure
further
assurances the leader of the House said
the Prime Minister has been clear that
when the vote will take place when she
believes she has the legal assurances
the parliament needs that the back stop
will not be permanent I mean the
international trade secret went even
further so it' be very difficult to
support the deal without changes to the
back stop and wasn't sure the cabinet
would agree for it to be put to the
House of Commons what actually happened
the prime minister went to the European
Council and couldn't persuade leaders to
give her the conclusion conclusion she
wanted the Christmas break came and went
then we had a document with commitments
on Northern Island that did nothing to
change the legal text and letters
appeared yesterday between the Prime
Minister on the one hand and the
president of the European Council and
the president of the commission on the
other the I'll
give wa think he's actually making a
case about trust and that's actually
what we are all and the countries being
asked to do is this great leap of of
trust of leap of faith because we don't
know what our future trading and
security relationships are going to be
and the sorry story is that all the way
through the last 2 and a half years
we've had a series of promises that
haven't been delivered on and will he
agree with me that he will remember for
example being told at that very dispatch
Box by a government Minister the then
Secretary of State for leaving and
exiting the European Union that we would
have a deal before we left that would
convey the exact same benefits of our
current membership of the single market
and the Customs Union that's what's
troubling people this is a blindfolded
brexit that's why people won't vote for
it Thomas The Honorable L's entirely
right I'm sure she will have noted the
inconsistent
here because the Attorney General said
in his speech only a few minutes ago
that we couldn't expect to have anything
detailed negotiated in at this stage yet
that's precisely what the government has
previously promised how on Earth are we
supposed to believe these conflicting
things I'll give way toor that is
exactly I'm grateful to him giv way that
is exactly the point at heart here in
this trust the attorney general just uh
committed the EU to not agreeing to
Future trade degs in response to our
request for Customs Union but he refused
to say and the government is still
refusing to say if they will commit to
the Customs Union in that future trade
agreement if they did that we would not
have the need for this discussion around
the back stop or this matter of trust
which The Honorable lady has just
discussed friend raises the point raises
the point about the real vague nature of
the political declaration which I will
come back to in a
moment they're queuing up I I'll give
right gentan first and I I will need to
make some progress we've talked talked
about trust and Promises which are vely
important and we promised uh to deliver
on the outcome of the referendum it was
this house that gave the people the
referendum in the first place we passed
our sovereignty to the people and we
said and we promised that we would
deliver on that verdict the verdict was
to leave the European Union and does he
not believe that if we will fail to do
so that would be seen as one of the
greatest betrayals of trust in this
country Mr Speaker my constituency like
I think the honorable gentleman
voted to leave the EU and I voted to
trigger Article 15 in good faith in line
with their wishes and I sincerely hoped
there would been something significantly
better before this house that we could
all have supported and gone around I'm
going to make some progress I will give
way again in a moment let me make some
progress uh and I want to come really to
the letter that's been sent by
presidents junker and Tusk on page two
because it said this the European
Council also said that if the back stop
were nevertheless to be triggered it
would only apply temporarily unless
until it is superseded by a subsequent
agreement then again they spoke about
best Endeavors back stop in place for as
long as strictly necessary but we all
know that represents no difference at
all to the position the Attorney General
advised on back in December we ask are
there any changes changes to the
withdrawal agreement text none changes
to the possible interpretations none
changes to the reassurances available
none and what did the Attorney General
say himself in his latest letter to the
Prime Minister about the council's
conclusions their impact on the Northern
Island protocol and I quote they do not
alter the fundamental meaning of its
Provisions as I advise them to be on
13th of November 2018 to coin a phrase
Mr Speaker nothing has
changed I I I want to make some progress
Mr Speaker I made clear in answer to an
intervention my own constituency of
tvine voted to leave and I respect
everyone who voted in that referendum in
good faith and in line with their wishes
I voted to trigger article 50 to trigger
the process of withdrawal and I wish
there was a withdrawal agreement worthy
of wide support across this house I wish
there was a political declaration that
actually did point away to a future that
secured our economy our jobs and our
futures and wasn't the meaningless text
the leap in the dark that it actually is
now more than ever we need to unite the
country away from a fractur debate to a
shared vision of our future the Prime
Minister says she wants to unite when
all she has done is divide failing to
unilaterally guarantee the rights of EU
citizens at the outset which was not
only the right thing to do but would
have created Goodwill on both sides of
the
negotiations red lines that created more
problems than they solved negotiating
issues in an order and a way that made
this backs stop inevitable the Prime
Minister has had 2 years to Reach Out
across this house for a consensus and
fail to do so and instead of speaking to
others she has stayed in her bunker now
Mr Speaker she only speaks at the
concrete walls unable to deliver the
changes needed the country deserves so
much better than this totally inadequate
agreement we hope for more in the
96 days since the Prime Minister first
stood on the steps of number 10 with
what proved to to be completely empty
promises and I stand here today Mr
Speaker nearly four years after being
first elected knowing that we can and
must do better at this key moment in our
history and for that reason the prime
minister's deal should be voted down by
this
house order the first of approximately
70 members wishing to speak from the
back benches is the father of the house
Mr Kenneth Clark Mr Speaker I shall try
to compete with the opposition spokesman
on brevity by being shorter than he was
and uh this is a chaotic uh debate uh Mr
Speaker in every conceivable way I think
future Generations will look back and
will not be able to imagine how we
reduced ourselves to this disorderly
exchange of a whole range of views
cutting quite across parties at a time
when we were taking such a historic
decision uh it was summed up for me uh
yesterday when I drove in and I drove
through the gates of New Palace yard
with flanked on either side with
lobbyists who are waving things at me to
the right I I had people voting yellow
placards leave means leave and to the
left I had people waving Union European
Union flags and uh demanding my support
both sides in as far as they were
shouting a clear message to me we're
shouting the same thing
they were both demanding that I voted
against the withdrawal
agreement and that summed up to me the
confusion because they were both
actually pursuing objectives neither of
which I agreed with which took us a
million miles away from the national
interest which the House of Commons
should surely in the end have to turn
itself to uh we all know where we come
from and I'm not going to labor my very
well-known views since I've been here so
long uh yes I offended one of my very
good friends in the house slightly I
think by referring to Hardline remainers
as well as Hardline bre of teers but uh
I confess I am undoubtedly a hard line
remainer don't think anybody more
Hardline on that subject in in the house
uh I was a cabinet minister but refused
to vote for the referendum being held
and the Prime Minister and the chief
whip chose not to notice my attempts
ostentatiously to abstain on the vote uh
I'm the only person on this side of the
house who voted against invoking article
50 I actually am a lifelong believer in
the European project to no opinion poll
is ever I think at this stage going to
change my mind I think Britain's and I
have no time I my friend I I I I believe
that Britain's role in the world now is
as one of the leading members of the
European Union one of the three which
when we have a normal president has
particular links with the United States
with the other don't and that enables us
to defend our interests and put forward
our values in a very dangerous world and
we have we have membership of
influential members ship of we lead on
liberal Economic Policy the biggest and
most developed free trade area in the
world which is always going to be where
our major trading partners are because
geography in the end determines that
they matter to us more than anybody else
so I won't go on but just in case
there's any doubt where I come from I
again think I am being pragmatic which
we all have to be the attorney general
was quite correct when he praised the
need for this house to achieve some kind
of consensus to accept some sort of
compromise which I regard as my duty to
minimize the damage the vote on invoking
article 50 revealed to me that there's
not the slightest chance of persuading
the present House of Commons to give up
leaving the EU because they're terrified
of denying the EU referendum to be fair
to my friends who are Hardline
brexiteers and always have been none of
them had the slightest intention of
taking any notice of the referendum but
it's now a a kind of religiously binding
commitment it it seems to the majority
of this house that they must leave so
we're leaving so why am I therefore
supporting the withdrawal agreement the
withdrawal agreement is a natural
preliminary to the proper negotiations
which we haven't started frankly it
should have taken about two months to
negotiate because the conclusions we've
come to on the rights of citizens on our
his legally historic debts and on the
Irish Border being open uh permanently
uh were perfectly clear and there and
their essential preconditions to which
the Attorney General rightly drew our
attention to the legal chaos that we
caused if we just left without other
detail Provisions in a 500 page document
the the the withholding agreement in
itself is
harmless the the Irish back stop is not
really the reason why a large number of
members of this house are going to vote
against it you you've got to be suffer
uffing from some sort of paranoia in my
opinion to think that the Irish back
stop is some carefully contrived plot to
keep the British locked into European
negoti relationships which they're dying
to escape from I won't they address it
with great eloquence which I admired it
it is obviously as unattractive to the
other EU members as it is to the United
Kingdom to settle down into some
semi-permanent relationship on the basis
of the Irish back stop in my opinion we
don't need to invoke the Irish back stop
at all we can almost certainly avoid it
seems to be quite obvious that the
transition period which will open up
should go on for as long as is necessary
until the full withdrawal agreement in
all its details on our political
relationships our regulatory
relationships our trade relationships
has our security our policing has all
been
settled and it I don't think it will be
completed in a couple of years I
actually think it will take four or five
years if we make very good progress
before we have completed all that and I
think that is the view of people with
more expertise than I've had although
I've been involved in trade agreements
unlike most people in the house who
actually are going to be saddled with
the responsibility of negotiating this
if we ever get that far but uh the if we
extend the transition period as is
necessary we never need to go into the
back stop and actually putting end dates
on the transition period is pretty
futile because actually when you get
there you can't actually begin to change
our relationship until you've agreed in
some detail what it is you're actually
changing to and that if this house
persists in taking us out of the
European Union is where eventually we've
got to to
get if I give way to my honorable friend
who is very good friend of mine I shall
let sudden find everybody's leaving I've
made it I'm I'm not going to keep my
word otherwise if I start give give
giving way the outcome I wish to see is
the same as the government's declared
outcome as it happens that we should
keep on the keeping to the narrower
matters of trade and investment open
borders between the United Kingdom and
the uh rest of the European Union and as
free frictionless trade relationships uh
as we have at the moment uh I shall
listen to people arguing that is not in
the best interests of the United Kingdom
and future Generations but I think it's
an impossible
case to make it is self-evidently the
case that we should stay in our present
free trade agreement we can't become
free trade to the rest of the world but
protectionist against those Continental
Europeans by erecting new barriers and
nobody said to the electorate at the
time of the referendum that the purpose
of the whole thing was to raise new
barriers to two-way trade and investors
across the way seems to me quite obvious
it is factually correct
in my opinion if you wish to keep open
borders the land border which happens to
be an Ireland and the Sea border around
the rest of the British aisles you have
to be in a customs Union and you have to
be in regulatory alignment which will
greatly resemble what we call the single
Market all this stuff about new
technology uh may come one day when
every closed Border in the world will
vanish but under W WTO rules you have to
man The Border
uh if you've got different tariffs and
regulatory requirements on the two sides
so that is where I think we we have got
to go and I think sooner or later we're
going to have to tighten up the
government keeps repeating its red lines
some of which were put out at early
stage long before the people drafting
the speeches had the first idea really
what the process was they were about to
enter into and most of them now need
dropping the the standard line is you
can't be in a customs Union because that
stops you having trade agreements with
the rest of the world which is true you
can't have a common Customs barrier
enforced by you all around the outside
of the Zone if one member is punching
holes through it and letting things end
under different Arrangements in other
countries now this is meant to challenge
the global future the bright and Shining
prospects of our being outside the
European Union which nobody came put
forward in the referendum they stem as
far as I can see from a very brilliant
speech made by my honorable friend right
honorable friend the member for Oxbridge
who was praised for giving an optimistic
tone to it all and held out this vision
of great countries throughout the world
throwing open their markets to us in
relief when we left the European Union
offering us better terms than we've
spent the last few years taking a
leading role in negotiating on behalf of
the uh with together with the European
Union and and of course the key one they
always site is the trade agreement we're
going to have with Donald Trump's
America uh which is a symbol of the
prospects that wait for us China
apparently comes next I have tried in
both places I have been in trade
involved in trade discussions with those
two countries on and off the best part
of 20 years they are very protectionist
countries they were before we had
president Trump in America I led for the
governments on working with the ttip
which we were trying to negotiate the
reason the EU us deal had the funny
title of ttip was that we couldn't call
it a Free Trade Agreement because the
Americans said that the Congress was so
hostile to the idea of free trade that
you couldn't talk about a free trade
agreement we had to give it another
title and we got nowhere even under the
Obama
administration because what we
particularly wanted was opening up
public procurement opening up access to
services including Financial Services in
the United States and I can tell you we
it was
completely hopeless TR trying to open up
their market now it's to it's different
with President
Trump the hopes with President Trump are
a sign of the new golden future that is
coming before US president Trump has won
first he's no time for WTO rules he's
been breaking them with some
considerable Vigor and sooner or later
he will walk out of the WTO I think his
view of trade deals is he confronts
Allied partner countries
the United States should be allowed to
export more to them and they should stop
exporting so much to the United States
he's enforced that on Canada and Mexico
and he's having a good go at enforcing
it on China his only interest that he's
expressed in the trade deal with Britain
is that we should throw open our Market
to American food which is made on anous
produc on an almost industrial scale
industri is very competitive in great
quantities that requires one thing we
abandon the European food standards and
Animal Welfare standards which the
British actually played the leading part
in getting to their present position in
the rest of the EU and we should adopt
the standards laid down by Congress the
House of Representatives and the senate
in response to the food Lobby there no
sovereignty nobody's going to takeing
notice of the UK on food standards
lobbying the American Congress it is an
illusion I'll give no others freedom of
movement if we enforce freedom of
movement properly when we were members
we wouldn't be in this trouble all the
anti-immigrant element of the leave vote
was not really about EU workers working
here we would be permitted actually to
make it a condition that people had a
job already arranged to come here we
were permitted to say they would have to
leave if after 3 months from losing a
job they had not actually got a new one
and everybody in this house and outside
Falls over themselves with praise for
the EU workers in the National Health
Service and elsewhere it is an illusion
that that is uh waiting for us so what I
say is in the presentant bizarre
position my view is
we must get on to the real negotiations
we haven't started yet it's not possible
to start to actually map out the closest
possible relationship I hope with the EU
if we're going to be forced to leave
we're in no position to start from to
this bad debate and sort it all out by
March the 29th it is factually
impossible not only to get the
legislation through it's impossible
actually to sort thought out some
alternative to withdrawal agreement if
it is uh if it is uh rejected today the
the we should extend it but that
involves applying to the EU it implies
getting their consent that will be quite
difficult uh for any length of
time that's the reason I advocate we
should revoke article 50 and that is a
means of
delay revoke it no one can stop us
revoking it and then invoke it again I
shall vote against it again but the
majority in favor of invoking article 50
in this house is massive invoking game
when we have some consensus some
majority for something and we I shall
everybody else by
giving once to my honorable
friend could I just say to my right
honorable friend whose speech I am
admiring um minute by minute that there
is one point on which he is wrong we
cannot revoke article 50
unless we provide satisfactory evidence
to the European Union that we are
cancelling our departure from the
European Union not suspending it not
pausing it canceling
it well I I'm not going to start I
haven't been in practice for 40 years so
if that is the case I will examine it
and have a look at what Authority he
gives me are we we therefore prevented
for some permanent glare thereafter from
ever invoking article 50 again I that's
a proposition that I would like to
examine in that case we have to extend
it but what we cannot carry on doing is
having this chaotic debate and in the
next 70 days coming to conclusions which
commit this country to a destiny which
will have a huge effect on the Next
Generation or two because what we're
heading for is leaving with no deal at
all all that will be just as
catastrophic as my right honorable
friend the attorney general has just
described and it's the one thing which
the vast majority of members of
parliament are flatly against leaving
without no deal for that reason
pragmatism in my opinion Common Sense
requires us to vote for this withrawal
agreement to try to get back to some
sort of orderly program
Mr Ian
Blackford thank you Mr Speaker it's
always a considerable pleasure to follow
the right honorable member for Rush Club
I have to say it's a strange world that
we live in because I find myself in so
many occasions pretty well agreeing with
much of what the right honorable
gentleman says and and and of course on
many occasions I do find that the right
honorable gentleman is in the division
lobbies with us I would only
respectfully and friendly say to him
that his analysis I think is spot on I
think he's demonstrated the futility of
those that believe that a UK out with a
European Union can somehow quickly put
together trade deals around the world
it's a fantasy it's for the birds and it
is I would say Mr Speaker an absolute
travesty that what's been put to this
house today is that we have that binary
choice between the government's Deal or
No Deal that is not the case there are
other options which are open to this
house and the right honorable gentlemen
for Rush CL has talked about either
revoking or staving off the article 50
process that gives the house time
frankly to come to its senses and the
idea based on the knowledge of what we
know now of the risks of brexit because
let's be absolutely clear there is no
such thing as a good brexit the
government's own
analysis the analysis of the Scottish
government just a second the analysis of
the Scottish government demonstrates in
any of the brexit
scenarios that this country the
countries of Scotland of England and
Northern Ireland and Wales will all be
poer under any of the brexit
scenarios than they would be under the
status
quo Mr Speaker it is the respon
responsibility of any government to
provide security for its
citizens a government that wishes to
bring forward a proposition that
imperils the employment
opportunities the living standards of
its citizens is an agregation of
responsibility that it should have and
it's on that basis that I would plead
with the right honorable gentlemen to
vote against or at the very least
abstain on what the government is doing
today because this house to use the
phrase which is often used must Take
Back
Control we must say to the people of the
United
Kingdom however they
voted that based on the knowledge that
we have based on the facts of the matter
that we have and let's just look at what
happened last week Jaguar Land Rover
announced that there'll be making an
additional 45,000 workers redundant that
follows on the 1500 that now we know
that the reasons for this are complex to
do with diesel cars to do with China but
a significant contributory factor is
brexit and this government stands
accused of putting workers on the door
and putting workers on the door as a
function of ideology because that's what
it is and if you look at the
circumstances of where we are today of a
prime minister that called the general
election
on the basis that she thought she would
come back with a stomping
majority she came back as a minority
prime minister and rather than seize the
moment and recognize that this is a
parliament of minorities where the Prime
Minister had to reach across the house
to try and achieve a consensus she
failed to do that and all that's
happened since the general election in
2017 until now is if we had an internal
battle in the Tor party the
brexiteers that want to drive us off the
cliff Mr Speaker there is no way that
the Scottish national party and the
people of Scotland are going to be
sitting in that bus as the Prime
Minister drives us off the cliff there
is no way that the people of Scotland
will be dragged out of the European
Union against its will friend I will
Happ thank Mar friend for giving away
he's making an excellent speech and
would he agree with me that given the
government's own analysis shows that no
matter the outcome with brexit we will
all be poter that it is the most
vulnerable in society who will pay the
price people with disability who have
been writing to me in their hundreds as
chair of the disability all party group
terrified of the outcome that brexit
will happen and they'll be thrown into
further
despair my my honorable friend is
exactly correct it is the most
vulnerable in our society that will pay
the biggest price for brexit those that
are disabled those that rely on our
Public Services because there is no
question that our public services will
be poer we know the economic growth in
the United Kingdom will be reduced by
brexit why are we punishing people to
that extent and that's why it's right
and why the government has a
responsibility to be honest with people
to refle reflect on what happened in
2016 there is a economist Dr Samuelson
who said when events change I changed my
mind what do you do why has the Prime
Minister not reflected on the situation
that would in Mr Speaker I'm grateful
for my honorable friend and her
intervention and I'm delighted to
announce to the house that in the
process of this debate all 35 members of
the Scottish national party have spoken
out and all spoken out about the risks
that we see to our constituents the
risks to our Industries up and down
Scotland and of course one of the
features that particularly alarms us is
the issue of freedom of
movement Mr Speaker we have benefited
enormously from those that have come to
work and live in our country to add to
the diversity
of our communities to make a
contribution to our economic growth EU
citizens that have
chosen to make their lives here European
Union citizens that are now being told
that they're going to have to register
register to sustain the rights that they
have it is as is mentioned by my
honorable friend from a sedentary
position disgusting I will in a second
because this is about people that are
part of us our friends our neighbors our
relatives and we're now saying to them
that they're going to have a different
status as a consequence of what we have
done but it's not just about EU citizens
that choose to come and live and work in
this country it's about our rights as EU
citizens as
well if the government gets its way and
brexit takes place on the 29th of March
from a situation today that each and
every one of us has the right to work in
28 member states we will be restricted
to
automatically only having the right to
live and work in the United Kingdom I
was lucky enough to work in the
Netherlands my son worked in the
Netherlands why should my grandchildren
not have the same rights that my
generation had it is an abhorrence that
we are treating the people of these
islands on that basis have a happily
giveway I'm very grateful to my right
honorable friend for giving way and he's
making a powerful point about the people
who have come to live and work and be
our friends and Neighbors in our
communities is does he agree with me
that it's an absolute disgrace that
these people who are so vital to us are
being asked are being told that they
must make an application to pay to stay
in their own homes many of whom have
been here for decades it's an absolute
outrage agree and of course it fits into
the hostile environment that many in the
government benches have prosecuted over
the course of the last few years we have
a an expression in Scotland we're all
jock Thomson's beards you know Mr
Speaker if I look at our history over
the course of the last 100 years our
population in Scotland has barely grown
we've gone from 4.8 to 5 A5 million
people we Face a ticking Time Bomb which
is an aging population the last thing we
need is to be cut off from that supply
of labor for people that want to come
and contribute to sustainable economic
growth in Scotland how are we to afford
to be able to invest in our Public
Services if we cannot generate economic
growth because that's what leaving
Europe is going to do to us it's going
to restrain our ability to to deliver
growth our ability to make sure that we
can look after the vulnerable in our
society Mr Speaker this is the defining
moment in the brexit process defining
moments for the future of
relationships members of parliaments
must recognize their responsibility and
for many I know that this demands making
difficult decisions I would say to each
and every Member of Parliament the
primary responsibility that you have is
not the party the primary respons
responsibility that you have is to your
constituents think about the risks that
are taking place as a consequence of
this deal it is the height of irr
responsibility for the government to
suggest that this is a binary Choice Mr
Speaker in the snp's amendment that we
have laid today we have given the
opportunity for the house to support
that we extend article 50 extend article
50 and give the people of the United
Kingdom the choice to make that
determination on the basis of the facts
on the basis of the knowledge as to what
brexit is going to do it is only right
and proper in a democratic principle
that we allow the people of the United
Kingdom to make that choice and I appeal
to members across the house now we have
in the P me many friends across this
place and many friends on the benches to
my
right I'm appealing to the labor
party for goodness
sake get off the
fence get off the fence because the
young people that voted for labor in
England in
2017 will never forgive the leader of
the opposition and his colleagues unless
they recognize that this is the
opportunity to unite
to unite this house to vote down the
government's deal support a people's
vote allow the people to have their say
and what they want will you do it I can
see the honorable chent chuning if he
wishes to intervene and accept his
responsibilities well you can blow a
kiss but what you're doing is you're
blowing a rasbery to the people of the
United Kingdom that's the reality and it
really is about time if you're serious
about politics if you're serious about
responsibility then grow up grow up and
accept responsibility and don't Dodge
this don't Dodge this you know it's
little wonder that when we look at
Scotland that the people of Scotland
have got a choice and the Scottish
national party have been in government
in Scotland since
2007 well I can hear people saying too
long years but the fact of the matter is
we've won three elections on the tro to
the Scottish Parliament and we've won
the last two elections to Westminster
and the party that's sitting in third
place in Scotland is the labor party and
the reason that the labor party are
sitting in third place in Scotland is
because they're out of touch and out of
step with the people of
Scotland I was absolutely it it comes as
no surprise that when challenged by the
leader of the SNP nobody got up to
defend the position of the labor party
nobody and what that tells us is that
there my honorable friend not agree with
me there is no such thing as a job's
first brexit it's a myth they I'm I'm
I'm I'm grateful for my honorable th for
that intervention because he's
absolutely right and that's why I'm
appealing to every member in this house
doesn't sound like it to think about
about the people think about the people
that have already lost their jobs think
about the thousand people in the
European me agency think about the
thousand people in the European banking
Authority think about those That Jag
Your Land Rover and the workers That Jag
Your Land Rover know that the labor
party today are not going to lift a
finger to protect their economic
interests that's the reality a party
that was once of the people that is just
sitting back and failing to accept the
responsibilities well thank goodness Mr
Speaker in Scotland that we have an
alternative and the people of Scotland
have watched everything which has gone
on over the course of the last 2 and a
half years taking back control they say
well my goodness they've taken back
control from the parliament of Scotland
when this house pushed through the
withdrawal act what happened was with
responsibility over Fisheries over
agriculture over the environment
which were down in the Scotland act when
the parliament was established as
matters which have devolved supposed to
be protected by the Su convention but of
course the government said well these
are not normal times and they grabbed
Powers not so much against the Scottish
government and the Scottish Parliament
but grab Powers against the people of
Scotland that had voted for it in a
referendum in 1997 that's the reality of
the conservatives that have always been
hostile to Devolution of course we're
told well the people voted in 2016 and
we should accept it but of course the
people of Scotland were told in our
referendum in 2014 if we stayed in the
United Kingdom our rights within the EU
would be respected absolutely the fact
that the people of Scotland voted by 62%
to stay in the European Union is ignored
by this government the fact that the
Scottish Parliament has said that we
wish to stay as a very minimum in the
single market and the Customs Union has
been ignored by this government contempt
for the institutions in Scotland
contempt for the cross party Unity that
existed on these matters in Scotland Mr
Speaker the time is
coming where the people of Scotland are
going to have to reflect
and how we being on how we are being
ignored listen to this the Scottish
Parliament has a
mandate for an independence
referendum and if and when the first
minister in the Scottish government
chooses to enforce that mandate this
house must respect the wishes of the
Scottish people I hope
tonight that this house votes down the
government's deal I hope this house has
the confidence to extend article 50 to
give the responsibility back to the
people but if this house is determined
to push ahead with brexit the day when
the people of Scotland will have to
determine their own Future do We Wish to
Be trailed to a United Kingdom that's
going to to damage your economic
interests or will we accept our
responsibilities as a historic
independent European nation Mr Speaker
that day is coming and it's coming soon
Sir William cash thank you Mr Speaker
for me that this has been a very long
journey towards leaving the European
Union not there yet the European
question has always been about who
governs this country and how the
national interest is served by our
democratic system of parliamentary
government which has evolved over
centuries of our
history we make our own law in this
parliament in line with the consent of
the voters in general elections based
upon the party
manifestos the government is chosen by
virtue of those who win the most seats
it is also fundamental that our
proceedings are both accountable and
transparent we have Hansard and all
votes are recorded any voter can see the
transcript and how their laws are made
and voted upon in this Parliament we
must fully repeal the European communist
act 1972 on the 29th of March as the
withdrawal act legislatively requires
that is why I agreed with the Prime
Minister when she said at the Lancaster
house speech that we would not have
truly left the European Union if we are
not in control of our own laws this
agreement does not do this despite
breathtaking assertions to the country
this may even be indefinite through the
back stop and through through the
undemocratic procedures of the Council
of ministers we would be indefinitely
Shackled as article 132 affirms even up
to 31st December so they say
20xx the decisions in that Council as to
which laws we obey and changes to the
rules creating great uncertainty for
business will be decided by qmv or
consensus by the other 27 behind closed
doors we will not be there there will be
no transcript and no reasons given as to
how or why the laws imposed upon us will
be arrived at this alone is a reason why
I'm voting against this withdrawal
agreement it is a denial of our
democracy and therefore of the national
interest it defies the referendum vote
and the withdrawal act itself which
repeals the European Community act 972
and all the treaties and laws including
the single Market market and the Customs
Union which have been heaped upon us
since we joined the European Community
itself in 1972 73 it is outrageous to
suggest that what we are doing in
rejecting this withdrawal agreement is
undemocratic this is pure Alice in
Wonderland Mr Speaker and turns the very
notion of democracy and National
interest upon its head but that is not
all this agreement is not compromis as
the Attorney General suggested it is
capitula
nor is it pragmatism we are not purists
we are defending our de democracy
against
servitude apart from control over our
laws there is the question of money
paying not merely 39 billion but far
more for nothing we will lose the rebate
then there is the role of the European
court of justice there is the issue of
our not being able to trade
independently outside the clutches of
the European commission we have
prodigious opportunities to create
prosperity and to provide the revenue
for the payment of our public
services and to Pro and and by trading
with other on our own terms with other
countries in the world through the
anglosphere and the Commonwealth there
is also the question of the
Constitutional status of Northern
Ireland there are the state AIDS in this
withdrawal agreement which would give a
power of veto to the European Union over
our incentives in relation to Ports
Industrial Development as well which
will be one of our primary means of
attracting foreign direct investment
bear in mind also that in the European
Union we run a deficit in the single
Market on Goods of around 95 billion a
year whereas Germany hides behind the
Euro with a surplus of40 billion pound a
year with the
eu27 so Paul Lever our former British
ambassador to Germany
said recently in his book Berlin rules
the EU he said is geared principally to
the defense of German National interest
he explains as I did in my own book
against the federal Europe in the
1990s early 1990s that there will be a
German Europe he shows that no decisions
including those relating to the
negotiations for the withdrawal
agreement were decided by the commission
or by other member states without the
prior agreement of Germany itself
why on Earth would anyone want to remain
the EU does not work for the UK nor the
EU itself with youth unemployment in
countries such as Italy Greece and
France of between 20 and 50% they are
utterly disillusioned with the austerity
imposed by the German Le fiscal compact
Hungary and Poland and other countries
in Central Europe are in Revolt and even
Sweden and Denmark have moved to the
right so what is it that makes these
reverses in this house believe that we
should remain in this imploding
undemocratic European Union whose
economic foundations are in tatters as
the Euro stagnates why on Earth do they
believe that a new people's vote is
needed when we had one enacted by Act of
parliament in the House of Commons and
voted for by most of those now trying to
unravel the withdrawal act and despite
every conservative having endorsed the
referendum vote in
Manifesto as I argued some months ago
our system is one of parliamentary
government not government by
Parliament government by Parliament
would be anarchic so we are faced not
only with a constitutional crisis but
also with a massive breach of public
trust as a party and as a parliament up
to the time of the Checker's proposals I
was fully prepared to support the
government but on the 6th of July my
trust TR in the government and the Prime
Minister was completely
lost I asked her on the 9th of July how
could she reconcile Checkers with the
repeal of the European communist act
1972 and I got no reply in the debate
the next week I stressed that the
80-page white paper setting out those
proposals and now intrinsic to the
withdrawal agreement had been
pre-planned for probably up to a year I
explained it would unravel the European
communist
1972 that this was a gross misleading of
parliament indeed the Checker's meeting
itself bounced the cabinet in breach of
collective responsibility and in breach
of the ministerial code all of this
amounts to a monstrous breach of
constitutional and public trust this
brings me to what happens next which as
I believe this withdrawal agreement will
be consigned to the grave of History far
from members of parliament as the Prime
Minister has asserted voting for this
agreement it is our duty to vote against
it we will not have effectively left the
European Union if we do not we will also
be undermining our Westminster system of
government depriving ourselves of
monumental opportunities of global
trading on our own terms and with our
friends in the United States who are so
disillusioned with this agreement and
the same applies to other members of the
Commonwealth as Churchill once said and
as I was reminded at the time of M by my
constituents we should pull our country
first our constituency second our party
third tragically our prime minister
became leader of our party by coronation
and not by the will of the party
membership they by all the recent
evidence are profoundly against this
withdrawal agreement we then had the
deeply unsatisfactory outcome of the
last general election I simply say
therefore that now is the time to walk
away from this European Union the
expression no deal is a misnomer it is
not a default position it is what the
act of parliament endorsing the Lisbon
treaty actually specifies there must be
no extension of time as the European
Union uh so-called number two bill which
has been introduced by the member for
grantom indicates and I glad that the
Prime Minister reaffirmed to me
yesterday that this is the case it will
achieve nothing I would strongly urge
the government therefore after this vote
is cast tonight to conclude that enough
is enough and that we have reached the
Journey's End now is the time to walk
away from the intransigence of the
European Union and our failed policy of
seeking to supplicate their guidelines
their terms and their pay masters we
witnessed similar events in May 1940
when the then prime minister actually
won the vote on the Norway debate but on
reflection concluded that he had to
resign because he had lost the
confidence of parliament as a whole I
believe therefore there are lessons in
this for the prime minister to consider
her position and to do so with dignity
and without
ranker Mr Hillary Ben thank you uh very
much indeed Mr Speaker I want to address
what happens next if as seems likely the
prime minister's deal is defeated this
evening now the first question will be
what will the Prime Minister do in that
situation until yesterday I thought she
might say well I'm going back to
Brussels to get some more assurances but
that route does appear to be blocked now
in the light of the letter that she
brought to the House's attention
yesterday I'd like to think that she
would take a bold step that she would
reach out across the House of Commons to
look for a consensus uh that she would
say that she would prepared to consider
a completely different approach even
announcing that the because she still
believes in her deal she is going to
take it to the British people and ask
them what they think now that really
would be political leadership but if she
doesn't do any of those things then the
House of Commons is going to have to
move swiftly to enable us to decide what
we can agree on because as the Prime
Minister rightly said the House of
Commons can say what it's against but in
the end the House of Commons will have
to be for something yeah here so we need
to decide on what a different policy
might look like and how we get there now
one option is undoubtedly to leave
without a deal now some members favor
that as we've just heard many of us
think it would be a disaster by the way
so does the government so let's give the
House of Commons a chance once and for
all to make it clear what it thinks of
that then there are the alternative
deals there's Canada with a variety of
pluses attached there is EA and a
customs unit which is what I have been
arguing for all of variation upon that
and then thirdly there is process how do
we enable any of the different
approaches if we can agree on them to be
negotiated with the European Union and
how could we do that when we are running
out of time now I think it is now
inevitable Mr Speaker that article 50
will need to be extended whichever
option the House of Commons chooses
assuming we can reach agreement on
something I support a series of
indicative votes and I support the bill
that The Honorable member for Grantham
and others have tabled which would give
the house if it's approved the legal
means to give effect to what we decide
including on whether to extend article
50 and if this house cannot
agree apart from deciding that we don't
want to leave with no deal in other
words if this house remains deadlocked
which is a
possibility then someone else will have
to decide and in all fairness I have to
say I can see no other way of doing that
in those circumstances other than
resolving to go back to the British
people and asking them what they think
now the reason why the Prime Minister I
would give way but time is very short
and many other people want to speak the
reason why the Prime Minister has got
into such difficulty is because the
House of Commons won't agree a deal
we'll discover tonight because of fear
uncertainty and doubt fear that we will
be locked into a back stop permanently
uncertainty about entering into a
process in which we will be in an even
weaker position than we have been over
the past two and a half years and doubt
about where this will all end up in an
age as the father of the house so
eloquently put it where it is the
quality of the alliances that you have
that determine the ability to influence
what happens in the world in the
interest of the people that we represent
now what would be the rational thing
thing to do faced with these set of
circumstances it would be to seek to
remove that fear that uncertainty and
that doubt and it would be to say to the
European Union look the only way we're
going to get a deal is not by exchanging
another set of letters or asking for
another Assurance but by moving on to
negotiate the future relationship now so
that everyone could see at the end of
the process what it would involve before
we formally leave now I
understand I understand the legal
position that in law the European Union
cannot sign such an agreement and the
Attorney General pointed out until the
United K Kingdom has ceased to be a
member state but it has a choice about
its negotiating mandate and we all
understand why the EU chose to structure
the negotiations in the way that they
did because far from holding all of the
cards as the last two and a half years
has demonstrated we've held virtually no
cards at all but if we were able to
negotiate more detail on the future
relationship and it would be challenging
for the EU it' be very challenging for
the government because it would finally
have to uh confront the choices it's
been steadfastly avoiding over the last
two and a half years in the end of that
process we would know where we stood on
the back stop and the nature of the
future relationship now to do this we
would have to extend article 50 and if
you want to reassure people and we may
confront this choice at some point that
extending or maybe revoking article is
not a device for the House of Commons to
overturn the result of the referendum in
2016 then the House of Commons could say
to the people do not worry whatever is
the result of this process we will put
back to you so you take the final
decision and if we could undertake those
negotiations while still a member from
the eu's point of view it wouldn't
really make any difference at all we'd
still be paying the money we're going to
do that under the transition we'd still
be accepting the rules of the European
court of justice we're going to do that
under the transition we'd still be a
member of the single market and the
Customs Union we're going to do that
under the transition we'd still be
accepting free movement which we're
going to do Under the transition now I
acknowledge that would be difficult but
it would be the sensible thing to do and
who knows where the EU might be in 2 or
three years time which we all of us know
is how long these negotiations will take
to complete indeed if the EU were to say
to other countries not just to the UK
you're not going to get what you want if
you leave but if you remain then there
is the possibility of Reform then that
would be the kind but that would be the
kind of leadership that would be the
kind of leadership that the EU could
potentially offer now I don't know
whether there is the Strategic Vision in
the EU to do that but they should
provide it because the forces present in
Britain are present in all of their
member states and reform including on
free movement would be in their interest
as well as in arms now if this isn't
possible and if the government when
won't reach out then we as Parliament
must take responsibility that would not
be us I say to The Honorable gentleman
subverting democracy in any way it would
be us doing our job it would be taking
back control and the draft bill which I
referred to earlier and which I support
will give us the means to do so it's
proposing to ask the L and committee to
take a role it could be amended to give
that responsibility else where on that
issue I I I'm going to conclude my
remarks uh which the House of Commons in
the end will have a chance to vote upon
now in conclusion Mr Speaker the
referendum result came as a shock to
many in this house but it did not come
as a shock to those who voted leave it
was a cry of Anguish as the EU became
the lightning conductor for the feelings
of 17.4 million people about the change
they've seen in their communities The
Disappearance of wellpay jobs the
shrinking of opportunities and let's be
honest
above all about our Collective failure
to share the prosperity of this the
sixth richest economy in the world with
all of our citizens but it will not be
solved by a damaging brexit yes it will
not be remed remedied by the convulsion
the argument the lack of Direction and
purpose the refusal to be honest about
choices that we face that have consumed
almost all of our energy all of our
effort and our attention and time and we
cannot let this carry on for the next 5
years we owe it to our constituents to
tell the truth we owe it to ourselves to
do the right thing and in rejecting the
deal today as we should we must show as
parliamentarians of all parties and All
Views that we are after the vote tonight
capable of coming together to listen to
compromise in the interest of the people
we come here to
serve thank you very much indeed limit
on account of the level of demand I'm
afraid there has now to be a 5- minute
limit on back bench speeches with
immediate effect Mr Dominic
Rob for my part in this debate I've
always understood the case for
compromise but compromise cannot come at
any price and the deal before us
involves the most severe and enduring
risks for our economy our democracy
while stifling the opportunities of
brexit that fired up over 17 million
people with optimism and hope to vote in
June
2016 my reasons are straightforward the
northern Island back stop and the scale
of separate regulation without
representation is undemocratic and a
threat to our precious
Union second the uk-wide Customs back
stop has morphed into a hybrid Customs
Union and single Market Arrangement
where the combination of alignment and
non-regression requirements prevent this
this house from determining the right
laws in the best interests of this
country friend give way I give way on
the back stop and just my my honorable
friend agree agree with me that the the
back stop is playing a risk the Attorney
General said it was taking a risk and
it's playing a risk with the Good Friday
agreement and the union of this country
and that is a risk that many of us are
not prepared to take my honorable friend
is absolutely right and on top of that
powerful point the uh effect of this
deal is to give up control that it would
precipitate a democratic Cliff Edge and
that's compounded by the lack of an exit
mechanism that we can control it gives
the EU a veto over any UK exit from the
back stop even if negotiations on the
future relationship languish for years
or break down altogether and it's very
clear that none of the subsequent
assurances alter the legal position are
set out in the withdrawal agreement with
my honorable right honorable friend
would he agree with me that if more
assurances were there that many more
members of this house would potentially
support that agreement my honorable
friend is right and I'll come back to
what I think the Prime Minister and the
government should do in the event that
the deal is voted down my third reason
for opposing this deal is that paragraph
23 of the political declaration means
that the upcoming negotiations on our
future relationship would take the back
stop as the starting point to be built
on
the future relationship would not be a
free trade agreement not even the
checkers model that was set out back in
the summer it would be a hybrid
Arrangement somewhere even further along
the spectrum of legislative alignment
with the EU between the Customs unit and
the single Market without any say over
the rules to be
imposed given the EU veto over us
exiting the back stop we will spend the
second phase of negotiations from March
under massive pressure from the EU to
accept additional single Market rules
potentially free movement access to UK
Fisheries as the price for exiting the
back stop exactly the EU will inevitably
press up press us right up until the
next election if not well beyond and
they would wield all the negotiating
leverage so to all honorable members
weary with
brexit I share your desire to move on
from brexit but be under No Illusion
this deal before us can't end the
grinding process it can only prolong
it this deal is so demeaning to our
country that it would inevitably invite
no demand reversal by the British people
from the moment the ink was dry it would
torment us and as a result our European
neighbors for the foreseeable
future so Mr Speaker what
next if this deal is voted down we
should make our best final offer to the
EU on the current deal including as
honorable members have made on all sides
an ability to exit the back stop and
transition to a best-in-class free trade
agreement and at the same time we must
accelerate our preparations for leaving
on WTO terms in case all reasonable
offers are rebuffed in Brussels so that
we can manage and mitigate the undoubted
risks of leaving on W terms whilst at
the same time leaving the arm of
friendship extended to continue
negotiations with the EU whether it's
right up until the end of March or even
Beyond Mr Speaker that is what my head
tells me about this deal but like so
many of us in this house on all sides
this decision touches our hearts and
indeed the very soul of who we are as a
country yeah yeah exactly and like many
of us I think what this deal means for
our children my two sons are four and
six I want them to grow up in a country
that is even better than today more
prosperous more ambitious more confident
and yes more conscientious in the world
too I want them to know that we
fearlessly chose the right path for
their future that we did not duck the
challenge weary of brexit we did not
avoid the undeniable but manageable
short-term risk at the longterm expense
of the economic health and the
Democratic foundations of the country
that I know we all
love but what I fear most in the terms
of this deal is the drain on our economy
the loss of competitive economic
Advantage the enfeeblement of our
democracy that this deal would inflict
inevitably over
time because it is the embodiment of a
distinct view of the United Kingdom one
that acques in defeatism and makes its
peace with man
decline Mr Speaker I will not sign up
for that not for my country not for our
people not for my children and not for
theirs because I believe in this United
Kingdom of ours I believe in our
entrepreneurs our
innovators I'm proud of our culture just
as I love those across Europe and well
beyond and I believe that we in this
place the mother of parliamentary
democracy accountable to the people must
determine the vital sensitive and
controversial issues of the
day not meekly abdicate such precious
decisions to
Brussels so I will vote against the
motion and the deal because it is racked
with self-doubt defeatism and
fear but equally for many of us who vote
against the deal we vote for we aspire
to something better and something
brighter and Mr Speaker with my heart
and soul I vote for the promise of
brexit that must be fulfilled I vote for
the temerity to regain Mastery of our
own
destiny I vote for the ability to reach
our full Global potential and above all
I vote for hope not fear and the
Renaissance of the Democracy in this
country and the people that I
love hate
Hur speaker and it's a pleasure to
follow uh the right honorable gentleman
many of what most of what he said I
fully agreed with and I want to say
tonight or today that it is with sadness
that I'm going to have to vote against
this withdrawal agreement uh this
evening I I say sadness because I hoped
that I would be able to support it as
I'm one of the very few labor MPS who
genuinely want to leave the EU and a
somewhat Lar larger group of Labor MPS
who genuinely want to honor the
referendum result and I include the
leader of my own party in that I'm very
conscious that this Parliament is full
of ran MPS it is a ran Parliament most
of them were very very upset when the
result came through they could not
believe that people had not listened to
their dire warnings so they were very
upset indeed and I think it's absolutely
true and the public know this that there
have been some in this chamber who have
spent their whole time from day one
after that referendum trying to think of
ways to stop it trying to think of ways
of stopping us to leave it and that this
is now the culmination tonight where we
have another opportunity for people
after tonight who will be trying to stop
it today for me is very simple I don't
understand why we need to vote on any of
these amendments because the reality is
that the Amendments the Amendments the
Amendments Mr Speaker if they go through
will have no bearing whatsoever on the
legal agreement they are not going to be
legal and of course we have seen and we
realize now that you know the assurances
given are not are not going to mean
anything because they're not in a legal
illegal prescribed way uh and I I would
remind people that who think these
assurances might be uh able to be
fulfilled that we're going to have a new
European Parliament in May we're going
to have new EU Commissioners the Prime
Minister may have built up a
relationship with some of those
Commissioners they will not be there and
the idea that somehow they would even
think some of them of honoring those
assurances I think we can reject that so
what happened to the Mantra of nothing
agreed until everything is agreed why
are we giving the 39 billion pounds even
if we owe it which I don't actually
think we owe as much as that why are we
giving that UPF front before we've had
anything in return the withdrawal
agreement will mean more more
uncertainty for the next few years with
the EU holding the Trump cards
especially on the back stop and I can
never support a situation where Northern
Ireland will end up being treated
separately from the rest of the United
Kingdom and having the only people who
are going to speak for them the
representatives of the Irish government
that is just not
tenable some people say here and I've
heard it said you know why don't we
after all it was only 52% 48% why don't
we just you know give a little bit
compromise to those who voted to remain
if that result had been 52% to remain
and 48% to leave do you think we all
those lawyers here the qc's the
solicitors would have been beavering
around trying to find a way of getting a
little bit of Canada or a little bit of
Norway into the kind of REM decision you
know let's be honest there are people
here who will do anything to stop us
leaving the EU we voted to take Take
Back Control I believe to the people the
people made their decision Parliament
gave that decision to the people to
decide whether they wanted to leave we
gave it up we said people you decide
they voted to leave and the idea now
that this Parliament will spend the next
week or so trying to find other ways of
actually stopping us leave on March the
29th will be I think shocking the
Attorney General has said that we must
Vote for This withdrawal agreement uh
for Holy pragmatic
reasons now with respect to the attorney
general the vote did not ask the people
of the United Kingdom did they want a
pragmatic leave or a pragmatic remain it
was very very simple they wanted to
leave and what happens after tonight one
thing cannot be evaded or overruled or
wrecked the United Kingdom must leave
the EU at the end of March to implement
and honor the will of the British people
and I actually trust I will give way to
my honorable
friend friend forgiving way she's listed
a whole series of arguments and reasons
that might undermine the decision from
2016 does she agree with me that there
would be no credibility for a second
referendum if the first referendum isn't
implemented thoroughly and
properly I think um my honorable friend
is absolutely right the people many of
whom who voted r as well will just not
understand when we haven't implemented
Mr Speaker the first referendum why we
should even be thinking of a second
referendum but whatever happens after
tonight as I said the UK must leave the
EU at the end of March to implement and
honor the will of the British people and
I do trust our prime minister on this I
have heard the Prime Minister over and
over and over again saying that we will
not revoke article 50 I have heard the
Prime Minister say over and over again
that we will be leaving on March the
29th yes that may mean some difficulties
but those difficulties are nothing to
what this country has had to go through
in the past we are a strong country we
are a proud country we are a determined
country with the people who believe and
have confidence in our country so let us
go forward to March the 29th leave the
year European union and have that bright
future which we know is ahead of
us thank you very much indeed Nikki
Morgan thank you very much indeed Mr
Speaker um how is it possible for this
house to capture an honorable members
right M speaking today the last 2 and a
half years in 5 minutes how is it
possible to capture 45 years of our
membership in 5 minutes well the good
news for those who like debating Europe
is we don't have to that because there
will be more debates to come many many
more as the Attorney General I can hear
the Joy on the benches
opposite as the Attorney General said
this is only the end of phase one and I
think the point that he was trying to
make in his speech today was that
actually today's debate should be about
the withdrawal agreement 625 pages of
the withdrawal agreement and the
political declaration M speaker I will
support the agreement tonight and like
my friend the right member for
rushcliffe that might perhaps not be
something that people might have
expected given some of the statements
that I have made but I wanted rather
than going into the detail I think it's
very easy to get stuck in the weeds of
the EU debate to talk about this
appendix or this Clause of the
withdrawal agreement that we don't like
but I think this house is really in in
danger of getting so bogged down in the
detail that we forget that the country
is looking at us not just at the
detailed debate but the tone of the
debate the way that we conduct ourselves
the way that we actually uh disagree
that we can do it well uh that we can do
it in a way that as the right woman
before lead Central said will hopefully
eventually lead us to a place where
there can be broader consensus and a
majority can be found because
unfortunately I think that ability to
find a consensus has been somewhat
lacking previous prime minister talked
about General well-being there has not
been nearly enough talk about
flourishing I begin to hear some of the
contributions saying what people want
what is a positive way forward and that
is where we need to be as a house if the
agreement is not approved by this house
tonight the country is deeply divided
our constituencies are divided this
house is divided but it is up to us as
members of parliament to change the tone
and start to heal the divisions if we
are ever ever to get on to talking about
other issues and that's one of the
lessons that I have learned in the last
two and a half years not that I've
always practiced it but it's certainly
something I think we should all aim for
whatever I say today whatever honorable
members right members on all side say a
substantial number of those watching and
our constituents will disagree with us
as we know some will disagree more vly
and violently than others but there is a
vast vast silent majority out in the
country who are watching today hoping
against hope that actually this house
does approve the agreement I don't think
they will be satisfied on the basis of
what I'm hearing but I have never before
had so many members of the public coming
up to me as a member of Parliament and
wishing us well for this vote the
country is watching what we do today and
Beyond I wrote an open letter to my
constituents and I don't hear enough
members of parliament talking about
their constituencies in this debate
today today we are their representatives
it is not about us it is not about how
we feel it is not about our high heads
and our hearts it is about who we are
representing and what is best for them
and I have come to the conclusion of
wrestling with this greatly over the
last two and a half years um I of course
would have been happy to see the
referendum results go differently I
would be happy to see uh an even closer
relationship with the EU going forward
but that isn't what people voted for the
majority who voted in
2016 they did vote for Change and it is
up to us to deliver that change I have
always been very clear that brexit
should not undermine our Constitution
and we have put our representative
democracy at massive strain to having
one referendum it shouldn't be about
undermining our economy although that's
not all about numbers in order for
people to flourish in this country it's
not just about the size of our economy
it is about other issues issues too
which have not been tackled by brexit
nor by the government over the last 2
years as our UK politics has stalled and
it should be about our values and not
undermining our values as a country and
one of those end our doubtly the British
people are very independently minded and
I can understand why it is that people
took the decision they did in June 2016
let me take in time available one brief
issue with what the Attorney General
said if the deal goes down tonight there
are other deals models on the table
where I believe this house can find
consensus and compromise carrying on
with this deal cannot be an option I'd
be disappointed if the Prime Minister
did that thank you sir Jeffrey Donaldson
thank you very much Mr Speaker and I'm
delighted to take part in this debate uh
my constituency speaking of constituents
voted by a majority to leave the
European Union but I recognize in
Northern Ireland that there are uh many
voices in opposition to that uh and uh I
have no doubt that that the Prime
Minister has worked very hard to try and
address the concerns that have been
raised on both sides of this debate and
I command her for it but when I hear
members of this house speak about the
danger that brexit poses to the peace
process in Northern Ireland I have to
refute that notion I believe strongly in
the peace process I'm delighted that in
the last 20 years we've seen a reduction
in violence uh we've seen our streets in
Northern Ireland be more peaceful and
that is something I want to maintain and
we don't want the clock turned by here
but the British people voted to leave
the European Union and we must respect
their
decision and when it we talk about a
hard border and the threat that the hard
a hard border could pose to the peace
process then I look at what the Irish
government says uh and I hear the Irish
Prime Minister say very clearly even in
the event of a No Deal outcome there
will not be a hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Irish Republic
that is the stated position of the Irish
government it's the stated position of
the government of the United Kingdom so
where is this hard border coming
from of
course when people say that the union
Customs code must be applied and WTO
rules can be app must be applied yes
they are right but that is in order to
provide confidence that checks are being
made they don't have to be made at the
frontier they can be made away from the
frontier so there's no need for a hard
Border in Northern Island and it is
worth noting uh Mr Speaker that even at
the moment with both the UK and the
Irish Republic being member members of
the European Union we have checks
between Northern Ireland and the Irish
Republic if you travel by bus from uh
Belfast to Dublin you can be stopped on
on the main road and they will check
your identity um uh for the movement of
animals there are checks across the
border the idea that there is no border
and no checks at the moment just isn't
true it does not reflect the reality but
these things can be approached sensibly
as they have been in the past there is
no reason that they cannot be dealt with
sensibly in the future my party does not
advocate for a No Deal outcome we want a
deal between the United Kingdom and the
European Union we want the prime
minister to deliver a deal for this
country but we do not believe that what
is on the table at the moment is the
best deal uh nor is in the best interest
of the United Kingdom and we've heard a
lot of talk today about the back stop
but my concern about the back stop is
not just its implications for Northern
Ireland I Echo uh comments that have
been made in the house today if we enter
the back stop it hands a mass of
negotiating advantage to the European
Union that weakens our negotiating
position in a most critical phase of our
uh uh the next stage to uh obtain a free
trade agreement with the European Union
and that's why I don't believe it's in
the interest of the United Kingdom of
course I give way because we hear a lot
about this back stop that it's something
that uh the EU doesn't want to implement
nor the UK and also that it's going to
be temporary
if that is the case why does he believe
that the European Union will not budge
on at least giving it a Time limited
Essence well I believe Mr Speaker that
the reason for that is because it gives
a negotiating advantage to the European
Union and it doesn't want to give up
that Advantage uh in favor of the United
Kingdom and what offends me about the
back stop uh and its potential um is
what the Attorney General described in
his advice uh to the government um that
Northern Ireland would have to treat
Great Britain as a third country for
trading purposes now the attorney told
us today that this already happens and
he gave the example of the Canary
Islands but the Canary Islands isn't
leaving the European Union the Canary
Islands will still have representation
will still be able to influence the way
in which regulations are drawn up by the
European Union not so for Northern
Ireland under the back stop arrangement
we will have to accept regulations over
which we have no say in how they are
drawn up not at stormant if we have an
assembly back uh not here at Westminster
and most certainly not because the Irish
government will Advocate on our behalf
indeed the Irish government has shown in
the past that it will look after its own
interests first and rightly so it's a
sovereign state in so far as you can be
a sovereign state in the European Union
and so the back stop is not in our best
interest uh as far as Northern Ireland
is concerned but not in the best
interest of the United Kingdom and
that's why we need to see real change
change which the Prime Minister
described as legally binding and and
what is on offer at the moment from the
European Union does not have legal
effect and that is a concern for us and
it's why we cannot support the
Amendments that have been tabled before
the house because until we see a
commitment a clear commitment from the
European Union to alter the back stop
Arrangement so that the UK has the
unilateral right to leave that back stop
at the time of its choosing and in
circumstances which would be beneficial
to the relationship look we're not about
we are not about trying to create
difficulties here but what we don't want
is to hand to the EU a significant
negotiating advantage and nor do we want
to see regulatory barriers between
Northern irand and Great Britain that
would damage our economy in Northern
Ireland I respect the views been have
been expressed by Business Leaders and
by others in Northern Ireland who
support uh the uh the the withdrawal
agreement as it's currently drawn up I
respect their view but I do not agree
with their opinion that the current
proposed Arrangements will be good for
the northern irand economy the so-called
Best of Both Worlds because it isn't
that and it doesn't give us that it
creates a barrier between Northern
Island and our biggest Market which is
Great Britain a regulatory barrier um so
that we can avoid having regulatory
differences between Northern Ireland and
the Irish Republic even though we do far
less trade with the Irish Republic and
the EU than we do with Great Britain and
so although I'm no expert in business I
believe that it cannot be in the best
interest of Northern Ireland to have
regulatory barriers with our biggest
Market in order to continue uh having
free trade arrangements with the
European Union which is for us in
trading terms a smaller market and so
therefore we urge the prime minister to
look again at this withdrawal agreement
she said that she would seek to secure
legally binding changes and that is what
we need and what we have on the table at
the moment doesn't achieve that and for
these reasons the Democratic unionist
party will be voting against the
withdrawal agreement this evening and we
will be voting against uh the Amendments
because they do not change the
fundamental reality that until we get
the assurances we need on the back stop
we cannot support what is on the
table Mr Dominic grieve thank you Mr
Speaker entertaining as it was to watch
the theatricality of my rable friend and
learned friend the Attorney General I
have to say to the house that it filled
me with a slight sense of Gloom to see
that the government had got to such a
pass that it had to rely on the advocacy
skills of the criminal defense Advocate
to get it out of it its
difficulties we had everything we had
the appeal to
patriotism and the Bri Fields
Beyond uh we had the analogy of the
airlock in which we were assured that if
we placed oursel for a period of time in
an uncomfortable position we would find
that the door would open to the fields
of Ambrosia Beyond whereas I'm afraid my
own view is that we will either choke to
death in the airlock as a nation or when
the door finally opens we will find the
landscape little to our liking and at
appropriate moments we also had those
delicious moments of confession and
avoidance from the attorney uh when he
gently pointed out that he thought that
the uh uh the the suggestion that we
could have a negotiated deal without
transition had been overblown
who over blew
it the truth is that for two and a half
years and during the period of uh the
referendum we have been living in a
Fool's Paradise in relation to
expectations where was the back stop
mentioned during the referendum and its
constitutional implications that worry
so much uh The Honorable members
representing Northern Ireland
constituencies where was the 20-month
transition it now potentially extended
for 2 years and where were the complete
lack of concrete terms for a future
relationship that's the reason Mr
Speaker why we now have the problem that
around only 20% of the public appear to
think that this is a good deal and it
should come as no surprise that so few
members of parliament are also willing
to support
it and the difficulty and this is where
I do agree with the attorney in what he
said the difficulty is that we are where
we are we can't turn the clock back I
know some honorable members talk of
Alternatives and we can consider them
but I have to say that my view is as to
where we are is that the alternatives
are going to be very hard to come by and
in any case I raise an anxiety as to
whether they can be
justified one of the things I found most
curious as this debate is I keep on
being told that I must sign up to this
this deal because it would be a betrayal
of the United Kingdom electorate not to
and yet there are honorable members who
are prepared to consider for example uh
going for a Norway style option which I
have to say seems to me to be an example
of the elites picking up the carpet and
brushing the broken glass under it to
try to avoid the difficulties that have
been
created that's why Mr Speaker I'm both
respectful of what the prime minister
has tried to achieve accepting it is
probably the only deal on offer
realistically and might be willing to
support it if it had the support of the
public and yet we have spent months
trying every possible device in this
house to prevent the house expressing
any view that the public ought to be
consulted here and on that I'm afraid I
will not Bunch y pains me to see how the
discourse develops pains me as the
speaker to see you and myself accused of
being in a Sinister conspiracy uh all of
which is utter and complete fantasy it
pains me to discover the number 10 press
office briefing against me last Friday
for involvement in an initiative of my
right honorable friend the member for
West Dorset in which I had not the
slightest degree of
involvement such is the level of Madness
that pervades us at present and that
makes me all the more determined as the
death threats come in and the rhetoric
heats up that we must stay sensible be
willing to have a dialogue across the
house and to try to resolve this the
question now is whether the government
is prepared to listen for the present I
very much regret that I cannot support
the government this
evening Steven Dy thank you Mr speaker
it's an absolute pleasure to follow my
right honorable and learned uh colleague
on the other side of the house and I
agree wholeheartedly with the vast
majority of his remarks um today um Mr
Speaker I am in this house first and
foremost as a representative of my
constituents of the people of Cardiff
South and panana and their views are
absolutely clear um they voted to remain
in 2016 and that has increased in
intensity um I've had nearly 2,000
messages emails phone calls
conversations 86% of them now tell me
that they want to stay in the EU uh the
vast majority of those want to see the
question put back to them so that they
can make the choice and of those who
still want to leave there is a split
between those who want to support the
prime minister's deal and those who want
to leave with no deal so there is no
consensus on what even leaving means but
let me be clear Mr Speaker let me be
clear to everybody in this house people
who voted leave did so in good faith
they are my friends they are my family
they are my constituents they are my
neighbors and indeed I have very strong
and good relationships with many people
across this house who fundamentally
disagree with me on this issue of brexit
we must listen to the concerns we must
hear them they were uh made loud and
clear and we have to respond to them we
have to offer hope and we have to offer
a positive vision for the future but I
will not vote Mr Speaker for a deal that
will leave my constituents poorer by all
the measures all the analysis that will
leave them less safe no I won't give way
um that will leave them less safe and
that will actually lead to more
uncertainty not less and this process
going on and on and on that is simply
not acceptable when we are told by
Leading manufacturing organizations by
our trade unions by our businesses of
the jobs that are being lost that are
being put at risk and the livelihoods
that are being put at risk as a result
and Mr Speaker I wholeheartedly support
um the policy that my front BGE has
taken to oppose this deal it is
absolutely clear it does not meet the
six tests that the labor party set out I
of course want to see a general election
Mr Speaker I'd like to see this
government removed for many different
reasons but it is clear that we're
unlikely to reach that objective and so
we must try hard we'd like to see a no
confidence motion put down I think if
the Prime Minister loses tonight but if
we are not able to resolve this matter
in this house then we must put this
issue back to the
people I do not think that there is a
majority in this house for other
variations on the deal I do not think
there is a majority for the Norway
option as a a previous proponent of that
in this house I also do not think there
is the time now to engage in fantasy
negotiations with the EU it's been very
very clear from the beginning what the
possibilities were and the constraints
that were put on those possibilities by
the prime minister's red line and that
problem that has been exposed by many
people that failure to reach out at the
start of this process across the house
to find consensus to find a way problem
has led us to the situation that we're
in today but Mr Speaker I want to
address two particular concerns that the
Prime Minister and others have raised um
against those of us who Advocate putting
this issue back to the people the first
is that it is somehow anti-democratic no
it is not it is a continuation of
democracy and I understand very much why
the Prime Minister feels that she is
Duty bound to deliver on a result that
happened in 2016 but what about the will
of the people today as the right
honorable L gentleman has said if there
was clear consent amongst the public
amongst the people of this country among
my constituents among all the
constituents in this house we would not
be in the situation that we are today
where the Prime Minister faces defeat
from every angle and where we we will
have to find a new way forward and
secondly I hear the concern that this
will stir up far right or right-wing
rhetoric and and violence on the streets
and civil disturbances we must simply
not indulge that terrible terrible
language that terrible terrible uh
attitude those people do not represent
LE voter in this country we must not
give into them our colleague who was
murdered would not have given into them
she would have stood up against them and
that's what we all must be doing in this
house and Mr Speaker I have to say that
I do see this as part of a much wider
challenge it worries me deeply deeply
we've talked much about the economy much
about the business implications of this
deal but when the people rubbing their
hands in Glee at this chaos are Vladimir
Putin Donald Trump and the enemies of
this country we all ought to be asking
ourselves some very serious questions
now Winston Churchill was quoted by the
rable member for stone earlier on and
I'd like to take uh Mr Speaker take the
house to another uh quote from Winston
Churchill from the early 1930s where he
warned he said he warned of ignoring the
warnings of our followers in the country
of ignoring the signs of the times and
he said this was one of those awful
periods which recur in our history when
the noble British Nation seems to fall
from its highest State loses all trace
of sense or purpose and appears to cower
frothing Pious platitudes I think Mr
Speaker of global Britain of brexit
means brexit Mr Speaker we're all
Patriots in this house let's find a way
forward let's put this issue back to the
people and let them decide thank you
order a 4 minute limit back bent speech
now apply Shish
far it's a pleasure to follow the
honorable member for Cardiff South and
P Mr Speaker for nearly 14 years I've
been a loyal conservative Member of
Parliament but I do not believe that the
withdrawal agreement before us is in the
interest of my constituents or our
country and that is why in November of
last year I resigned for my post as a
minister in the northern Island office
allowing me to speak up against this
agreement and also to vote against it
later on
today the government has repeatedly said
that the United Kingdom's constitutional
and economic Integrity would not be
compromised however the legal
advice given by the Attorney General to
the Prime Minister on 13th November says
on page 2 paragraph 8 and I quote for
regulatory purposes Great Britain is is
essentially treated as a third country
by Northern Ireland for goods passing
from Great Britain into Northern Ireland
I raised this issue earlier on with the
attorney general but whilst his answer
was eloquent and articulate I'm afraid
he did somewhat fudge the issue we
entered the then European economic
Community as a United Kingdom at is and
it's important that we leave it as such
as we do so at in at the end of March
the withdrawal agreement sets out the
terms upon which we will negotiate a
future Free Trade Agreement but it is
extraordinary that we are required to
pay upfront 39 billion billion pounds
before we've actually negotiated the
deal
itself it is also extraordinary that we
agreeing to enter enter an unending back
stop from which we will not be able to
leave unilaterally effectively Mr
Speaker we are agreeing to be handcuffed
by the EU and they will determine when
they come off the assurances and warm
words are just bad warm words and
they're meaningless we are told that the
back stop will be temporary but
temporary has to be judged in context
and given that the agreement with Canada
to took 7 years with Singapore eight
years you can rest assured that
temporary means many years yeah yeah and
France and Spain have already made clear
that they will have conditions in the
case of France access to our Coastal
waters for fishing Spain writes as
regards jalter and they have said that
they will not agree to our departure
unless they have satisfaction on those
matters not only will we be held hostage
in the Customs Union in this way but
we'll also be heavily restricted in our
ability to do favorable trade deals with
the rest of the country
with the rest of the world of course I
recognize the need for compromise in
international agreements but Mr Speaker
this is not a compromise this is a
cave-in a cave-in by our country it is
an agreement that has been negotiated on
the basis of fear fear of being outside
the EU rather than a negotiation based
on
confidence it is important to remember
and the facts make clear that in the
decades ahead economic progress in the
countries outside the EU would far
exceed the progress within the EU Mr
Speaker what we are de debating today is
not just about today or tomorrow or next
month or even next year it is about the
decades to come it is about the future
of our children it is about the future
of our children's children we need to
get it right and this agreement does not
do that that is why I will be voting
against this agreement this evening yeah
Alison mcin thank Mr Speaker I am sorry
that the member for stone the member for
isan Walton and the member for voxa nor
the Attorney General are in their places
because I would like to say to them and
to all members of this house I need no
lectures on how to love my country none
of us do Mr Speaker we all care deeply
for
Britain but the fact is as the members
of the treasury select committee found
in our report published for this debate
before it was aborted in December there
is no dividend for our country in brexit
economically there is only
loss there is no brexit bonus there is
only The Madness of doing something that
we know to be a bad idea because we
allowed another bad idea to have a
referendum for which we were ill
prepared to take hold and I won't repeat
the cliche that people in the referendum
didn't vote to become poorer because it
doesn't matter now what matters is what
my me is what my friend for Cardiff and
panar said the choice is ours now Mr
Speaker should we vote to make our
constituents
poorer and I would just say this to
those who think that their constituents
will be angry if they don't back the
deal what will they say when they are
accountable for a permanent downgrade of
our economy do they think they can do
that without consequences either I don't
think so Mr Speaker we talk often about
wages in this house and the real issue
of wages and how they've fallen over the
past 10 years but to properly understand
the money in people's pockets you have
to understand if matters what they are
able to pay for and the fact of what has
happened to our currency since the
brexit vote has made us all poorer Mr
Speaker there is only more to come and
there's no escaping it and the reason
this has happened is because there's
there was a deep dishonesty at the heart
of the leave campaign they said we could
have Global Britain Britain open to the
world more globalization but also less
immigration more command and control
over our economy
and less
globalization and that is the root of
the impath that we have found ourselves
in that contradiction at the heart of
what people were offered and the truth
is because of that contradiction we
don't really know what the public want
now we've had a general election that
had an inconclusive result because
people were offered something that was
never really on the table and then voted
for it I know another referendum Mr
Speaker would be far from perfect but I
come to The Reluctant conclusion that
offering people a choice of the brexit
as we know it to be versus what they
have now and the deal that they have now
is probably the only way forward and
finally Mr Speaker I'd like to conclude
by just mentioning the thing that has
kept me going through the turgid debates
that this brexit discussion has been and
that is the reason that we should be
here for our aging population Treasury
select committee reports should be about
wages in nursing homes not brexit for
our young people we should be talking
about how to fund libraries and teaching
assistance not
brexit I ask myself the simple question
Mr Speaker by those objectives does
brexit help or is it a hindrance will it
help our country have the money it needs
or will it hold us back the answer Mr
Speaker is glaringly obvious brexit is
bad for our country and it's time we
took steps in this house that we know we
need to do to
rectify Dame Caroline Spelman thank you
Mr Speaker well I will be supporting the
prime minister's deal today because as
the West Midlands businesses who employ
thousands of my constituents tell me it
is good enough good enough for us to
leave and Thrive outside the EU not
perfect maybe but those who flirt with
plan B's must examine their conscience
when they hear the flight of Industry
this isn't a time for taking a stand
against the pragmatic reality of what is
actually on the table and in this regard
I credit The Honorable member for
gainsberg for recognizing this right now
what business needs is some certainty
with just 73 days to go before we leave
the EU firms are already having to take
costly decisions to stockpile goods and
parts and in some cases mothball
production capacity and the cost of this
hits their bottom line and ultimately
results in having to let people go the
car industry for whom the EU is the
principal Market is particularly hurt by
this let's remember its factories are
drawing workers from some of the most
deprived parts of the UK colleagues may
not have lost jobs in their
constituencies yet but in the West
Midlands we certainly have I call on the
government to find a way to help the UK
car industry such an important employer
exporter and life Transformer through
the challenges they face these grieve me
deeply as the Renaissance in
manufacturing has transformed the lives
of my constituents take for example The
Single Moms on the council state in my
constituency you've taken up well-paid
jobs through apprenticeships with
companies like jaguar Land Rover when
Dawn not her real name shows up in my
surgery next week to complain about
losing her job the thing she understands
is project fear is not being able to
keep up the mortgage payments on the
home she has provided for her kids so
what can we do to stop this inescapable
human cost at very least as a parliament
we must stop the UK crashing out of the
EU without a deal there is a majority
for no to no deal in Parliament the
letter i co-authored with the honorable
member for Birmingham erdington
attracted 225 MP signatures I and other
honorable members have tried to withdraw
amendments tonight which could have
wrecked the meaningful vote but we
remain determined to rule out no deal
businesses tell me they have roughly 14
days to decide whether to shut factories
to whether the storm of disruption after
we leave the EU or stockpile at huge
expense the least we can do is to
provide a stable platform or Foundation
by ruling out no deal the hit on
business is taking place now 90% conc of
the cbi's members are stockpiling as
well as thees in their supply chains
spending billions on contingency they
would otherwise used to invest 10,000
lorries pass through do every day just
in time delivery will become not in time
delivery with the slightest hold up at
the border the path the country has
chosen is Frau with risk even if in time
opportunity beckons so let us at least
manage the risk of a no deal brexit so
that constituents like Dawn don't face
losing their jobs their homes and their
livelihoods and a second Church States
commissioner uh Mr Speaker I'd expect
you might expect me to make some
reference to something profound the
Archbishop of Canterbury had to say in
the debate in another place that leaving
without a deal would be a political
practical and moral failure I Echo the
words of the hon right honorable
gentleman F Leed Central that we must
come together trying to unite and bring
Unity to our country here here Brad Shaw
given the time constraints Mr Speaker I
shall focus on what should happen later
tonight when this motion is defeated but
let me start by saying that if the UK
leaves the European Union under the
terms the government is proposing it'll
constitute one of the greatest acts of
self harm in our country's history we
will be poorer we will have less not
more sovereignty and we' be guaranteeing
that the uncertainty and political
wrangling that have so disfigured
Britain for the last 2 and a half years
will continue for years and years to
come it's increasingly clear to everyone
except perhaps the Prime Minister that
she and the country will face two
choices after tonight's vote to reach
out finally across this house to seek a
majority for a less damaging Norway
style brexit or to put her deal to the
public in a people's vote I am extremely
doubtful there will be a majority in
this house for Norway now if in 2017
after the general election when she'd
lost a majority the Prime Minister had
sought consent
she probably could have got Allway
through many of us repeatedly pleaded
with her to do so but she stuck to her
red lines for fear of what the hard
brexiteers in her cabinet on on her back
benches would do to her as recently as
last spring nearly 80 of us on these
benches defied our own party leadership
and voted for a Norway style solution
but we were rebuffed as we have been
repeatedly rebuffed when we've tried to
steer the government in the direction of
the least damaging brexit we now told
there are several cabinet ministers and
others on the benches opposite and some
over here who would like us to rescue
this disintegrating government by
backing Norway now well I'm sorry Mr
Speaker it is too late the overwhelming
majority of those of us on this side of
the house who back Norway a year ago
would not do so now the rest of Europe
which has shown commendable patience
with the British government has said we
we can have more time we can extend
article 50 but only for a general
election or another referendum not for a
tortuous renegotiation of the withdrawal
agreement with no end point which would
be certain Labor's policy Mr Speaker
unanimously agreed at our last
conference states that if the government
is confident in its brexit deal I quote
it should not be afraid to put that deal
to the public the Prime Minister could
at this late stage save her deal by
seeking parliamentary support for
conditional on the ratification by the
public in a referendum but if she won't
labor must act Britain's facing the most
serious political economic and
constitutional crisis in our peacetime
history the time for dither delay and
constructive ambiguity is over the
country is crying out for decisive
leadership so let us have our motion of
no confidence tomorrow let's test
parliament's appetite for an election if
we don't secure one let's rule out no
deal test if colleagues wish to the
Norway option but then quickly pursue
the only rational choice left for our
country which is to give this decision
back to the people I appeal to the Prime
Minister for once just this once put the
national interest first but if she won't
Mr Speaker Parliament must do that for
her Justine
Greening thank you Mr Speaker I I think
for every single sing Le Member of
Parliament in this house uh this is a
very difficult vote that we all face
this evening rep representing very
different communities up and down the
country and I think the additional
challenge is that brexit is not about
Party politics all of us are genuinely
asking ourselves how we can represent
our communities and do what is in the
best interest of this country I cannot
support this deal like many MPS that is
because actually whether I represent the
remainers in my constituency of whom of
course there are many who think that if
we are still following so many rules we
should be around the table setting them
or whether I represent the brexiteers of
whom there are also many in my community
they simply don't believe that this is
the brexit that they felt they were
voting for it just does not give them
the clean break from the European Union
and I would say that in many respects
brexit has been perhaps a failure of
Party politics at the leadership level
on both sides of this house because
actually far from uh thwarting democracy
actually today I feel I'm representing
my community because they have very
clearly told me what they think about
this particular deal and how they would
like me to vote on and I think the
failure on the front bench of the
government comes from the fact that this
has been clear since the summer this
isn't a
surprise that the withdrawal agreement
and the political declaration have not
found favor with enough MPS in this
house it was absolutely blindingly
obvious and I think for the front bench
to turn around and somehow suggest that
the rest of the house has got it wrong
is a bit like a person steering the
Titanic towards an iceberg and then
blaming the iceberg for not getting out
of the way so this is a real failure I
think think of number 10 and I do feel
that a bit of recognition of that would
not go a miss and of course the the
wasting of time delaying the vote from
before Christmas did no good whatsoever
I also think it's a failure of the labor
front bench uh the dither And Delay as
has just been described I think has
really shown Party politics frankly
probably at its worst at the very time
our British public needed us to step up
to the plate I I think that the the
election in 2017 simply compounded a a
government that was not willing to
compromise actually after a brexit
result that frankly was close and did
require compromise if enough people were
going to be brought with it um I really
do urge um members of parliament tonight
to not think about Party Loyalty that's
not what this vote is about this vote is
about the future of our country and I
think whatever happen happens tonight
and in the coming weeks we as a house
need to start finding better ways to
work together on long-term issues that
British politics has failed to deliver
enough on for the British public whether
it's housing whether it's what I care
about social Mobility an opportunity
whether it's the environment whether
it's social care the only difference
with brexit is that it was a long-term
issue that had a deadline and sure
enough we have not been able to meet
that deadline and it does look very much
to me like we will move from a fudged
deal to a fudged delay but it should be
a delay if we have it with a plan in
mind not with nothing um maybe this
house won't be able to agree on any path
forward if that is the case then surely
we need to do the right thing and
recognize that in a democracy when you
have big unanswered questions they have
to be questions that the public are
allowed a sail yeah Tom
break brexit and the way way it is being
handled is a national
embarrassment uh worse than that it is a
damaging International embarrassment
that great tactician David Cameron
devised what he thought would be a
cunning plan to staunch the decades long
Euro bloodletting in his party a
referendum but the referendum instead of
acting as neat sutures to bind together
the ideologically driven brexiters and
their more rational colleagues has taken
a scalpel to the Tory party's jugular
and critically and of far more
significance the countries to driving
the country to the brink and in some
cases being willing to drive over it is
overwhelmingly the tor's
responsibility now of course the the
leader of the opposition uh has a cameo
role of course demonstrating the same
aptitude for leadership during the
brexit campaign as he has
since but where I would share some of
the blame as a longstanding member of
parliament is not tackling the
conditions that led to a majority voting
for brexit blame that has to be shared
by successive governments not this one
not the one before not the one before
that and indeed probably not the one
before that either I regret not being
active enough in promoting the benefits
of being in the EU for students research
common standards for drugs or medicines
investment in places like the hospital
where the Prime Minister launched the
10-year NHS plan 50 million of Euro
financing or the potteries factory where
she gave her speech yesterday 400,000
from the European Union not being
outspoken enough in rebutting the
ludicrous infantile and mendacious
claims that Brussels based British
newspapers correspondents made about the
threat to British pink sausages or
standardizing condom
sizes most importantly I regret the
failure to tackle deep-seated concerns
in some towns and cities over the
failure to invest in infrastructure
underperforming schools to rebuild proud
communities devastated by the loss of
heavy industry I regret also that
Devolution wasn't pushed hard and fast
enough and responsibility funding and
accountability for delivering jobs
skills training Bus and Train Services
vested in politicians closer to those
reliant on those Services these
challenge remain and of course we owe it
to those who voted brexit and indeed
those who voted remain to address them
but does anyone anyone in this chamber
believe that brexit and the Prime
Minister so-call deal provides the
solutions they don't nothing that leaves
us poorer can the PM's deal of course is
nothing of the sort it's a fiction a
chimera a mirage the political ation
comes in at a measly 26 Pages compare
that to the 1,600 pages in the Canada EU
trade deal according to the primary own
statement yesterday the real deal our
future relationship is something that
could not be struck until perhaps as
late as as December 2022 and some
believe that is wildly optimistic and
that's one of the reasons why her deal
be defeated today I do not doubt that
with the red lines that she chose
herself this is the best deal she could
secure unfortunately it is a bad deal so
where next the prime minister's deal is
defeated we expect shortly No Deal has
been rejected by Parliament there's a
fresh round of negotiations with the EU
is very unlikely to be sanctioned by the
European Union so the prime minister is
left with one option put the deal to the
people in a people's vote and offer them
the choice to stay in the European
Union Owen Patterson Mr Speaker great
pleasure to follow the H member for
Carson Wallington who touched on David
camera introducing the referendum he
forgot to mention Mr Speaker that
actually it was a liberal idea to have
an inout referendum when we oppose the
Lisbon treaty and of course Mr Speaker
what we face is a constitutional
conundrum quite rightly the member said
we promised a referendum in out if we
won the 2015 referendum we then had long
processes in this Parliament
guaranteeing that we would give the
power to the people to decide we then
had the referendum the people decided
overwhelmingly to leave 17.4 million
people the biggest vote in British
history the biggest majority in British
history on any one subject everyone then
said what does leave mean and the
conservative party very helpfully
interpreted leave to mean leave the
single Market leave the Customs Union
and leave the remit of ecj and sadly Mr
Speaker what we come up with here does
not deliver that that's right this is a
betrayal of what the people voted for in
my last speech you can't ask me to speak
I touched on the impact on our laws it
is ludicrous that laws will be made by
27 Nations imposed upon us so we we
cannot query them you take the area of
Agriculture totally dominated by the EU
it is extraordinary that our agriculture
will be held back to levels of support
of 2019 throughout the whole period of
transition our competitors on the
continent will be better funded have
access to our Market on free terms that
is a particularly penalized sector of
our economy you take state aid we've had
a deal and guy this week showing the
horrors impact on defense and there is
no exit we know that the Attorney
General say there is no clear exit and
all this is happily going to cost us 39
billion with nothing promised 39 billion
to have the right to keep talking and
talking and talking there is absolutely
no incentive on the EU to end the talks
they've got us trapped they'll be
imposing law upon us they have access to
our Market they can clobber us when we
don't obey their laws through the
ecj and we will be pay what's not to
like and we saw it from har selm who
unwisely blurted out the pasao oppressor
that he'd got everything including the
cost of losing Northern Ireland there's
a real horror for me in this paper
carving up something called ukn a new
political entity in which not a single
elected represented from Northern
Ireland have any impact on that law is
shameful it is a complete breach of the
principle of consent which was embedded
in the Belfast agreement it's a as lord
trimol said it's a breach of the demand
for the assembly to be consulted so I
will not be voting for this thankfully a
very large number of other members will
also not be Ved for it what should we do
I went to see M barer with Lord Trimble
to discuss the problem of the Irish
Border which can be solved by current
techniques and current processes and we
have an incredibly instructive and
constructive discussion what we need to
do is to go back to the free trade offer
of the 7th of March from president Tusk
we should go back there on Thursday
morning and said yes we will engage in
very serious discussions on your Free
Trade Agreement in parallel we will
immediately tell you we are going to
World Trade Organization terms which has
come under the most ludicrous caricature
attack because it's synonymous with
leaving World Trade terms means we're
leaving it's not as good as a free trade
agreement but it does mean we're leaving
that will Galvanize the European Union
in coming back to us we've had harabas
today only only today the German foreign
minister saying he would come back to
the talks so we will do the country a
service tonight if we overwhelmingly
vote down this agreement which is
completely unacceptable pushing the euo
back to their generous offer of free
trade agreement we won't get it through
in time we trigger article 24 of Gat
which which means zero tariffs zero
quotas continue during the course of the
discussions possibly up to 5 Years thank
you Lisa
nandy Vision in this house I haven't met
a single member privately or publicly
who believes that this act stands a
chance of passing tonight on this side
of the house for many of us that is not
because of the withdrawal agreement
itself it's because of the complete
absence of clarity about what is to come
next three years after one of the most
divisive episodes in British history it
Beggars belief that we stand here with a
government asking for our votes but
unable to tell us even the broad
direction of travel I represent a
constituency with huge numbers of food
manufacturing jobs that are at stake and
there are two visions of the future on
offer one in which we retain close
economic ties with the EU with the
rights and the working prote and the
living standards that go alongside it
and the other where we follow the US and
China down a race to the bottom zero
hours no hope economy and that will have
profound implications for my
constituency and many others I have
discussed this with the Prime Minister
and I am grateful for her time but still
now as we stand here with hours to go
until this vote there is no clarity
about what comes next and I've have been
honest with the Prime Minister too about
the fact that
members of parliament like me who from
the beginning have sought a way through
this and have looked for reasons to vote
for this withdrawal agreement need
confidence that there is a role for
parliament in what comes next we are a
deeply divided country we represent a
range of views in this house and all
parts must be heard but I say to this
Parliament too to my friends and
colleagues here that we collectively
have not risen to this challenge I've
heard members on all sides pretending
that no deal is a political hoax not a
legal reality I've heard members
pretending that you can resolve no deal
and avoid that catastrophic scenario by
simply wishing or voting it own you
cannot we cannot continue to grandstand
to remain in our entrenched positions to
call one another traitor as I've heard
again in this debate today despite death
threats abuse and the murder of one of
my colleagues in recent years it will
not do and I later both the front bench
opposite and my own front bench here too
none of us will hang on to power or the
prospect of Power by a slight of hand we
are here to lead and in the country's
interests not our own I haven't seen a
level of anger directed towards MP since
I was first elected nearly 10 years ago
during the expenses Scandal we are
playing with fire here we are breaking
our democracy but here is the hope the
public are better than we are and for
all that the extremes have tried to
drown them out there is a decent
sensible pra pragmatic majority in this
country who want a way through we cannot
go on arguing about the will of the
people and nor can we keep dividing
people with our binary choices let's ask
them to help us resolve this as they did
in Ireland in Canada in Australia and
this week president macron in France
responding to widespread unrest in just
seven year weeks
a Citizens assembly could make
recommendations to this Parliament that
would help help us break the dud loock
it will not offer us an escape from hard
choices or rest Spike from them there
are choices that have to be made we are
now in a situation where every option
facing this country has costs there is a
clear tradeoff between Democratic harm
and economic harm and we have to be
honest with people but nearly 3 years
after the referendum we cannot continue
to lie to the people it is time after
this vote Falls tonight to begin to work
together and to tell the
truth sub Mr Speaker and I agree with
the honorable member for Wigan it's
imperative as we face this the most
important decision that this house has
made in Generations that we are indeed
honest with our constituents that we
tell them the truth and we all of us act
in the National interest not just for
our constituents but of course for the
generations to come and in that spirit I
don't hesitate to say Mr Speaker that I
believe that our great nation has made a
terrible mistake in deciding to leave
the European Union not withstanding that
I voted to honor the referendum result I
voted to trigger article 50 and then I
reached out to my government across
these benches to find and work and seek
some sort of consensus that would
deliver on that referendum result whilst
doing the least possible damage to our
economy and avoiding any hard Border in
Northern Ireland but Mr Speaker as you
know and other who followed this debate
it was all in vain and it was with a
heavy heart that I and many others came
to the conclusion that the only way out
of this impass was to take this back to
the British people and as we've thought
it and we thought about it and we've
talked to people it's absolutely clear
it is the right thing to do it's right
not just for those who are entitled now
they know what brexit looks like to
change their minds it's also right for
those older Lea voters as they consider
their children and their grandchildren
to put their in interests first and
began to change their minds and of
course for the young people who didn't
have the opportunity to vote because of
their age now two and a half years later
to have a say about their future because
they will bear the burden of it all Mr
Speaker I agree with so much of what's
been said by so many honorable and right
honorable members and if anybody on this
side of the house is still not sure
about how to vote tonight I don't ask
them to agree with me in my analysis I
come up this from a very different
perspective if I may suggest to my
honorable friend the member for
Northwest Cambridge here who I thought
in his speech beautifully unpicked the
whole of this deal and explained why in
good solid careful terms why it is
indeed such a bad deal it must be voted
against and I would not for one moment
say to him or any of the other people
with whom I have on these side such huge
disagreements that anybody is in any way
being undemocratic tonight in voting
against this deal because I know
although I don't agree with many of
their reasons that they are voting
because they feel it's the right thing
to do they believe it's in the natural
in the National interest and that must
be right Mr Speaker it must also be
wrong for anybody to vote in favor of
this deal because they have in effect
been blackmailed into thinking that the
alternative is no deal that is simply
not the case we've heard the
Alternatives that are available whether
it be a people people's vote whether it
be this bill that has been put forward
but it also can't be right I gently say
to dear friends on this side to vote for
this deal on the Bas it's it's a
terrible deal how on Earth does that
make sense how does one explain that to
one's constituents it can't be right to
vote for this deal on the basis that
it's so bad you've actually got some
cunning plan of an alternative to it but
when it fails you're going to put
forward and it can't be right and I say
gently to dear friends on this side to
vote for this deal on the basis that as
one said to me my Association would tear
me to pieces if I didn't Mr Speaker this
is a bad deal and we must vote against
it nobody voted to be poorer it's also a
terrible leap in the dark and I say with
great respect to my honorable right
honorable friend for rushcliffe it
absolutely doesn't provide the certainty
that British business is crying out for
it is a deal that must be rejected we're
meant to be the party of business and
it's bad for business the party of the
future and it's bad for young people
let's all come together and vote against
this deal
frankfield over the last weekend as it
was clearer and clearer how the
political traffic was moving I changed
my mind on how to vote tonight before I
was going to vote against the government
motion I will now vote for it and I wish
to explain that but for all the problems
that we've had my very honorable friend
F Wigan said about the nastiness in this
debate the nastiness comes because we've
indulged in a referendum because we
thought the people would agree with us
and we found it impossible to
incorporate in a representative system
of government a delegate system of
government operating from referenda so
the idea we want more of that PO Poison
by having another vote is the last thing
that I'm actually going to move to but
my I've
changed my mind because for all the
weaknesses of this agreement the
government has put forward to us for all
of its
failings um uh I believe we now risk
losing
brexit that doesn't excuse the
government for their incredibly Inc UNC
competence it doesn't mean that some of
us when this stage is over won't push
for a d andel's type inquiry to find out
why we landed at this late hour in this
desperate position that we are but I do
not wish to live my time as a member of
parliament for burken head aiding and
betting those whose real aim is to
destroy brexit it does Mr Speaker give
us five Advan vages that I campaign for
in supporting brexit first of all it
fulfills the promise that we will
control our
borders secondly after the transition
zone we will be free of paying cash the
any cash uh to the European Union
thirdly it will give us British laws for
British people
fourthly it will allow us to
negotiate new trade
agreements and fifthly the Prime
Minister has answered on three occasions
to me in the house it will offer us
frictionless trade for our manufacturing
industry we have some manufacturing
industry left in birkenhead we have
voxel's manufacturing down uh the uh the
the WHL towards I call it the main land
um but I take heart that the car
manufacturers Association said that this
was the best deal that they could accept
and that the car industry as far as
brexit goes will actually uh be
safeguarded but I want to end on the uh
on the note that my very honorable
friend uh for Wigan not uh mentioned it
hasn't been one person who's been
roughed up we're all pushed and poked
and uh by um ex enthusiasts let's call
them on the outside all of them wishing
to stop those views which they do not
wish to hear from being
heard and one of the things that
representative government has done not
delegate referenda government has done
has always given us a chamber where
people can listen to views and that
they're not somehow held to account as
we are
by a group outside who's actually given
us instructions we may not like it in
this house we may have misjudged our
electorate we may think they were
foolish to actually give us uh those
instructions we asked for instructions
and they gave us instructions to
leave thank you sir Edward Lee Mr
Speaker I beg to Lou move Amendment B in
my name and other honorable friends uh
which you have selected to be voted on
tonight it's obvious that one of the
main problems with this agreement is of
course the Northern Ireland back stop
and the fact that there is no ability by
ourselves to end it unilaterally and
there is no end dat settting it and
therefore my Amendment addresses this
problem by saying that if becomes clear
by the end of 2021 the European Union
will not agree to remove the nor and
Island backtop the United Kingdom will
treat the indefinite continuation of the
backstop as a fundamental change of
circumstances and will therefore abgate
those parts of the withdrawal agreement
this is a vital point because under
international law if you sign a treaty
saying that under the treaty something
will be temporary and it turns out to be
permanent or semi-permanent you surely
have the right to abgate those parts of
the treaty and when people say that
Amendment B is defective in law I ask
them to look at my Amendment R which
sets out international law in this
regard and it would be perfectly
possible allowable and in accordance
with precedent under international law
for the government when they sign this
treaty to issue what is called a letter
of reservation making it
clear so
I will The Honorable lady allow me
because there's so many others people
get in less people get in so I believe
that what my amendment is trying to do
is to achieve a compromise to try and
unite as many people as possible around
a deal I have to say that having done my
level best
to try and help the government to
achieve this compromise I am somewhat
disappointed that the Attorney General
appears to have slapped it down
following my intervention on him and
therefore I do reserve the right if the
government are not prepared to support
this amendment in fact to vote against
the main
motion why because I believe that the
fundamental problem with this withdrawal
agreement is and therefore I think I
speak for many conservative members of
parliament it is the fear that the
Northern Ireland back stop will become
permanent and therefore we have to find
a way of solving this problem and I have
no doubt that if the main motion is lost
tonight that the government will go back
to Brussels and will try and get some
movement on this issue but actually you
do not need to unpick the withdrawal
agreement you can do do this
unilaterally under international law and
I think it is perfectly possible
feasible that if the government went
back to Brussels if they informed them
of their right to issue a letter of
reservation making clear that we cannot
allow this backs stop to be permanent I
don't believe that that would actually
destroy the whole deal I agree that we
have to try and get a deal you know I I
want there to be a deal with the
European Union that's what I've been
asking arguing for I do not want to risk
brexit and I follow the words of the
right honorable member for Buren head
I'm aware that this might be in many
respects the best deal that we're going
to get I don't want to walk through the
same lobby as members of the opposition
I don't want to please Tony Blair who
wants there to be chaos so he can argue
for a second referendum I want to bind
this party together and find a
compromise and the compromise is staring
Us in the face that this one last issue
needs to be resolved then we can unite
get a deal and move things forward order
after the honorable gentleman the member
of
Halton who is the next speaker to be
called the time limit will have to be
reduced to three minutes on account of
the level of demand it's a pleasure to
welcome the honorable gentleman for hton
back to the house Mr Derek twig thank
you Mr Speaker Mr speak over 57% of uh
voters in Holton uh voted to leave the
EU um and I do find it condescending and
disrespectful for those who say that
they didn't know what they were doing um
it was veryy clear the overiding message
I had from my cons who voted to come out
of the EU was that they wanted to end
three movements of Labor and they wanted
to take back control and have more
control over our laws now whether
rightly or wrongly people genuinely feel
that is the right thing to do to leave
and that it would be a better future for
us out there but I also recognize that a
large number of my constituents who want
to stay in and like me believe
passionately that brexit is not in the
UK's best interest but have also
listened to those those their concerns
but I made it clear at the general
election in 2017 that we must get on
with brexit and to call the best
possible deal I do not think it should
come any surprise to anyone that it was
going to be difficult the Prime Minister
could have reached out from an early
stage to Parliament and the opposition
but chose not to and included she could
have reached out more to the country as
a whole to the public she cannot command
a majority but acts as if she has one
she wanted to keep MPS at arms length
prime minister must take must take a
great deal of responsibility for the
mess we in our in I should also add Mr
Speaker that I I've had constituents
including those who voted to remain
complain to me about the arrogance and
the behavior of the EU in the
negotiations as well so it's not just
the Prime Minister that has a sh for to
blame it's it's only now that the deal
is in trouble that the prime ministers
wanted to have discussions with a wider
set of MPS including back including
opposition MPS the idea that we should
just accept the first deal uh the PM
puts to the house and not challenges
those smacks of the arrogance I I
referred to earlier she expects that
parli should just roll over and accept
it and then try and use the threat of a
of a no deal brexit just insults our
intelligence when we know there's not a
majority for that in in this house and I
might add at this stage that the leave
campaign said during the campaign that
they wanted to see a negotiated
settlement there was so I do not believe
there's a majority in this country for
uh leaving the EU without a without an
agreement uh Mr Mr Speaker uh in this
deal we're neither fully in or fully out
and we have to abide by the rules what
we have no say in what others will be
making decisions with while we look on
we are real takers we are in a weaker
position than what we are
now there are too many unresolved issues
of great importance to our national
interest the prime minister is asking us
to take a big leap into the
dark 90% of those constituents who have
either written to me or have spoken to
in recent weeks believe this is a bad
deal and that includ that is both levers
and
remainers if this deal is rejected I
believe it will send a strong message
back to Brussels that we must find A
Better Way Forward and a better
agreement and that this Parliament will
will not be deterred from demanding a
better deal I will be voting against
this deal because it is bad for my
constituents in hton and bad for the UK
as a whole I believe we've got to find a
way forward we've got to cooperate and
work together in the National interest
to find a solution that the people want
us to have and that means talking more
to people it means getting across the
issues and the difficulties that we
envisage but we must have that
cooperation in order we can move this
forward there may be a number of ways of
doing that Mr Mr Speaker and indicative
votes has been one of the things being
talked about uh during the debate
tonight but the fact is we have to
listen we have to cooperate we have to
find a better way of moving this forward
because it cannot continue the way it is
yeah yeah thank you very much indeed the
three minute limit now applies Steven
Krab thank you Mr Speaker pleasure to be
called in this important debate defeat
of the withdrawal agreement is an near
certainty tonight so we're being told as
a result of the entirely predictable
coming together of the no dealers with
the no brexiteers but also crucially Mr
Speaker because of the failure of the
government to build a critical mass of
centerr support for the deal and given
the overwhelming numbers voting against
this deal tonight feels almost like the
easier thing to do but what if you are
someone who genuinely believes in
respecting and implementing the outcome
of the referendum result yeah yeah but
if you also believe that brexit was also
was going always is going to be a
process rather than a one-off event and
if you believe that leaving the EU
should be done in a way that's
responsible and orderly and that certain
vital economic and constituency
interests should be taken into account
and if you also believe that squaring
off brexit against the Northern Ireland
peace process was always going to
require incredibly sensitive handling
and if you believe that compromises were
always going to be inevitable because
the theory of a perfect bre brexit was
always that a theory
then what is the right approach then not
the easy approach what what is the right
approach and I'm clear that as somebody
who believes all of those things voting
for the deal tonight is the right thing
to do and we have a serious
responsibility in this house today and
particularly that responsibility weighs
most heavily on this side of the chamber
because it's we as the party in
government who made this referendum
happen we triggered article 50 we're
responsible for the timetable we helped
shape the the prime minister's red lines
in
negotiation so it's not the prime
minister's deal that's on the table for
discussion it's our deal it's got all of
our names already attached to it and the
question for us tonight is whether we
are responsible enough to come together
and pragmatically support this to
provide a way forward and direction for
the country or whether we abdicate our
responsibility and disown the very deal
that we as a party in government help to
shape and I say respectfully to those
colleagues of mine who for a long time
have fought the Battle for brexit were
there right at the very beginning we've
heard a number of good speeches from
them this afternoon the question I would
put to them is brexit always going to be
some oppositional Insurgency that's
forever saying no to things a vehicle
for permanent discontent absolutely or
can brexit ever be seriously implemented
as a program for government and I say Mr
Speaker I was was serious when I
promised my constituents that I would
Implement brexit as a program of
government and that's why I'm voting for
the deal this evening because I believed
what I said I took seriously the
promises that I made to my constituent
it's too easy now to walk away the
responsible thing to do is back this
deal tonight angers Brendan mcneel top
to Mr Speaker at six long weeks since
this process began on the 4th of
December and I'd just like to start with
a book recommendation Mr Speaker you
find it very good reading in fact a fent
nul's heroic failure brexit and the
politics of pain it's a great read Mr
Speaker it tells about the psychology
behind brexit exactly why they got
themselves in this situation the colon Z
there will we be a colony the J to
possession of every emotion uh but it
really The Madness of brexit is well
cath the Irishman Fint in the tool and
he starts off with a great Turkish
proverb saying an Englishman will burn
his bed to catch a flea and that's
exactly what brexit feels like so I I
would appeal to you please don't burn
your B please revoke article 50 for your
own good you probably would't listen but
anyway I've said
it how did we get here well the prime
minister went and triggered article 50
on March the 29th um she had not much of
a thought on March the 29th 2017 and
then I remember I was fencing my
potatoes a few weeks later Mr Speaker
and round came the news that she was now
holding a general election I was a bit
surprised I thought maybe the Prime
Minister had a plan but clearly from
that moment on fencing my potatoes I
knew she didn't have a plan it was very
obvious and then SE month later she went
to Florence of all places no idea why
she went to Florence to beg the European
Union for two more years they gave her
21 months uh and this is what she's now
fighting about her whole strategy with
any foresight whatsoever it was only
beaten by the right honorable leader of
the opposition who wanted to trigger
article 50 immediately meaning the
disaster would have already happened it
goes on without any cognizance to the
needs of the fauland islands or jalter
who do want any of this nonsense and I
know this is damaging to them if you
speak to any of the representatives you
will understand that yeah now when I
spoke to the Prime Minister last week
when she eventually engaged with MPS it
was pretty clear that she was at sixes
and sevens she wanted frictional trade
but had no idea or seemed not to
acknowledge that she' need to be in the
Customs Union and the single Market to
achieve that I saw today the Attorney
General being Bamboozled by the the the
idea of fish as a commodity I don't
blame the Attorney General from being
Bamboozled his own prime minister in ji
couldn't answer that point she couldn't
see the difference between fish quotas
and then once the fish were landed as a
market commodity and this is very
important for my constituency in the
island of Lewis Harris North USA South
Us in bar not to mention not to forget
of course VY erisi
scalpy Berner ber and grimsy these are
all very important matters but the prime
minister is not listening she
acknowledges the damage to GDP she said
so at the meeting and prime minister is
only wanting this deal to buy herself 21
month she is again playing the glory
again at card kicking it all down the
road and hoping she will survive she is
running out of road now and she knows
she's running out of road but one thing
I'd like to say earlier it was all
blamed on David Cameron but of course
the Liberals were the ones who started
this game in the beginning and that
should be remembered too many in the UK
have played the game of Europe This is
why we want to get out of Europe I want
to get out the United Kingdom as
Scotland we want checking you're paying
attention check you paying attention we
in Scotland will want out of the UK to
stay in Europe we see what Ireland's
doing we'll do the same H we're all
immensely grateful to The Honorable
gentleman Dr Julian
Lewis because brexit should mean
brexit and no deal is better than this
bad deal I shall vote no no and no thank
you Mr
Speaker Rachel
Reeves it's a pleasure to follow the
right honorable gentleman uh look Mr
Speaker and members of this house this
isn't about what happens this evening
because that is a foregone conclusion
this is now about how the Prime Minister
responds to the defeat tonight and where
she takes us and where the government
takes us next my select committee on
business energy and Industrial strategy
has taken evidence back in November and
December on these issues and I just want
to give members from all sides a sense
of that evidence and what businesses
said to us Paul Everett from the
Aerospace defense and space lob uh
business uh trade body told us that the
withdrawal agreement is not as good as
the deal we have today and won't ever be
as good as it is today Nestle gave
evidence to the committee and they said
that leaving the EU is like ripping all
the wires out to the back of a huge main
frame and then when you are standing
there with all these wires it will take
an awful lot of time to rewire us into a
different trading system the chair of
the American Pharmaceuticals group said
we are trying to rebuild what we we may
have taken apart and of course there is
now the news from Jaguar Land Rover
where they describe the perfect storm of
which brexit is One fierce element
resulting in 4 and a half thousand job
losses Mr Speaker we are in a position
where the government says that the deal
that they have negotiated is not as good
for our economy as the one we have today
we have businesses telling us that the
deal the government has negotiated is
not as good as the one we have today and
yet tonight we have the situation we're
in the place where the government are
asking us for vote for a deal which we
know will make our constituents poorer
our economy weaker and our security
Arrangements less secure as well I can't
in good conscience Mr Speaker vote for
that deal and I did not come to this
decision lightly my constituents voted
the way the country voted they voted to
leave but I don't think that there is a
single person in my constituency who
voted for the deal that we have before
us this evening and I don't think that
by voting for the deal that we have
before us this evening that we will heal
the divisions that we have in our
country since the referendum nearly a
thousand young people in my constituency
have turned 18 they are probably the
people most affected by the decision
that are making this evening and yet
they had no say in it I hope that in the
days ahead the Prime Minister will start
to listen as she has not listened so far
Mr Speaker to the voices in this house
and to the people in this country I hope
that she will rule out no deal in the
interests of our country and in the
interests of our economy and building a
better future for us all and then
allowing the people to have a say on the
deal that she has negotiated heidy Allen
thank you very much Mr Speaker I want to
begin by addressing the issue of our
divided country something repeatedly
emphasized by commentators I disagree
they are totally United United by a
pride in their country and a
determination that their Nation deserves
the best regardless of which side of the
argument we're on it's because we all
care passionately about the future of
our country and our citizens although
there is clearly disagreement like in
any family about the path to get there
we are united in demanding nothing short
of the best I believe therefore that
this shared determination and sense of
national dignity means we will find a
way to navigate these times and come out
stronger on the other side but we have
to find a way of uniting this place and
the people when I decided to become an
MP it was for one reason I wanted to
play an active role in assisting and
serving our country it wasn't for the
job title it wasn't because I had a
sudden urge for my friends and family to
think me honorable indeed they're
regularly quick to dispel me of this
myth it wasn't because I wanted a job
for life it was because I wanted want to
play my part for as long or as short as
my party and my electorate wanted me to
as a member of parliament you are a
custodian for a short time with a
responsibility to do the singular best
for your constituency and your country
and nothing else so I've approached my
role by applying analysis the
consideration of facts constant
unchanging and by listening to and
representing my constituents in South
cambrid as best I can so it angers me
greatly when I hear MPS say they will
reluctantly with a heavy heart Vote for
This compromise
not because I don't believe the Prime
Minister has done her best I have no
doubt that she has but MPS none of us
should be voting for something that
might make the economy weaker and risk
jobs how on Earth can we purport to be
representing this country to National
level if we are prepared to Advocate
that not good enough I say absolutely
not good enough if we're doing it to
protect ourselves our own jobs our po
our party or our own reputation within
our party then we should be ashamed here
here and if if that sense of Pride and
unwillingness to compromise in our
nation's future which result in me
losing my position then I am prepared
for that because Mr Speaker I will look
back at my time as a member of
parliament in this country's hour of
need and say I did my bit because lest
we forget we are elected to carefully
consider all the options all the risks
to read those lengthy documents and to
make the tough decisions when required
and I exercise those duties with the
utmost
seriousness I recognize of course I
cannot please all the people all the
time but from the thousands of emails
letters tweets and conversations I've
had with my constituents it appears they
are content with my Approach will she
give way I
willing I'm sure that many young people
in her constituency who particularly
want to make sure that their views and
concerns about brexit and listen to will
be particularly pleased to hear her
talking about how she approaches this
very important long-term decision that
affects them the
most because that is that is the most
important point because this is about
the future not here to today and
certainly not yesterday so here we are
today with a non-binding political
declaration that would inevitably and
indeed already has become a negotiating
tool for other EU leaders France for
access to fish Spain for game playing
with jalta and the biggest risk for me
the possibility that our next prime
minister may not honor the negotiating
principles in that declaration exactly
right with this prime minister's
position assured I would perhaps have
more confidence but there is a very real
danger that the government may be led by
someone who wants a hard no deal brexit
in that instance the political
Declaration on legally binding would not
be worth the paper it is written on so I
ask myself if this deal will definitely
improve opportunities for my
constituents will it really Safeguard
jobs will it guarantee scientific and
Med medical collaboration no no no will
it support our services industry which
make up 80% of our economy no they're
not even part of the deal so Mr Speaker
I have no regrets I have no reluctance
for me the decision is as clear as day
this is not good enough for my country
so let us harness what unites Us in
Great Britain and Northern Ireland that
pride and determination to demand the
best for the future let the people be
part of the serious decision let them
vote on this deal and let's ask them is
it good enough David Hansen thank you Mr
Speaker we are coming to the end of a
long process of which today is the final
day of the debate uh like the Prime
Minister I voted remain in the
referendum like the Prime Minister I
voted to trigger article 50 because my
constit
voted to leave in that referendum and
like the Prime Minister I want to see a
deal which meets the aspirations of our
business and our community of the
referendum but also to bring our country
together and I have to say Mr Speaker
that having reviewed this deal this deal
is not it uh I speak as a former Justice
and security minister in this house when
we had labor governments I cannot see
any proposals in this withdrawal
agreement that gives any comfort on the
issues of of europol on eurojust on the
European arrest warrant on cooperation
on CIS 2 sharing information on
criminals across Europe no contact at
all on those issues for the future I Can
See No Deal on trade in this deal before
us today which will secure the future of
employment across the United Kingdom or
in my constituency uh I had the very
great privilege of serving as a northern
Island Minister and I can see no
justification whatsoever for treating
Northern Ireland as a different part of
the United Kingdom given the history of
the difficulties in Northern Ireland
with the Irish Republic and colleagues
uh here today share that view and I
understand why that can also not be a
deal the treasury Zone figures show that
the prime minister's deal will reduce
the economy by at least 2.5% and
therefore I cannot support it but I
can't also Mr Speaker support no deal in
my constituency I have Toyota who are
going to cost 10 million pound per day
for the cost of a no deal brexit I have
Airbus nearby employing thousands of
people who depend on free and
frictionless trade that no deal will
destroy I have farmers in my
constituency who need to export their
goods which No Deal will destroy I have
Vox holes in my constituency who even
the prime minister's 2-year period will
mean that decisions about the next
generation of vehicles in Vox hols at
elere Port nearby will be taken with the
shadow of no frictional trade being held
over them so I can't support no deal but
I say to the Prime Minister echoing what
my honorable friend fed Central said
there is scope for a deal if she looks
again at her red lines if she looks
again at what I stood on in my election
18 months ago now for access to a single
market for strong rights at work for
strong environmental activity there is
scope for a deal I don't know what's
going to happen in the next 48 hours
there may be a vote of confidence it may
be won't it may be lost but whenever
that does settles Mr Mr Speaker this
prime minister and this government or
another prime minister and the same
government will need to contact the
opposition to find a way through this it
can be done it should be done and I want
to make sure that I defend the interests
of my constituency we will not be poorer
because of a decision that we can work
our way through thank you Mark
Pritchard thank you Mr Speaker in June
2016 after 40 years a generation uh my
constituents along with the rest of the
country were given a voice on the
European question uh my constituency
overwhelmingly voted to leave the
European Union and tonight I will honor
their views honor their voice and to
paraphrase my right on friend the member
for lra I will represent them despite
the fact that I voted to remain and
setting aside the details of the
withdrawal agreement for just a moment a
legally binding agreement I want want to
address conversations I've held with my
constituents rather than with
distinguished right honorable and
honorable colleagues and friends in this
house and my constituent vote to leave
uh did not uh suggest any fear of
foreigners or concerns about wage
deflation or
immigration but it did reflect an
understanding of that Universal and
overarching principle and principles of
Freedom sovereignty and Independence so
aily put by my right honorable friend
the member for Isa and Walton earlier on
and my constituent support for brexit is
not inconsistent Mr Speaker with a fond
affection for Europe shared European
values a belief in the rule of law High
environmental and employment standards
freedom of speech and their I said
democracy their decision is also not
inconsistent with recognizing the huge
contribution of EU citizens to the NHS
to UK farming particularly in shopshire
to car food and defense Manufacturing in
all these sectors EU citizens continue
to make and I hope will continue to make
a highly valued contribution to our
economy and our society brexit was not a
vote against Europe but it was a vote
for Britain a free and independent
Britain and I will not be supporting the
withdrawal agreement this evening
because it puts the United Kingdom in a
weaker position than our current status
as a full member of the European Union
it makes us as we've heard rule takers
uh but not rule makers it does not set
Britain free to implement bilateral
trade deals with other countries around
the world 30 so Mr Speaker much has been
said over many weeks in this place uh
about those that voted to leave the
European Union and I want to say it is a
higher principle rather than the some of
the low commentary that we've heard in
this place from both sides of the house
it is a higher principle that my
constituents have voted to leave the
European Union and that is the freedom
of this country the independence of this
country and the sovereignty of this
country thank you Gregory Campbell thank
you Mr Speaker can I first of all uh
commence by saying that this withdrawal
deal
uh as we read it at the moment keeps us
uh as an Annex of the EU not in a brexit
from it uh what I would like to say Mr
Speaker is this that uh in the past two
years there has been a narrative that
has uh developed both within the chamber
and across the nation and the narrative
is a completely and utterly false
premise that narrative is that the EU as
it is constituted is a place of safety a
place of security and a place of
certainty and to leave that is like a
ship in a storm and many people have
portrayed the United Kingdom as we leave
the the EU as being that vessel that is
facing uh uh an unfortunate and untimely
departure from a port or a harbor uh and
that completely and utterly negates all
that has been going on within the EU
over the course of the past couple of
years uh and and what what do we see is
the seedbed of that in the EU whether it
is uh National populism in Italy in
Germany in Hungary in Sweden France
Poland it is a sense and a feeling of
frustration of isolation of a a a sense
of political establishments not
listening not paying heed to what the
people say and what the people want and
that is what I detect in this country Mr
Speaker a sense of frustration a sense
of
alienation allowing an expansionist
Empire uh to keep us uh embodied as a
side Annex to that EU is not going to be
a good future it's not going to be a way
to show our children and our
grandchildren that this is the future
this is a future that we can look
forward to and aspire to what we need Mr
Speaker is after today uh assuming this
uh vote uh is CED in the way most people
think it will be the prime minister to
go back to Brussels and to say this is
not going to win I we need to have an
agreement that I can get past the House
of Commons and above and beyond that our
people in the United Kingdom will be
demanding not just aspiring to but
demanding that above and beyond a good
trade deal above and beyond that they
Aspire something greater something
beyond that and that is a sense an
ultimate sense of Freedom beyond the
EU Damien
Collins I also govern against the
withdrawal agreement I will not be
voting for this evening U I believe the
deal is not what people voted for in the
referendum and I believe it'll leave us
worse off and in terms of having less
control in our relationship with the EU
than we have today I believe there is a
lack of faith a lack of good faith and
that is why so many members across the
house have spoken against the deal when
the negotiations started we were told
there wouldn't be an agreement on
anything until there was an agreement on
everything we were we were told that the
future Arrangement and the arrangement
on trade would be part of the
negotiations in the deal we were then
told that an agreement on the amount of
money we would need to pay During the
period of transition would unlock the
process of discussing the future trade
agreement we are now told that we must
pay the money as part of the transition
with no obligation or requirement on the
part of the EU that we should meet the
that we should agree a trade deal we
will not get any of that money back if
the negotiations fail but my concern is
not just that my concern is the
immediate future what we are voting for
to happen now and to use the analogy of
the Attorney General of his key into the
airlock room which really is the back
stop he is right we can turn the key we
can go into the back stop but what
became clear through his remarks which
he didn't necessarily Express when he
used this analogy is that when we go
into that room our key is taken off us
we neither have a key to go back to
where we were nor one to go through the
door into the next space we are trapped
in the back stop and the EU have got
lots of good reasons to want to keep us
there they have us by default committed
to largely the rules of the Customs
Union they have us shadowing the rules
of the European single Market with no
say in how they're made they can sit
back and wait for something more
favorable and maybe they would something
like something more punitive too but it
leaves them holding all of the cards in
any negotiation on our future
relationship that is not a situation
this country should put itself in that
is not the basis to to negotiate a good
deal for the future which gives us a
good trading relationship and protects
the interest of this country as well we
should not give that away we're being
asked to do something now which we were
promised would never happen we're being
given a fetac company we're being told
you have to accept this deal otherwise
there's no brexit or there's no deal at
all I do not believe that the German
foreign minister has said today if the
deal is voted down that talks can resume
and they must do and it would of course
be a betrayal of the people of Northern
Ireland to lock them into a different
economic and political status without
ever having asked them whether that's
what they would accept and that's what
they wanted we have to reject this deal
today we have to go back to the
negotiating table we have to make sure
that whatever option we choose gives us
the freedom to choose our future
direction does not lock us into
Arrangements we have no power to get out
of that would be a betrayal of the
interest of this country and something
that I could not accept Steven Morgan
thank you Mr Speaker of Paul uh parent
importance is the notion that democracy
is a process not an event it is our duty
to defend and deliver the will of the
people from Portsmouth to Pickering
Penance to Peterborough it is essential
the referendum result is respected
however it is clear that no one in the
referendum voted for this Half Bake deal
put forward by the Prime Minister this
deal is a galaxy of uncertainty the
treasury select committee highlighted
this explaining that the government
analysis did uh did not assess the
short-term impact of leaving the EU when
this fact was put to the chancellor he
agreed if the chancellor himself agrees
that the deal is uncertain how can the
Prime Minister expect MPS to gamble with
the lives of their constituents so what
does this government's deal mean for
Portsmouth for QA hospital it would mean
sta shortages induced by the prime
minister's continuation of the hostile
environment a reduction in shared
research and international cooperate
cooperation and it threatens Prosperity
needed to fund a much loved local NHS it
rules out a permanent Customs Union with
the British say which is vital to
support portsmouth's businesses local
jobs and the manufacturing Supply chains
they depend on it also threatens
portsmouth's International ports which
generate 7 million directly to council
coffers to fund local services in an
area where third of children live in
poverty and a city forgotten for too
long by
government will this continue under Mrs
May deal whilst I've asked un anwers
questions remain Mr Speaker it is
inevitable that there are multifaceted
challenges posed by exting the EU in my
constituency we've seen a 12% swing
towards remain from a leave vote
uncertainty perpetuated by this
government still has left many others
with unanswered questions that's why 70%
of people in Portsmouth South want some
kind of final say when it comes to
brexit the people need Clarity the
people need control the people need a
final
say a noil a noale scenario Mr Speaker
would see those most vulnerable bearing
the brunt of decisions made by the few
if no deal brexit was imposed there
would be 29% increase in average food
import cost affecting people on the
lowest incomes
disproportionately this Palace in
Westminster is the birth place of
democracy where so many decisions have
been made to shakee not only our great
country but our world one thing I can
all agree on we can all agree on today
is that brexit is the most important
decision this country has taken since
the second world war my grandparents
grew up in Portsmouth my parents grew up
in Portsmouth I grew up in Portsmouth
the importance of this deal is not just
for us here today but for Generations
that inherit consequences of our actions
it is a privilege to stand here and
represent a constituency that
contributed so greatly to our nation's
success I cannot jeopardize portsmouth's
future by voting for a deal that would
make my home City poorer thank you
Robert
Halon thank you I voted rain in 2016
because I felt it was better for Britain
to belong to an alliance of democracies
however in my heart I felt that the EU
was both undemocratic and bureaucratic I
understood why people wanted to take
back control and the pressures that
Ordinary People face in their daily
lives particularly with the cost of
living and it was clear to me after the
referendum that the public had enough my
own constituency of harow voted 68% to
leave and I made it very clear to the
residents of harlo that I would do all I
can to ensure that the wishes for brexit
was followed through and it's why I'm
strongly opposed to a second referendum
which would divide the country once
again and disenfranchise 17 million
people who voted to leave and cause
political potentially cause political
unrest and extremism as many who voted
to leave would feel that their wishes
had been ignored I Do Not For a Moment
believe that the people were not
informed or were too stupid far from it
in fact it was us politicians who were
the foolish ones for not listening to
the anguish of many workingclass
communities over many years struggling
with the cost of living and the pressure
of on our Public Services doing the
right thing working hard yet facing
obstacle after obstacle after obstacle
in their daily lives so my view was that
any withdrawal agreement needs to ensure
that it follows the wishes of the
British people and the problem for me
with the prime minister's deal is this
how do I go back to my constituency of
harow and say we don't have money for
our libraries our hospital and our
community groups but we can give 39
billion of hard-earned taxpayers money
to the EU without even getting a trade
deal at the end of it when the House of
Lords said there was no obligation to
pay the 39 billion should the government
at least not have published a cost
benefit analysis of the money we wouldd
have to give to the EU under the
withdrawal agreement and we're tied to
the EU structures via the transition and
the back stop a Spaghetti Junction of EU
bureaucracy that potentially could be
infinite I have never rebelled uh
against the the current prime minister
in this Parliament but I will be voting
against the deal for the tonight for
those reasons because we create two
different regimes for Northern Ireland
and the rest of the United Kingdom which
has the PO potential to weaken our Union
we're in this Spaghetti Junction without
a vote a voice or a veto and that's why
I also trying to offer Alternatives with
a colleague on the opposite side of the
house um the right honorable lady from
Manchester a common market 2. not a
common market would actually Take Back
Control by removing us from the cfp from
the Communist agricultural policy Take
Back Control of our fish and our Farms
take us out of the European cour of
Justice offer us a a break on freedom of
movement but Safeguard jobs Safeguard
our community Safeguard business and our
economy thank you Shabana mmud thank you
thank you very much uh Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister uh said this morning in
setting up today's uh vote that we that
is to say Parliament mustn't and I quote
let the country down but the real
tragedy is Mr Speaker that ever since a
prime minister assumed her position and
began the process of implementing ing
brexit her way of handling this process
has done exactly that it has let the
country down because a vote won by 52%
to 48% required the language of
compromise from the government and the
Prime Minister herself at the outset and
not the language of red lines we are Mr
Speaker a divided nation not surprising
if we ask of our citizens uh to answer a
binary question in a highly polarizing
and toxic debate and no attempt has has
been made to reach out no genuine
attempt has been made to reach out to
the 48% to bring people together and to
tell those that found themselves in a
minority by a very small margin on that
day of the referendum result that this
is still their country too or by stating
unequivocally that all those citizens
who have been exercising their British
rights and their British freedoms to
dissent and to hold an an unpopular or a
minority position uh still arguing for
remain is not the act of a sabot or a
traitor but it is in fact as British as
it gets instead we have allowed the
toxic uh language and rhetoric to take
hold poisoning not just our politics but
our wider society and just as there has
been no reaching out to the rest of the
country by this government Mr Speaker
there has been no reaching out to the
rest of this house uh either the
Attorney General said it feels like a
very long time ago now at the outset of
his speech that we have reached this
point today reluctantly that is not true
Mr Speaker all of these uh choices that
have been made along the way choices
willingly and indeed willfully made by
the prime minister they have led us not
reluctantly to this place that we are in
today but inexorably to the place that
we find ourselves in today and it is
unforgivable that we have lost a whole
month a simple running down of the clock
because the Prime Minister was afraid of
what will happen inevitably this evening
anyway that is to say she will lose a
vote I cannot support the withdrawal
agreement or the political declaration
uh for many of the reasons uh that
members have already sat at not least
because it ignores 80% of our economy
and the services sector on which so many
thousands of jobs uh depend I will
though Mr Speaker support all and any
measures that allow Parliament now to do
what the executive has so demonstrably
failed to do and that is to commence the
search for a consensus I believe that we
should move to some indicative votes to
find what will command a majority in
this house we must take all and any
steps to rule out a No Deal brexit the
real tragedy Mr Speaker is that uh
brexit on any terms will not solve many
of the reasons why brexit took place in
the first place but at the very least we
must as a house must make the best of it
and find a consensus way forward thank
you Richard bacon Mr Speaker uh a
constituent of mine who voted leave
recently said I am sick and tired of
being told I didn't know what I was
voting for I knew exactly what I was
voting for recently on Bloomberg mvin
King the former Governor of the bank of
England said Britain is not facing an
economic crisis it is confronting a deep
political crisis Parliament has brought
this on the country it voted
overwhelmingly to hold a referendum the
people were told that they would decide
indeed they were on the 10th of November
David Cameron said at chattam house
ultimately it will be the Judgment of
the British people in a referendum you
will have to judge what is best your
decision nobody else's not politicians
not parliaments not Lobby groups not
mine just you you the British people
will decide it will be your decision
whether to remain in the EU on the basis
of the reforms we secure I emphasize Mr
Speaker or whether we leave in February
2016 David Cameron at the EU Council
then secured his reforms there was the
so-called red card where enough National
parliaments combining together might be
able to block a commission proposal
there were temporary limits on access to
inw work benefits for newly arriving EU
workers there were some limits on child
benefit and a vague commitment to reduce
regulation that was the deal it wasn't
very impressive but that was the deal
and that was what people voted on
whether to stay in the EU on that basis
or whether to leave and they voted to
leave the question in the Scottish
referendum was should Scotland be an
independent country if the vote had gone
the other way and unionists have then
said well you know it depends what one
means by an independent country or did
the people really know what they were
voting for this will make Scotland
poorer I can't possibly support it there
would justifiably have been outrage yet
that is exactly what is happening here
where the question was straightforward
should the United Kingdom remain a
member of the European Union or leave
the European Union that was the question
and the people voted leave the problem
is that some people have no interest in
respecting the result of the referendum
and they think they know better the
present situation recalls berl bre's
poem the solution after the uprising of
the 17th of June the secretary of the
writers Union had leaflets distributed
in the Stalin Alle stating that the
people had forfeited the confidence of
the government and could win it back
only by redoubled efforts and as bre put
it so devastatingly in the final stanza
would it not be easier in that case for
the government to dissolve the people
and elect another I will be voting
against this withdrawal agreement
because it will not deliver brexit it
gives the EU the right to impose law on
us indefinitely and a veto over whether
that would ever change well breaking up
the country by requiring Northern
Ireland to treat GB as a third country
and making us pay 39 billion even though
without a withdrawal agreement we're not
legally obliged to pay a penny and while
the former Chief of the defense staff
and the chief of sis both say the
withdrawal agreement will fundamentally
uh affect our national security people
voted for change what we want is a
self-governing country where we rule
ourselves we don't need this deal we
just need to
leave thank you Hannah bardell thank you
very much Mr Speaker at the heart of
this debate
are opportunities and rights the
opportunities and rights of the next
generation of young people across the UK
and the 16 and 17 year olds who didn't
get to vote in this referendum because
the government didn't think that they
were responsible year here now it's hard
to believe I'm sure but it's h some 13
years since I graduated from University
and when I was at the University of
Sterling I studied alongside arasmus
students I studied alongside arasmus
students who came from across the EU who
enriched our life who enriched our
country who enriched our education
system and I had colleagues and friends
who went across the EU and had exactly
the same experience but we are going to
deny those
opportunities to the next generation of
young people is a human tragedy and that
we are treating the EU Nationals across
the UK with such contempt is also a
human tragedy and when the Scottish
government and the first minister of
Scotland put the hand of friendship out
in the first few days after the
referendum unfortunately the labor party
were calling for article 50 to be
triggered and when we put the hand of
friendship out again in recent months
saying that we would pay the ridiculous
fees the EU Nationals were being asked
to pay this government has tried to
block it and the Scottish Alliance for
children's rights and concerns set up a
committee and they highlighted some of
the concerns like EU funding
opportunities to work to study and
travel
abroad and so much of what we hold dear
about the EU has been about our rights
and as a gay woman I know that this
Parliament and the Scottish Parliament
has done a huge amount for LGBT people
but as Mark tend wrote In The Guardian
last year the Westminster Parliament has
played its part in making amends but
without the carrot and stick of European
institutions would we enjoy the level of
protections from discrimin nation that
we now possess and I think that is a
reasonable point to make when you look
at this government's track record on
Trade union rights what happens what
happens when we don't have those
protections anymore where does that
leave us and in 2017 John Walker h at
the UK Supreme Court H
had his uh pension rights um inated so
that his husband would have the same
pension rights it was an 11year battle
against this government and we must not
forget the big boys that did it and ran
away those who got us into this mess who
are now nowhere to be seen yeah and we
also must remember Mr Speaker that my
constituents and the people of Scotland
voted to remain within the EU and when
the circumstances change and politics
moves forward as it inevitably does
people should be allowed another choice
Baron thank you thank you Mr Speaker and
I Rise to move my Amendment F in my name
and that of other right honorable and
honorable members
um very briefly the amendment would give
the UK government the unilateral right
to exit the back
stop at a time of its choosing it's very
straightforward we the UK could not find
itself indefinitely suspended in a back
stop if this amendment is passed it
would allow the UK to choose the time if
it did enter the back stop a time to
exit and it would not have to seek EU
approval to do so um Mr Speaker I I Rise
with some sadness I think the
negotiations to date have been um
approached as a problem to be solved
rather than an opportunity to be seized
I for one do not like the transition
period but in any negotiations
particularly after 40 to 45 years of
integration there has to be an element
of compromise and I'm willing to accept
that but the back stop I would suggest
is the real problem for many on these
benches spot on the government cannot
answer this very simple question at the
moment and it directly addresses the
indefinite nature of the back stop and
that is without any legal certainty with
regards our ability to unilaterally exit
the back stop what certainty is there
then that the EU could not play a very
long game drag out the
negotiations and by further extending
the transition period which it could do
absolutely could then we could be having
this discussion in three four five years
to come that is not honoring the result
of the referendum we need to leave the
EU we need to be quite definite about
this and the back stop is not the answer
because it is indefinite we could be
there for a very long
time I'm sorry I others need to come in
I do apologize but the the back stop by
giving a passing Amendment f it also
encourages both parties to negotiate
constructively when it comes to the
transition period and the TR great deal
because if the EU knows that they can't
trap us in the back stop then it is more
likely to constructively negotiate a
trade deal for the benefit of both
parties I would
suggest the PM prime minister could then
go back to the
EU the EU has a long track record of
11th hour deals I think it would go a
long way the amendment to help unite our
party which is terribly terribly
important so Mr Speaker
the amendment is not passed
unfortunately I will have to reluctantly
vote against the withdrawal agreement
Richard burden Deputy speaker can I
first declare an interest I chair the
all party Motor Group which received
support from the Society of motor
manufacturers and Traders the motorport
industry Association and the RAC
foundation and yesterday I attended the
first meeting of the development
partnership that has been established by
the business secretary in response to
the announcement that Jaguar Land Rover
are cutting 4,500 jobs this year now
this isn't a company in crisis indeed in
addition to the job loss announcement
the company were able to tell us
yesterday about the really exciting
forward investment plans they have going
forward but it is still a time of great
uncertainty for the employees involved
and there is a big role for that
development partnership in standing by
them I also don't claim that the job
losses at Jaguar Land Rover are only to
do with brexit the downturn in the
Chinese market is an important part of
the picture as indeed has been the
depression of sales of cleaner diesel
engines and shortage of time means I
can't go into that today but brexit is
part of that picture too and yesterday's
meeting reinforced to me my belief that
whatever else happens beyond all other
things the important thing now is to
rule out crashing out of the EU without
a deal it's not something that can be
mitigated you know whether it's a furry
company with no ships or converting an
Airport runway into a lorry Park it's no
answer for motor manufacturers or to
their companies in the supply chain to
have somewhere to park their trucks when
they cannot get those trucks to or from
the channel ports to deliver the parts
needed every day to build 6,600 cars and
9,000 engines here in the UK they need
to be able to get the 1,100 trucks that
carry these components across the
channel every day to keep their plants
going not just only on time but in the
right order to keep production lines
going and it's the same for the 3.4
billion pounds worth of components going
the other way coming from supplies in
the UK into the European Union to build
Vehicles over there and the only way the
only way to keep that production going
is not to make law efforts to try to
mitigate the chaos it's to stop the
chaos happening in the first place
investment decisions are now on hold if
we want to guarantee those and secure
those we have got above everything else
to rule out no deal and to do that we
have to decide what we do after the
prime minister's deal is defeated
tonight as it surely will be we've got
to buy ourselves some time to do that
because any other option will not be
able to be completed by the 29th of
March so if that means extending article
50 that's what we should do we need to
prevent a No Deal brexit by default that
is now the overriding priority
Jones in this house gave the people a
vote in 2016 the people had their say
and the majority voted to leave I did
not vote to leave but the majority did
and that must be respected now there are
lots of views as to how we should leave
uh the EU I take the view that I want to
stick as much as I can to our 2017
Manifesto that I was last elected on and
that did form the basis of what we have
in front of us today is the deal perfect
no does it get us out of the EU on the
29th of March yes and it gives us the
basis for having a situation where we do
Take Back Control of our laws our money
our borders our fishing our agriculture
policy and the basis of a trade deal I
do accept I accept totally the
challenges that honorable members across
this house have raised in relation to
the back stop and I've had to take a
view and balance that view Against The
Wider imperative I must admit I am drawn
uh to uh The Honorable gentleman for
Basildon Amendment and I was certainly
drawn as well to my honorable friend for
Southwest wilshire's uh Amendment and I
do hope that if this
uh vote fails tonight that we may look
at the situation in the context of those
types of proposal and whether or not we
can make further agreement with the EU
because I fear that if we do not work
along those lines uh we have two
distinct groups in this Parliament one
that want a No Deal brexit and one that
don't want brexit at all and I do fear
that both of those groups are going to
want to raise to the 29th of of March
both of them think they are going to win
but only one group can win I think if we
looked at it in terms of race the
favorite is probably no deal because uh
we have the legislation already in place
uh to uh work towards that uh but I
would not rule out following the events
that we had last week that the people
who want to stop us leaving the EU will
do everything within their power between
now and the 2019 9th of March to stop us
leaving so Mr Speaker I will B the deal
but I just want to say to the house and
to my constituents and I'm interested in
supporting this deal because I think
it's good for jobs I think it's
particularly good for manufacturing
industry in my area but I will not Renee
on the referendum I won't support
anything that extends article 50 a
second referendum or or doing anything
that will stop Bret we must leave on the
29th of March committed to that and I
hope the house will do that if we do not
ratify this deal in the coming weeks and
Liz Kendall much of this debate has been
dominated by questions about the
northern Irish back stop whilst these
are vital we must not lose sight of the
fundamental question we should be asking
ourselves tonight is this agreement
right for our country will it make us
prosperous and stronger and help us deal
with the challenges of the future Mr
Speaker it will not
the agreement doesn't secure our future
trading relationship with the EU as
people were promised in 2016 we haven't
even begun those negotiations and
despite what many businesses hope they
face huge uncertainty for years to come
but the truth is there is no free trade
agreement that will deliver the same
benefits as our current relationship
with the EU there will inevitably be
barriers to trade which will inevitably
make us poorer than we would otherwise
have been at the same time during the
transition we'll be giving up our say
over many of the rules that govern our
lives a say which whatever the
brexiteers tell you Britain has always
exercised to powerful effect within the
EU how is that taking back control
neither does the agreement provide
answers to the reasons why people voted
to leave in the first place as my right
honorable friend the member for wer
Hampton Southeast has said in many parts
of the country the brexit vote was
driven by a deep sense of loss loss of
the industrial jobs and the pride and
purpose they bought and a rejection of
what has come in its place I know from
my own constituency that many people are
angry and above all they want change but
the EU and immigration have not caused
the very real problems people face and
brexit will not solve them Britain is
actually better able to cope with the
problems created by globalization when
we're part of a strong group of
like-minded countries
and most of the powers to transform
people's lives lie within our hands we
should be offering people the chance to
succeed not something or someone to
blame and we should be making the
changes to our economy and public
services so people in every part of the
country can thrive in an inevitably
uncertain World rather than pretending
we can somehow stop the clock and make
the rest of the world go away Mr Speaker
I'll be voting against this agreement
tonight but time is running out we
cannot wait any longer to provide the
leadership we need to get us out of this
hole I will support moves to try and
build consensus across this house and to
rule out the threat of No Deal and the
chaos this would bring but I believe the
best way to break the Log Jam is to put
the question of where we go next back to
a public vote because what's on offer is
so very very different from what was on
offer in 2016 because it's right in
principle to say this is the reality of
brexit do you want to go ahead or stick
with the deal we have there is no jobs
first or sensible brexit and we
particularly on these benches should
have the courage to tell it like it is
the two-minute limit now applies Andrew
Salo thank you Mr Speaker people had
wanted to have their say on the European
issue for very many years when we gave
them the referendum on the alternative
vote the main question in my
constituency is why aren't you giving us
a vote on our membership of the Europe
European Union so 17.4 million people
voted to leave 58% of my constituents
more people voted for this than have
voted for anything and importantly
constituencies in this house voted to
leave and those people were promised
that their vote would be honored it was
the people's decision it wouldn't be
overturned by politicians or by this
Parliament and I don't think it would be
right to say to those people that we're
now going to have a second vote when we
haven't delivered on what they voted for
the first time now I think what has
become clear in the last month or so is
that there is a majority in this house
against no deal so if there is a
majority against no deal and if we then
vote down this deal the Alternatives
that are left Norway or some version of
it I think are so far from what people
voted for that we will have broken Faith
with the British people so what I say to
my friends across the house pragmatic
brexiteer brexiteers and Democratic
remainers alike we must stop an alliance
of people who want to stop brexit an
alliance of people who want an even
stronger brexit actually denying what
the people voted for conservat uh um we
know that business does not want a
second referendum that would lead to
even more uncertainty and I heard from
trades unionist today trades unionists
who who wanted to to leave saying it
will unleash an unprecedented level of
disillusionment in British politics
which will be unparalleled in our
history if we don't deliver brexit thank
you Mr Speaker this isn't a deal to be
honest the withdrawal agreement means we
pay3 bit9 billion pound for the right to
obey EU rules without the right to sit
at the table when they're being drawn up
and the political declaration is so
wooly it could mean whatever you want it
to mean or for that matter and more
importantly whatever the next president
of the European Council and the European
commission wants it to mean we have no
idea whether we shall have open trade
with our closest neighbors we have no
idea whether we should continue to share
information about dangerous
International criminals um or take part
in EUR poll or be able to extradite
criminals to face Justice across
European Union borders so it's bad for
British jobs and it puts our national
security at risk I'm angry Mr Speaker
that we've wasted so much money on
brexit money that could have been spent
on my in my constituency on decent
services but what pains me most of all
is that we British who have always been
proud to welcome strangers from other
countries we who have traveled across
Europe to build Great British companies
we who followed Churchill's injunction
to build a Europe of peaceful
cooperation we who pride in ourselves on
the rule of law and our robust
parliamentary system have utterly
squandered two years on a massive
distraction from the real subjects that
matter inequality poverty wages the
state of our public services and low
productivity and in the process we have
become an international laughing stock
anxious angry uncertain divided death
threats to our constituency offices I
have not heard a single member say that
this deal is better for Britain than our
present deal not even the prime minister
so how on Earth could we possible vote
for it consensus frankly is a delusion
in here Party politics has failed the
Prime Minister must build a new
Coalition and the people must have the
final say thank you very much Craig
Tracy again it's um no secret that I
voted to leave the EU as did the
majority 67% of my constituency and
nearly 175 million people across the UK
and I know the reasons for leaving were
varying across the country
but I've spoken a thousand to my own
constituents both before during and
after the referendum and they were very
clear in what they voted for they wanted
to see an end to free movement and
control of our borders they wanted
sovereignty for our Parliament and they
wanted the ability to trade freely
around the world and those are
sentiments that I very much
share I was Keen to see an agreement
delivered that I could support and um
critically the one on offer doesn't meet
two of those criteria set out by my
constituents returning of our
sovereignty and the ability to Fred try
and my personal concerns on the deal
similar to many in this house mainly
around the back stop and the future
legal
agreement as it stands the deal on the
table potentially gives away our
sovereignty and 39 billion P worth of uh
our money with absolutely nothing
guaranteed in
return um as I've said getting agreement
is the most favorable option but not at
all costs and I believe with this deal
that we have we're giving too much a
away but I don't believe it's too late
to change course we can secure
amendments which deliver wholly on the
referendum result and those changes need
to include getting rid of the Northern
Ireland back stop and having guarantees
on our future Rel relationship which are
things are likely to command a majority
in this house and importantly deliver on
the Democratic will of the British
people and it's important that is
delivered because people are so
frustrated at the games of some
politicians um who are seeking to
frustrate the result that was given so I
implore the PM to go back to the EU I
know they've said the deal was final but
they've moved on other things and we've
seen that they are able to change the
goal post when they um when they suit
and come back and give a deal that we
get
behind and before I start my speech I I
would like to take the opportunity to
pay tribute to the ply cry assembly
member Stefan Lois who very sadly passed
away on Friday at at just 54 he still
had so much to contribute he was without
a shadow of a doubt one of the party's
best Minds his inspirational vision for
lifting welles's status in the world
reached across the political divides his
influence and Legacy will endure beyond
our political lifetimes and we miss you
st the Prime Minister and her Inner
Circle have reached endgame run out of
Road in the project of misinformation
arm twisting and semantic chicanery of
my way or no way of partnership ship
proferred as the gateway to the future
of her precious Union she says she's
reaching out across the party boundaries
but it's just too little too late it is
sadly that the spirit of acknowledging
another vision of the respect implicit
in the sweet moderation of compromise
such politics are Beyond her her gaze
has a way of swiveling back to the
brexiteers fossilized in the strata of
her own party the rest of us and
especially the voices of Wales have been
invisible and unheeded here is a concept
of parliamentary democracy in the age of
devolution reduced to the Absurd Mr
Speaker she claims no Solutions other
than hers have been profited or are
indeed possible this tire political
Gambit now looks desperate it has
neither credibility nor
veracity Mr P speaker when we plead with
her to give the people the final say as
many of us had on the biggest question
of Our Generation the Prime Minister
commands us to honor the result of the
brexit referendum yet in 1997 she voted
against legislation to establish the
National Assembly for Wales and in 2005
stood on a Manifesto calling for another
referendum with the option to overturn
the result history has shown that she's
very much prepared to go back to the
people of Wales and so I would ask her
today why not
Europe thank you very much indeed 11
thank you Mr Speaker um we've heard time
and time again today in this chamber
that the people should have a final say
well people did have a final say and it
was in
2016 just because people in this chamber
can't quite come to terms with the fact
uh that the public weren't sufficiently
scared witless uh that they voted to
remain in the European Union is no
excuse for us not to listen to what they
had to say 57% of the Ribble Valley
voted to leave 75% of conservative seats
voted to leave 61% of Labor seats voted
to leave and at the last election labor
party and the conservative party both
stood on manifest that said we would
deliver leaving so therefore that's what
we have to do I know democracy can be
difficult at times but that is no reason
at all to deny the Democracy that this
Parliament gave to the people the
sovereignty going back from this house
to the people and they had their final
say I've got problems with the deal as
it currently stands particularly on the
back stop uh basically the European
Union uh have an opportunity to actually
chain us uh to the European Union
but of course they haven't got the
handcuffs so what we are doing is
deciding to offer them the handcuffs and
the key and I think that would be hugely
dangerous uh indeed I look forward for
the opportunities when we do leave to do
trade deals throughout the whole of the
world including the European Union they
um we we buy 341 billion pound worth of
goods from them they buy 95 billion less
from us it's in both our interests for
us to come to some form of Tri deal
we've got a 20-month transition period
when that can start but the important
thing uh is that we leave on the 29th of
March it's almost like Christmas day
I've got to tell you it's the 25th of
December that's what people look forward
to and if we if we deny people the
opportunity to live leave on the 29th of
March they'll never forgive us to Rena
ring K thank you Mr Speaker yesterday
working in my emergency department as a
doctor I looked around the waiting room
and saw it all on on display people's
pain their hopes their fears their
courage whether you are a mother relying
on food banks to feed your malnourished
children or you are a father waiting too
long for a cancer chemotherapy operation
this deal does nothing to improve lives
just as the NHS is tasked with healing
and prevention so we are too in this
house we have politicians and
commentators who continue to fuel the
rhetoric and fan the flames of hatred
Parliament once a symbol of hard one
rights through Democratic discourse is
seeing voices forcibly suppressed by
fear and intimidation people questioning
the very character of our culture in
order to tear apart the fabric of our
society this deal the language around
this deal and the empty threats used to
force us into supporting it are doing
nothing nothing to rebuild Britain
we can start the journey to rebuild
Britain by looking at the rising use of
food banks the numbers of operations
canell the number of police on our
streets now more than ever in this place
we need to take a long hard look at
ourselves and ask ourselves who are we
British people are tired of rhetoric
political games and uncertainty and in
the absence of a government which leads
this Tory government it is imperative
that this house set an agenda which
looks to repair the Deep wounds that now
exist within our society we need to dig
deep over the coming days and question
not only what sort of leaders we want to
be but what we are going to do and how
we are going to force our country to
heal once all is said and
done blunt thank you Mr Speaker amazed
to make it into the top 50 um I'm going
to try and make uh three three three
points um the first is to agree with the
honorable general for hon and my
honorable friend for S Norfolk about the
attitude towards the Le vote it wasn't
some Cry of Anguish or an expression of
concern it was a decision we gave the
people the decision and they took it um
the second point I want to make is about
the preparation for no deal and I'm
obliged to the anonymous civil servant
who uh concluded his piece in the
telegraph on the 28th of December as
follows an enormous effort by thousands
of hardworking civil servants has been
May to ensure that if we leave the EU
without a deal crashing out over a
cliffedge is simply not going to be an
option and it is purely a political
decision not to make this clear to the
public and nervous backbench MPS but if
the government was Frank with Parliament
and the country and we have authorized
4.2 billion pounds of expenditure on
this by the way um what justification
would be left for its disastrous
withdrawal agreement what would ROM
remainers do without a project fear they
would need to think up convincing
positive Arguments for staying in the EU
something that is so far proved Beyond
them and the final point I want to make
is about defense and intelligence now I
know that my right honorable and Gallant
friend the member for Mid Sussex has
taken an extremely dim view of Lord uh a
noble friend uh Lord Lord gri and Sir
Richard dear in the letter they have
written to conservative Association
chairman and he's perhaps quite right to
have the expression of a outraged
baitman cartoon um for their for their
behavior in that way however there was a
real concern that even my right
honorable friend was not able to address
when he didn't have time limited remarks
um last Friday about the substance of
what they are warning about in the
detail of all issues over csdp and the
rest that is that is contained um within
the European Ai and we would do well to
pay
attention good over thank you Mr Speaker
when I first first spoke in the
meaningful vote debate I spoke of the
shambles of this government's handling
of brexit of my alarm at the historic
mess of their making of my anger at the
contempt with which they have treated
this house and the people we represent
EXA I spoke of my constituent outrage at
the termoil the government is inflicting
on the economy and of the threat to
workers rights environmental stand ERS
that this brexit door represents I spoke
of the danger the government's approach
has towards EU citizens rights rights
that must be guaranteed no ifs and no
butts now 5 weeks later what has changed
the Prime Minister said she was going
back to the EU to get reassurances to
appease her disgruntled backbenches but
she has returned with nothing nothing
has changed as her saying goes we are
now being asked to accept the same bot
deal as we were then a deal that fell to
protect jobs rights or people's
livelihoods a deal that the government's
own analysis shows would reduce GDP by
3.9% and make every region worser a deal
that provides no guarantees on
maintaining key rights such as the
rights of disabled people which are
protected and found under the EU Charter
for fundamental rights all that has
changed since the Prime Minister ped the
vote is that we now just have 73 days
left until the 29th of March and it is
clear the prime minister is trying to
run down the clock and hold this country
to Ransom she is using the prospect of a
catastrophic No Deal to threaten this
house into accepting her botch deal this
is unacceptable and I know the people of
baty and the people across this country
are disgusted at this attempted
blackmail that is why I will be voting
against her deal and I encourage all
members across the house to do the same
Jeffrey Clifton Brown speaker I intend
to to change my mind I am a brexiteer by
DNA through and through we gave the
British people the opportunity to vote
in a referendum on the 23rd of July June
last in 2016 I intend to vote to honor
that in full but in return I expect my
colleagues on the front bench to pay
very close attention to my concerns
about this particular deal I actually
happen to believe we have a very bright
future outside the EU and the current
position is legal position is we are
leaving without a deal unless this house
overturns that legislation therefore the
ultimate irony is all of those people
who are voting tonight for against the
deal are more likely to end up with a no
deal I do not want to see that happen I
want us to leave with an agreed deal an
agreed deal that is acceptable to the
British people I have two main
reservations one is on the Northern
iseland back stop I think we do need to
get legal clarification as as a
withdrawal from that back stop in a
specified time preferably no longer than
two years the second major objection I
have to the back stop is that it ties Us
in to a customs Union with the united
with the EU I want to see us get out of
that Customs Union so that we can have
an independent trade policy because I
think the best future we have for this
country is outside the EU trading with
growing Nations around the world we
cannot do that while we're stuck in the
back stop I therefore intend to vote for
this deal tonight I intend to sort this
matter out from my constituents as I
promise
I intend to give businesses certainty
but in return I want the government to
come back with a better deal Tim faren
on the day of the 2016 referendum result
I called for a vote on the final deal
this didn't instantly meet with wild
approval my motives may have been
misunderstood because you see I am used
to losing elections I have never called
for one of those elections to be rerun I
am a very good loser I have had bags of
practice you see there is much talk
about the legitimacy of our democracy
and Trust in Parliament being tarnished
if we don't enact breit brexit on the
29th of March but what does it do for
trust in politics if we force the people
to accept a deal that most of them
clearly do not want let's not fool
ourselves nobody here speaks for the
majority there is no majority of the
people anymore the brexiters in this
place are voting both ways today the
brexiteers out on the streets peacefully
protesting are calling for votes in both
directions today I have the joy of
stopping for a few minutes good quality
banter with many of them last week we
should do more of that by the way but
some were asking me to vote for the deal
most were asking me to vote against so
the minority of my constituents who
favor brexit most are asking me to vote
against the deal some for the 17.4
million figure is now divided into at
least two opposing camps referendums are
an awful means of sorting out any issue
they are divisive they are dangerous
unless of course it's an issue that
nobody cares about like the alternative
vote but we have reached the place where
the only Democratic legitimate peaceful
and consensual way through this
appalling mess is to give the people the
final say let our future not be one that
anyone can claim was foisted on Britain
and not by politicians by this prime
minister's whiteall russels stitch up
let our future be one that is owned by
the British people that was endorsed by
the British people that has a legitimacy
that brings the unity and the healing
that only a final say can
bring thank you Ral J Warder speaker
it's a pleasure to follow my uh The
Honorable gentleman who talks about
winners and losers but this is not about
Winners and loses it's about what's
right and the Prime Minister has
repeatedly said that no deal is better
than a bad deal I believe a deal is
possible but this is not it this is a
bad deal now I know that some
both in this place and Beyond have
expressed their wish to agree it anyway
people who continued to campaign for a
main after the referendum in order to
guarantee that we avoid no no deal or
people that believed in leave but out of
part of loyalty or fear of brexit uh
seek to support the deal in front of us
I respect that others will vote as they
see fit it's important for every member
to act in good conscience but it is for
that very reason that I cannot support
this deal trust in politics remains at
an all-time low to pretend to pretend
that this deal delivers on the
referendum only continues to F to Foster
the distrust we've seen out there let's
be honest with people this deal doesn't
deliver on the referendum it retains the
worst parts of the European Union
without the real benefits of brexit so I
happen to agree with the vast majority
of my constituents have contacted me
both leave and remain voters who have
urged me to vote against this deal
nonetheless let me be clear I do want to
secure a deal with the European Union I
continue to believe that we can still
agree one and I do believe that the
negotiation now sadly does potentially
need to continue even after a No Deal
departure from the European Union on the
29th of March we must be bolder if we
wish to strike the best deal for Britain
whether before D-Day or
Beyond Mr Speaker this should be a
historic day for the future of our
country and Parliament this was once the
Chamber of Winston Churchill and Clement
Atley instead it is a day of high farce
and self delusion the government
pressing ahead with the deal they've
known for weeks is dead the leadership
of my former party offering the illusion
of an election when they have no chance
of winning a no confidence vote the No
Deal Camp who have no regard for the
impact this would have on our
constituents in The Last Chance Saloon
it's incumbent on us to seek a pragmatic
compromise which can secure a majority
in this house and in all political
parties I don't care whether this is
presented by the government or
facilitated by this house putting brexit
back to the people would be an
abdication of our responsibility it has
nothing to do with breaking a log Jam
and everything to do with seeking to
reverse the result of the first
referendum it will further divide our
country when we should be leading and
healing
I cannot support this worst of all worst
deals and I genuinely believe that the
only option which can secure now a
majority in this house is a common
market too at its core a very simple
idea that can we can be out of the
political structures of the EU but
maintain our economic and security
partnership this will require a
radically reworked political declaration
based on EA and EA after tonight this
should form the basis of the prime
minister's new NE negotiating position
or alternatively the house will have to
take control and seek a pragmatic
compromise Comm a market to or something
else our Duty Mr Speaker is to lead and
to heal this divided
nation
more it's a pleasure to follow the
honorable gentleman and it's an honor to
be taking part in the debate at AC
Crossroads in our history in 2016 the
British people voted to leave the
European Union and the government and
this Parliament needs to respect those
wishes I accept Mr Speaker that there
are passionate views on both sides and
speaking for myself I've always treated
those with differing views with respect
but it is wrong for some to suggest that
most people didn't know what they were
voting for many of those that espoused
those views really think that the people
of this country should not have been
given that decision in the first place
it is my belief that those are calling
for a second referendum are seeking to
damage our democracy as no decision by
the British people would mean anything
anymore because once a decision was
reached those that were not happy would
try to undo it and this might go on
again and again and again and again now
division is healthy in a democracy and
in our political process but a second
referendum I believe would take our
country to Breaking Point and undermine
the dignity in our democracy the
withdrawal agreement does allow for some
control to be taken back and Mr Speaker
I do respect that the the Endeavors of
the Prime Minister she has made a major
commitment to this her perseverance is
commendable and her diligence
unquestionable there is only one point I
wish to make on this withdrawal
agreement and that is on the Northern
Ireland back stop the inclusion of the
back stop is perhaps the most potent
aspect of this agreement given the fact
it poses a real threat to the Integrity
of of our United Kingdom while some have
tried to allay the fears with optimism
more concerning are those that have
displayed a parochial indifference that
fails to recognize our role as United
Kingdom members of parliament acting in
the interest of the whole United Kingdom
yeah yeah the British people did not
vote to have the foundations of our
nation to be undermined in any way and
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I'll never forget
Warren who I first met as an apprentice
moving into the house a little Victorian
terorist house with his partner saying
that as a consequence of having got a
job in the Jaguar plant uh good and
well-paid job he was moving into the
house of his dreams with the woman of
his dreams uh the plant and the success
of Jaguar Land Rover has transformed the
lives of thousands including in my
constituency erdington rich in talent
but one of the poorest in the country
the company producing 108,000 cars a
year at the heart of the Midland's
economy now absolutely key is the
relationship with Europe half their
Market is in Europe if they had to fall
back on World Trade Organization terms
it would put up prices of cars they sell
between three and
£5,000 the millions of Parts every day
the thousands of lorries the
frictionless trade that relationship
which has been absolutely key to the
success of the automotive industry in
our country and Ralph Smith the
inspiring chief executive together with
the whole industry warned of the
consequences of what happens if we don't
get it right what was the response of
some of the honorable members opposite
honorable member for axbridge f business
honorable member for harage and North
Essex he's making it up honorable member
for Oxbridge again not sure that Ralph
knows more about the automotive industry
than I do and The Honorable member for
chingford saying not one job will be
lost as a consequence of brexit what
planet do they live on and that's why
two things a key this is not a good deal
but first we have to get to a good deal
that works for Britain we have to get to
to that honoring the obligation uh that
we gave to the people of Britain at the
time of the referendum but secondly in
the meantime there can be no question of
a No Deal brexit and the words of Ralph
spith no to no deal because to go over
the cliff on the 29th of March without a
deal would be utterly catastrophic for
our
country
M of my constituents voted to leave and
so did I it may be unfashionable but I
will be supporting the government
tonight because after the sophistry
chicer and obfuscation of last week I
genuinely feel that we may not have
brexit at all the adant the Attorney
General is absolutely right to say that
there is risk in the back stop we need
to drisk the back stop my Amendment
would have done that had it been
selected ad would would as would the
amendment table in the name of my right
honorable friend the member for East
Devon the Amendments B and F had pretty
much the same effect since they would
introduce a time limit I commend them to
the government uh Mr Speaker uh in 2006
people weren't being thick or stupid or
ignorant they weren't overwrought they
weren't racist they weren't prejudiced
they were not needing to be given a
second chance and they were not
anguished in the words of the right
honorable gentleman the member for Le
Central they just wanted to leave they
are sovereign we serve them let's get on
with it Adrian
Bailey speaker the Attorney General
opened this debate by saying this debate
was
ineluctable the fact is it wasn't it
only became ineluctable when the Prime
Minister failing to recognize the need
to build a consensus across the country
country and in Parliament started to
adopt language which was inflammatory
about the EU red lines which ruled out
much needed conditions for any
settlement that would help our
manufacturing industry and indeed the
situation with the Irish Border and also
opposed any parliamentary involvement in
the process by doing so she alienated a
body of people in this house and across
the country which she would need to
build the necessary consensus to get a
deal that would be acceptable vot of
Parliament and the country Mr Speaker I
represent a
constituency which voted 70% brexit I'm
a remainer I don't pretend it's a
comfortable position to be I voted to
trigger article 50 because I felt I had
to honor the reference
result and I've Been Loved heavily to
say that as a representative I should do
what my constituency wanted the problem
is I'm also being lobed on people who
want a Better Health Service access to
the doctor they're worried about their
jobs of a Jagua Land Rover they're
worried about policing and the rise of
crime in the locality and I know that
all these which I equally obliged to
deliver will be jeopardized by V for
this particular settlement because it
does not give us what we have now what
we need is for this to be defeated the
prime minister to extend um article 50
and for a consensus to be reached in the
uring
months speaker I would have liked to
have been able to support uh the
government's motion this evening uh I
voted rain uh and uh certainly I have
deep concerns about this whole process
but I have looked at the whole issue of
the back stop and I have been consistent
in this respect which is why uh an
amendment was tabled in my name which
was not selected and indeed a similar
rather better Amendment building on mine
from my right honorable friend the
member for westrey chairman of the
northern Island Affairs select committee
but that wasn't selected either and I
just cannot reconcile myself uh as an MP
in this house that I can vote this
evening to effectively commit this
country into a back stop from which it
has no unilateral right to withdraw so
it is with a heavy heart that I shall
not be supporting the government this
evening because I believe there is still
a deal a fair deal to be done with the
European Union there is a good deal
which respects all our peoples and all
our Industries and all our businesses
there is a deal to be done but Mr
Speaker this is not that deal Neil gray
Mr Speaker I wish to set out why I'm to
vote against the prime minister's deal I
start from the position of respecting
the result of the EU referendum in
Scotland the people of Scotland
resoundingly rejected the idea of brexit
and according to the polls continue to
reject brexit and the prime minister's
deal in even greater numbers I know
wonder it has all been about
self-interest for this prime minister
and the Tory party she triggered article
50 without a plan she held a snap
general election for her own
self-interest but lost her majority she
ignored the Scottish government's offer
of a compromise which would have carried
the house she set herself red lines
aimed at satisfying her extreme
brexiteer back Benes but boxed her into
an impossible corner and left her facing
a no vote confidence vote anyway failing
to prepare is preparing to fail and
that's why I think the biggest mistake
was triggering Article 50 when she
didn't hadn't done her homework she
tipped The Hourglass with no plan no
idea no backing and today two years on
as the Sands start to run out nothing
has changed she has no credible plan no
idea and no backing and now she was
trying to make it a Hobson's choice in
order to deflect from the politically
inconvenient choices that do remain or
open to us she should request an
extension to article 50 to allow people
to have their say but the Tory
leadership aren't the only ones to have
acted purely out of self-interest in
this process the leader of the
opposition wants to renegotiate brexit
but won't say what he would renegotiate
he wants a general election but doesn't
have a plan to achieve one and won't say
what his brexit policy is going to be he
can't decide whether to back another EU
referendum and doesn't know if he would
campaign for leave or remain in
conclusion it could have been so
different on radio Scotland this morning
The Honorable member for Easter rightly
encouraged the prime minister to ignore
the extreme brexiteers sadly his very
sensible advice was 2 years too late the
sanss of time have moved on instead the
warnings of it of brexit leading to a
greater chance of Independence are
becoming a self-fulfilling
prophecy Dr Caroline Johnson thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I voted to leave
my constituents voted to leave the
country voted to leave and leave we must
country but I say to my fellow
brexiteers in this house that we must
accept that we are a majority in the
country but we are not a majority in
Parliament if I give an analy we are 10
players on a pitch playing a team of 11
the odds are now even further stacked
against us since the referee has
demonstrated he's prepared to change the
rules this deal is not perfect and I am
concerned particularly about the
indefinite nature of the back stop
but the risk of not supporting a steel
as demonstrated last week is that
members of this house will think to
water down even this brexit or to stop
it all together I will support this deal
because once the withdrawal agreement is
signed the door to remain will shut
firmly and we can all come back together
and focus on delivering the best future
for the UK outside of the
EU changed any rules of the debate what
I have done is I've chaired the debate
from start to finish facilitating every
honorable and right honorable member of
every conceivable humor opinion to have
every opportunity to put his or her view
it's a point so blindingly obvious and
so transparently fair that all
reasonable people would I think accept
it Karen
Smith thank you Mr my constituency of
Bristol South voted 53 to 47% remain and
the closeness of that vote is something
I have sought to represent and
understand since but the Prime Minister
can't say that they will be better off
the best I've been told even in private
by brexiteers that there will be a
period of uncertainty for some 15 or so
years and then we will perhaps know
we've made the right decision that is a
Monumental leap into the unknown that I
will not make for my family and I will
not make it for my constituency and it
is a shocking dereliction of
responsibility by the Prime Minister
that she asks us to do so I want to talk
briefly about our precious you I Mr
Speaker the word precious means of Great
Value not to be wasted or treated
carelessly but this government has
treated this Union carelessly not only
have the last 2 and a half years done
nothing to heal the 4852 division but
they have done nothing to bring together
the views and interests of people across
this Union and only let out the
destructive Nationalist and separatist
Genies out of the bottle and caused
Great uncertainty across our land the
prime minister has not even done what
her predecessor said and involved the
devolved Executives the government and
the regional powerhouses properly in her
negotiations there seems to be a glimmer
of hope from last week the latest brexit
secretary started talking about
targeting Regional assemblies and the
governments that's not the sort of toner
approach we need that is more of the
same if the government is to salvage
anything from the last 2 and a half
years then they must recognize the
mutual interests of all our people
across the constituent parts of the
United Kingdom and they need to start
treating the English cities and regions
with a modicum of respect they have to
start healing this country Leo doti
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise Mr Speaker
to support this deal and I do so I do
say as someone who voted to leave the
European Union like 58% of my
constituents because Mr Speaker in my
judgment this deal is the only sane and
sensible path to an orderly brexit that
will allow us Mr Speaker to reset our
relations with the European Union not as
an unwilling member of the federal Club
but as a a close friend in Ally when we
do this reset Mr Speaker we must bear in
mind the positive Vision laid out by S
Winston Churchill in Zurich in
1946 when he implored a Europe that had
been ravaged by War to unite for the
sake of peace and he famously exclaimed
Mr Speaker that we should let Europe
arise the role of Great Britain he said
Mr Speaker should be as a friend and
sponsor of the new Europe and we must be
its champion and it's uh Champion its
right to live and to shine that positive
M Vision Mr Speaker still applies today
and that should guide our relations with
our European friends in the future and
more than that Mr Speaker it should
guide our relations with countries
Beyond Europe and it should guide our
role on the world stage more than ever
before in the new era Mr Speaker we must
be more confident more positive more
International and more Global than ever
before and we should be confident in the
ability of British Commerce British
culture British diplomacy and British
law to have a far-reaching highly
positive impact around the world but to
do that Mr Speaker we must make the
first step of achieving the prize of
brexit and the first step Mr Speaker is
passing this withdrawal agreement and I
will be supporting this tonight thank
you
Joanna
Cherry yesterday the Prime Minister
wondered what the history books will
make of all of this I'd like to venture
a few suggestions she will be remembered
as the Prime Minister who has presided
over the biggest failure of government
and leadership in the United Kingdom in
modern times here here instead of having
the moral courage to face up to the fact
that the EU referendum was one on the
back of lies and fraud she has instead
set out to achieve the unachievable a
deal better than the deal we currently
enjoy in doing so she has ignored the
weight of expert evidence she has
ignored the economic assessments of her
own government and
advisors and she has presided over over
a regime so incompetent and questionable
that No Deal government contracts are
being awarded without competitive
tendering to dubious entities without
any legal justification whatsoever and
she spent hundreds of thousands of
pounds on taxpayers money trying to
prevent us from knowing the answer to
the question of whether article 50 could
be unilaterally revoked she barely has
the confidence of her own party and they
only put up with her because none of
them have the gumption to step up to the
plate to sort out this mess correct it's
likely that she soon won't have the
confidence of this house and in Scotland
she's never had our confidence and she
never will yeah she should not take the
Scots for fools the majority of us voted
to remain and the majority of Scots now
realize that they were lied to during
the 2014 Independence
referendum those lies Mr Speaker were
that Scotland was an equal partner and
that the only way to guarantee staying
in the EU was to vote to stay in the UK
the results of referendums one on the
back of Lies cannot stand and that's why
I'm voting down the steel I want a
second EU referendum and there should
also be a a second Scottish independence
referendum mik word you Mr Speaker I
plan to support Amendment Q this evening
because the safeguards sought on the
back stop are necessary and supported by
a substantial number of members I shall
now be voting for the similar Amendment
Ted by my honorable friends for basilon
and biller Ricki I arrived in
Westminster yesterday expecting to
resign today as a pps2 vote against the
motion whil there is much to support in
the withdrawal agreement and future
partnership under a prolonged back stop
we couldn't take back uh the control
that I campaigned for in the referendum
and the 71% of my constituents in Dudley
South voted for that hasn't changed it
still worries me however I've concluded
that there is now a much greater threat
to brexit that my constituents voted for
events over the past week show that
there are
in this house who will stop at little to
frustrate rexit leaving no convention
and no established practice of this
house
safe I cannot risk those who have never
accepted the referendum result stealing
the brexit that my constituents and
voters around the country voted for in
record numbers my constituents aren't
stupid they weren't misled they knew
what that they were voting to Take Back
Control of laws our borders our trade
and our money they knew it wouldn't be
plain sailing but they knew it was a
battle worth fighting they expect us to
deliver I don't expect this motion to
pass tonight and so the government must
listen to genuine concerns across this
house and the deal that it comes back to
this house with must genuinely take back
the control the people voted for in 2016
I will support that work starting
tonight in this evening's vote it's the
last chance and our best chance we have
to deliver on the promise of brexit and
our democracy desperately needs it to
succeed thank you Paul Sweeney thank you
Mr Speaker this is uh today is the last
day of my 20s and uh as I reflect back
on the last decade I have to wonder how
did I end up here and uh how did the
country end up here in this Almighty fle
frankly um and it seems to me that the
root cause of a lot of of our problems
in this country is one of economic
alienation economic alienation caused by
a crisis of neoliberalism one that has
failed the poorest people in our society
and we try to identify the root cause of
a lot of the problems that erupted in
the vote of so many people in this
country to leave the European Union and
also looking back as a veteran of two
referendum campaigns of uh so many
people voting to leave the United
Kingdom as well it can only be in my
opinion put down to the fact that the
established structures in this country
have failed to deliver prosperity and
security for so many people in our
country when I look at my own
constituency where only 51% of people
participated in the EU referendum it
seems to me that many people have
disengaged with the political process
entirely and that is something that we
have to take cognisance of in this house
if we're really going to repair the
trust in our political system between
those who vote for us as representatives
in this place and the body politic at
large in this country who many many
cases have disengaged with our political
process simply by talking about a deal
talking about no deal isn't going to
heal that Rift in our democracy we have
to much have a much greater and more
thoughtful approach to how we heal this
division in our society and how we do it
and I don't think that the Prime
Minister who has just joined us is
equipped to do that and she's failed
miserably in her efforts and her
partisan approach and delivering this
deal we must adapt and deliver for the
young people of this country including
myself who have to face the future of
the consequences of this action of this
house and this prime minister she must
rise to the occasion and so far she has
failed miserably to do
so kir in
ha the British people directed us to
take the United Kingdom out of the
European Union and it's our duty to put
that to effect we must not tell them to
vote again until they give a different
answer or deliver a non brexit that
keeps in the EU in all but name there
are clear opportunities and we must
embrace them
no parliamentarian is 100% comfortable
with what's in front of us that was
inevitable for a whole host of reasons
including no clear direction for the
outcome of a lead boat but too often
self-interest takes over the
decision-making process with the SNP
determined to force a No Deal situation
in the hope that that would accelerate
their case for Independence myself and
my fellow Scottish conservative aamps
and I've always been robust when it
comes to our support for the fishing
industry no one can say that that
industry has not been pragmatic when it
comes to our departure from the EU
whatever happens today let me be clear
that I will not accept any extension of
the transition period Beyond December
2020 because we must embrace the Sea of
opportunity that brexit presents to them
absolutely right I also had concerns
around the northern Irish back stop and
it's with deep disappointment that we
have not reached a technological
solution to date I would have also felt
much more comfortable with an end date
on the establishment of a future
economic partnership but Mr Speaker this
decision for me is about my businesses
my constituents those that I represent a
deal is a negotiation with a large dose
of pragmatism and having spoken to many
of my largest employers my constituents
knocked on their doors and stood in the
supermarket what they want is
uncertainty removed Mr Speaker the
withdrawal agreement may not be perfect
but it does deliver on the decision does
it deliver on the decision taken by the
people of our United Kingdom in 2016 yes
does it return full control of our
borders as so many people wished yes
does it provide long-term stability for
businesses our farmers and our fishermen
yes and of all the option on the table
this agreement is the one with the most
in the National interest Mr Speaker I
believe that it is and that's why I'll
be supported the deal
tonight thank you Mr Speaker it's a
pleasure to follow the member frangus
for a thoughtful speech albeit one who
thrust I must say I cannot agree with
over 2,000 of my constituents in Oxford
East have contacted me about this this
deal and only a handful say they support
it and I agree with them I can't support
it for four reasons first of all it
gives an adequate protection for our EU
citizens who are our neighbors our
friends and our workmates I see the
Prime Minister looking at me but she
will know that I have had a repeated
communication with her and the Secretary
of State over many many weeks trying to
get confirmation over the exact criteria
for settled status we still don't have
that Clarity that we need and that's now
coupled with an arbitrary salary level
for those coming to our country for the
EU which will starve our hospitals and
our universities and many other
employers of the staff they desperately
need I can't support it because of that
secondly I can't support it because of
inadequate plans in that deal for
research cooperation into the future so
essential for the two universities and
my constituency FL I can't support it
because of insufficient certainty on
Customs huge farms very important
manufacturers like BMW Cy in my
constituency they don't just need
certainty for two years they need it for
20 and they certainly don't get on this
deal and finally there are no legally
binding guarantees in this deal to stop
a race to the bottom on environmental
standards or working rights this deal
has got to be voted down and after such
a failure of leadership this government
must go if it won't then all options
should be on the table including a third
public vote to find a way
for our country but whatever the process
all of us parliamentarians here need to
remember we're the ones who have power
we have power not those vulnerable
people affected by the politics of hate
out in our country we have that
responsibility and we must always reject
that hate the unest is on us thank
you there's a peculiar irony Mr Speaker
isn't there to the fact that today marks
the anniversary
in
1535 of Henry VII styling himself
Supreme head of the English church 500
years on here we are arguing over the
same questions of who rules on what
Authority now stop the clock order order
very unseemly atmosphere The Honorable
gentleman must and will be heard Alex
spart thank you very much Mr Speaker 500
years on we find ourselves still arguing
about our relationship with Europe and
who rules I have little confidence that
500 years from now we will have resolved
these
questions tonight and in the weeks to
come the house has three choices it can
make there can be a deal there can be no
deal or we can stay in the European
Union if it is not this deal then it
must be another deal and by all the
rumors going round that deal will be
worse than the one on the table it will
keep us more closely aligned to the EU
and give us less say in fact it will be
worse staying in the EU those people who
W the house who want to stay in the EU
hide behind the idea of a second
referendum well those honorable members
who think the first referendum was
devises divisive goodness me they
haven't seen anything yet absolutely it
is time if those members in the house
who want us to stay in the EU believe it
they should call on this house to have a
vote to revoke article 50 but they won't
do that so the deal before us is what we
have and this is a deal which treated
right and taken in the right direction
will give us control of our borders our
laws our Waters and our trading
opportunities time we have had time
enough to go over these issues it is
time now for the house to make a
decision I will vote for the deal for
tonight and let's move
[Applause]
on thank you Mr Speaker I didn't come
into Parliament to spend my time working
on the future of the European Union it's
not what my constituents when they
elected me first in 2010 intended me to
spend my time on either they wanted me
to concentrate on their living standards
their security the future for their
children and grandchildren and a better
planet for the future of our world but
actually all of these things are
encompassed in the decision we make
tonight and about our commitment to our
ongoing relationship with our European
Union neighbors and I will not vote for
a deal that will make my constituents
poorer that will make them less secure
that will mean that we have less
influence in decisions that are taken
that will affect them and that will
reduce our standing our our highly
respected and highly regarded standing
in the world I am distressed as all
honorable members members are at the
divisions that this brexit story has
revealed opened up in our country but
our duty now is to concentrate on
healing them and I do not believe it
will ever be possible to do that if we
deliberately make our country poorer and
more unstable and less influential than
it would otherwise have been we need to
concentrate on building a positive
prosperous powerful future for this
nation voting to leave the EU and voting
for the prime minister's way of leaving
tonight will not enable us to do
so that woman the speaker mine is the
constituency that voted more than any
other to leave the European Union in
2016 if we do not give back control of
our laws borders and money it will be
hard to say that this country is a
democracy the people in 2016 heard all
the apocalyptic predictions that we now
hear about WTO and they made a choice
and in part the country did that because
Parliament had rightly or wrongly come
to be seen as out of touch with the
people on a host of issues if we don't
deliver what the people voted for we
will prove them right and we will damage
a democracy further in which people
already lack Faith so how do we get
there it is clear that this house does
not want to back a No Deal departure it
has already been clear that people on
both sides of this house will vote to
stop it so I say to those of my
constituents who have called me a
traitor and worse that when I vote with
the Prime Minister tonight I do so
because I am committed to brexit and
voting against this deal puts winds in
the saes of those who seek to stop it
those people have had too much success
already voting against this deal will
not bring a a harder brexit it will
bolster this House's dangerous attempts
to undermine it those who say no deal is
in law and will happen I say to them
this house will rewrite that law I am
voting tonight for the only way out of
this conundrum a necessary Gateway
however painful it might be there is a
risk that we get stuck in the back stop
but it is now smaller than the risk of
not leaving at all we in Parliament are
better than letting the people down we
deserve to get on with it to deliver
this brexit and we should like it or not
in many cases support this deal
tonight I am going to be incredibly
parochial in the general election of
2017 my personal Manifesto to the voters
of North GS had said and I quote I am
working for a brexit right for North
dors that will support business protect
jobs and workers rights promote local
farming Safeguard the environment and
give opportunities for our young having
reviewed the deal I am confident that it
meets those commitments and the
referendum decision to Le we live as we
know in a representative democracy where
the voters of North Dorset send me to
Westminster to exercise my judgment and
support the policies of the conservative
government I do not and none of us do
possess the Judgment of Solomon all I
can try and do is to assure them that I
am trying to do my best for them and for
our country and I am conscious that in
so doing I will not please everyone but
I do not think that is the purpose of
politics I'm a Democrat I voted remain
and my side lost y the referendum was
not as we know our fine our finest Hour
the majority of the house has made clear
that it would support the decision and
Parliament would deliver it I maintain
that view a second referendum is fool's
gold our country's use of referendum is
on constitutional issues and brexit is
now an issue of domestic policy my right
honorable friend the Prime Minister has
worked if I may say so her fingers to
the Bone to get this deal right it has
my full and unequivocal support to
deliver brexit to maintain and the faith
in our democracy this house should stop
the postering and support my right
horable friend in the lobby
tonight
B the UK is to leave the EU that
decision was taken two years ago the
question is whether we crash out or
support the withdrawal agreement
followed by the period of transition and
the future Arrangements on trade and
relationships ass soon assuming we're
not trying to reverse the referendum and
there isn't a majority I think either in
the country or in the house for that the
majority of us support the prime
minister's deal the majority of
conservative supporters support that I
suspect the majority of Labor supporters
support that and other parties given a
choice including Northern Ireland would
as
well our responsibility is to find where
there's an overlap between what's
possible and what's right I believe that
the negotiation agreement on withdrawal
is that position for the opposition to
be reasonably polite they seem to
resemble members of the Scarab family
who are upside down pushing in the wrong
direction don't quite know where they're
going if the choice of the country is
between chaos and compromise I think
this agreement is the right way of being
sensible and I back the plan in the
National interest thank you Jeremy
Corin thank you Mr Speaker this this has
been a vitally important debate for the
future of our country and our future
relationship with the European Union
following the decision of the people in
the 2016 referendum the debate today is
the culmination of one of the most
chaotic and extraordinary parliamentary
processes I've ever experienced in my 35
years as a member of this house
Parliament has held the government in
contempt for the first time ever for
failing to publish their legal advice
yes then for the first time in a
generation or more on the 10th of
December a government failed to move its
own business in the house the government
has been defeated on a vote in its own
finance bill for the first time since
the
1970s the Prime Minister opened the
debate on her deal more than one month
ago a debate that was due to end on the
11th of December but she pulled it in a
panic
as she herself conceded it would have
been rejected by a significant
margin she has run down the clock in a
cynical attempt to Strongarm members
into backing her
deal despite her promises she's failed
to negotiate any changes to her deal
with Europe no wonder no wonder the
Prime Minister has suddenly discovered
the importance of trade
unions she voted to clip their wings in
the 2016 Trade union act and she's
utterly failed to convince them she has
anything to offer Britain's Workforce
and this Mr Speaker is the heart of the
matter the Prime Minister has treated
brexit as a matter for the conservative
party rather than the good of the
country but she's failed to win over
even her own party many conservative
members who voted remain are opposed to
this deal as are dozens of conservative
members who voted
leave after losing her majority in the
2017 general election the Prime Minister
could have engaged with members across
this house she could have listened to
the voices of trade unions and if she
had been listening both businesses and
trade Unions would have told her they
wanted a comprehensive and permanent
Customs Union to secure jobs and
trade the decision to rule out a new
Customs Union with a British say and the
lack of certainty in the deal risks
business investment being deferred on an
even greater scale threatening jobs and
threatening living standards or even
worse it risks many companies relocating
abroad taking jobs and investment with
them Mr Speaker many workers know
exactly this
situation
because they are facing These reality
this reality now their jobs are at risk
and they know their jobs are at R risk
both the first Ministers of Wales and
Scotland have also made clear to the
prime minister they support for a
customs Union to protect jobs and the
economy this day deal fails to provide
any certainty about future trade it
fails to guarantee our participation in
European agencies and
initiatives losing this cooperation
undermines our security denies our
citizens opportunity and damages our
Industries Mr Speaker the withdrawal
agreement is in short a reckless leap in
the
dark it takes this country no closer to
understanding our post brexit future and
neither does the future partnership
document under this deal in December
2020 we will be faced with a choice
either pay more and extend the
transition period or Lo us into the back
stop at that point the UK would be over
a barrel we would have left the EU have
lost the UK and be forced to pay
whatever was
demanded
alternatively the back stop would come
into Force an arrangement with which
there is no time limit or Endo it locks
Britain into a deal from which it cannot
leave without the agreement of the EU
and as my friend the member of hob and
and pangas has pointed out on so many
occasions this is unprecedented in
British
history the last two years gives us no
confidence that this government can do a
deal in under two years so at some point
before December 2020 the focus would
then inevitably shift from negotiations
on the future relation ship to
negotiations on an extension to the
transition period including negotiations
on what further payments we should make
to the European
Union the vague partnership document
says and I quote it can lead